foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
people to me the chance Rook F7 oh no
no
[Music]
foreign
land of fjords Majestic mountains Cliffs
and waterfalls
in addition to stunning geography Norway
is home to the greatest chess player who
has ever lived Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best
from Carlson's fiercest online rival
today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps lodibeck Abdul
sotorov and kukesh domaraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023 Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana two more longtime
Headliners seek to take their next turn
Atop A major tournament Wesley so and
Shakira mamat yarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field who will
come out on top will Carlson run the
table yet again or will someone else
usurp the throne this is Norway chess
it's a beautiful day here in Stavanger
and we are all buzzing with excitement
as we return to the gripping action that
is Norway chess the players have
recharged after their rest day and the
stage is set and all those battles are
about to begin so get ready and let the
chess commence I'm your host
International Master Ivanka houska and
it's a great pleasure to be here in the
studio alongside Superstar Grand Master
Judith poga and of course legendary
Grandmaster and commentator David Howell
yesterday it was a free day but we have
seen three rounds of action due date
what have been the highlights for you
there are a lot of highlights so I don't
start because I cannot finish until the
evening but if I have to pick two things
first of all I'm very interested how
Fabiano will continue because he looks
extremely solid very balanced here and
just to pick a game from round three it
was very impressive for me how firoza
turned over a little bit unpleasant
position with black against up the
software of it was some very interesting
moments there yeah definitely there's
have been some highlights and David the
players themselves had arrested
yesterday how do you think they will be
feeling today I'm hoping they feel
refreshed and ready to continue fighting
but they've been so impressive up to
this point and it's just hard to imagine
just continuing uh in this vein of form
and uh yeah I know the players they will
have been doing different things I think
we'll be revealing later on one of their
activities on the rest day but I'm
hoping that they were studying some
chess that they've come ready to fight
again yeah it's been great so far and
along May that continue long may that
continue and let's recap on Thursday's
results and there was an epic match up
there at the top hikara Nakamura losing
to Magnus Carlsen in the Armageddon and
then another notable result was Fabiana
carono racing to the top with this ideal
start against orientare what other
results catch caught your eye on that
day Judith
wow which one I mean I mentioned already
of course the alireza game which was
very impressive to me and also how
gokish was playing extremely well
against mametero because in the
classical game it was a draw and then
the Armageddon was really exciting of
course with mom and jarowitz all the
time he had a fantastic position winning
position and then somehow the the
youngster could turn things around and
even win the game yeah and David I have
to ask you what's your favorite the
classical part or the Armageddon
normally I'm a classical guy I prefer
classical chess but the armageddon's
have been a lot of fun too especially
seeing Magnus and Hikaru go at it in a
king's Gambit just before the rest day
so uh yeah this format is just bringing
out the best in both formats definitely
and let's take a look at the standings
because there is one person who is at
the top of the table with some very
impressive play that is Fabiana Carana
with seven and a half points out of of
nine in second place we have alireza
farooja Hikaru Nakamura in third place
with five points out of nine and someone
who really desperately needs to take
some weight victories in their classical
games is Magnus Carlson and of course
Wesley so both of them on three points
out of nine and three and a half points
out of nine but there is everything to
play for because take a look at today's
matchups it is no HS after all and at
the top of the table we have good cash
against Magnus Carlson and we have to
remember kukash was the youngest player
in the world to have ever beaten Magnus
Carlson any other result a matchups that
uh you're eagerly anticipating do it
obviously the one you just mentioned it
is something we want to look a lot I
think I'm very curious but also about
alireza Fabiano game I'm very very
curious they are on the top of the
leather board so it's it's so
interesting how they are going to be
playing and look at ferozo he's he
really made it played a great game in
Iran Street he did and for you David
yeah I think all is going to be on those
two runaway leaders and uh for Asia with
white we know he takes huge risks we
know he's a maximalist I think he's
going to put Fabiano under some serious
pressure but of course yeah we will keep
an eye on others uh all of the games
including gokesh against Magnus uh I
just can't wait to see how both of them
do after that resting yeah I certainly
can't wait because this is Norway chess
and Norway chess is known for its very
unique tournament format it's never
really been done in anywhere else in the
world and it brings out the best in the
players it's a 10 player single round
robin
120 minutes for the entire game it
sounds like a lot but it really isn't 10
second move increment is again the
players get after move 40 and in the
event over draw Armageddon will break
the tie and of course this is the home
of Fighting Chess so no draw offers
allowed before move 30.
this one is going to be so exciting
I mean we have seen a lot of absolutely
thrilling games so far haven't we
I don't recall any boring games so far
in the tournament other than maybe the
classical clash between Magnus and
Hikaru but uh that was a pragmatic
decision for both and here we do see
kukesh getting ready to face the former
world champion Magnus Carlsen now Anish
Gary with white we haven't mentioned him
but he's facing Hikaru Nakamura who
takes his seat another big Clash both
players really wanting to win in the
classical portion to try and catch up
with the leaders actually we could say
that of everyone everyone needs to start
winning in classical to catch up with
Fabiana at this point absolutely the
this format makes it extremely
interesting that it's okay to win an
Armageddon but let's face it it's only
one and a half point right so it's just
a little bit more than than
losing the Armageddon because who loses
in Armageddon gets one point so really a
classical win it's a real way of
catching up with the others so someone
wins too classical game from number
seven he's number one in the tournament
exactly and I think Anish Gary said it
himself you know this format actually is
very much dependent on those points and
like you say one class could win Nets
you three points and that's it you zoom
up the standings and there we see Ali
Reza farouza getting ready to face off
against Fabiana caruana and Ariane who's
having a tough time of it I have to say
against Wesley so now how is it I mean
what advice would you give to someone
when you're facing a rather difficult
opponent
well I was so sorry for tari when he he
could not win and convert his very great
game against abdulsator of in round two
because there he he really gave out a
great deal of his knowledge and he made
some good calculations but in the final
moment where he could collect the point
it was not good for him so I think it's
very difficult to digest something like
this and he knows it and he knew it of
course before the event that he's the
underdog in the event he played here
before at the same time it's extremely
difficult to get your energy from day by
day again to fight I'm sure he has to
who he has to understand that he has to
be focusing he has to be prepared to
play
and uh forget about the result
completely and uh sorry I just saw on
the camera that that Magnus Carlsen has
arrived with a new look he shaved off
his beard wow
who would have thought that the 17 year
old go cash would be uh the Harrier of
the two here Magnus it shows he means
business he shows uh he wants a fresh
start after that rest day something
wasn't right right something wasn't
working for him and we know the players
they're superstitious they want to make
a change
it seems like he did his preparation
yeah if that was the only preparation he
did maybe it was a good move nonetheless
Magnus Carlson wow is that unsettling
for good cash you know your opponent
turns up with a rather radical new look
it can be I I do remember as well during
the 2021 world championship match with
Magnus and Jan Napoli Yan was the one uh
having a haircut halfway through that
match when things weren't going his way
and obviously that didn't work out in
the end but uh it showed he meant
business and we're off the games have
just started we see gokesh open with one
E4 and what do we think Magnus is going
to go for I was going to say C5 but then
he reached for the King's Pawn and up
the playing in a very classical way
solid start do you think we'll see the
Marshall attack again Judith that
brought him a draw against no way
something more competent I think so he
will go for some complicated
yeah and uh there we can see to the left
of the board that we have a very very
fancy new feature it is the win draw
loss bar and your you can see there the
percentages whether it is actually or a
fighting game so the more it is in the
gray portion it means that the more
games there have been that have resulted
in draws
and we see an Italian
yeah the Italian and uh well still a
very fighting opening in general the
draw percentage while it's a kind of at
a decent level it's what we expect for
most openings these days and we do see
that white wins a lot of these types of
positions maybe more than black does and
uh Magnus now pondering his next move
Judith do you think he's going to
surprise gokesh his young opponent here
by playing an offbeat move like H6 maybe
the slightly more passive Bishop E7
Bishop C5 uh leads to more Mainline
Waters these days lots of options for
Magnus I don't know what he has in mind
but you can see that shaving his beard
it was already something he shows that
these days
is marked it's like he's changing his
attitude in some ways towards today's
game
wants to have a long game he wants to
he's ready for a battle he's ready ready
for a fight for a long game
and I think it's also interesting for
him to play with the new generation uh
kids because maybe
because I think it's very interesting
for him to to look how they are
developing from day to day he
understands that gokash is extremely
talented uh boy he knows exactly I think
that he's potentially a future world
champion who he's playing with and I
think when you're number one in the
world it's very important for you to
play with new figures new people to
learn from them fresh ideas for example
it was very interesting for me even
looking Nakamura back in his
summary of the game when he played
against him that he was telling on many
moves of kukesh that I was not counting
on this I didn't expect this so it's
also interesting I think that when we
see youngsters around that they do have
new ideas they do have a very fresh look
on the same position which the others
are seeing looking analyzing for years
or maybe even decades but with a
completely new idea so I think this is
also somehow challenging for Magnus and
it's uh it gives him a very positive
feeling that he's playing with someone
who will give new ideas an interesting
game
and there we could see good cash
developing his Bishop out to G5 and
that's the kind of move that invites
Magnus to enter complications with
kicking back the bishop and perhaps even
kicking it back all the way to G3 now
when you consider that gokash is very
much a fighting Dynamic player Is it
wise for Magnus to enter into such a
Battleground
well that's the thing with the Italian
game these days you're pretty much
obliged to enter that uh fighting
Battleground as you call it Ivanka uh
with this pin is just so annoying for
black to deal with at some point you
will have to break the pin at some point
modern Grandmasters they tend to play G5
it's just when you play it you've got to
make sure that it doesn't backfire and
just until a moment ago we did see the
wind draw lost bar and uh here we see it
again uh here white does have a very
decent uh win percentage but so does
black it is that type of position where
anything can happen
I do have a feeling a drawer isn't that
likely a result here just from my own
experience it tends to work very well
for white if black cannot break this pin
in a satisfactory manner but it can
backfire on black uh sorry it can back
fire on white so if you do kind of find
black able to push G5 and start
attacking on the king side it's
is something that I've never really
understood these types of positions
computers always say level 0.0 but uh
that tells that fails to tell the whole
story too in fact the win draw loss bar
seems to suggest all three results
completely possible
yes because I think this is the type of
position also that the better wins in
some way but also of course you have to
understand the nuances in the position
because it is also sometimes uh not the
same if you play G5 and white castled
already or you play G5 and White Castle
so it's uh it's it's it's always a
debate whether is he going to play G5
now or he's going to play Queen E7 or
some Preparatory move before that so
it's a provocation and it's uh you know
it's the tension whether G5 now and then
Knight H5 possibly but I think that's
not possible
uh G5 Bishop G3 Knight H5 now because
probably some Knight E5 is in there
um yeah maybe we can jump in and show
some typical ideas here Judah as you
mentioned uh G5 Bishop G3 Knight H5 if
you're wondering about and that is the
question right can white jump out the
way and hit this Knight
oh I don't know to be honest these types
of positions are so complicated maybe
white can get away with this C5 93
Knight F7 yeah Knight takes G3 Knight
takes F7 although or even Knight C6 is
possible yeah maybe Knight takes C6 is
the safer of the two and uh in this
position if we just go back one move and
I take C6 and wow the bars are hating
this what could be happening here yeah
this this is a typical tactic
and yeah there's some mating threats
meaning that black gets out of the way
with the queen no attack from the White
Knight and black will win material on H1
next move
yeah this type of tactic is uh quite
typical in these positions but often
white just ignores uh the tension here
even if white can get away with Knight
takes E5 often D4 yeah exactly white
just strikes in the center a move like
D4 breaks out uh so Knight to H5 can
backfire and yeah it's just about when
to push this move do you push with G5
before castling is black do you kind of
wait for white to Castle on this flank
before playing G5 a variety of waiting
moves ding loves to play the move A5 in
this position for example uh our new
world champion he loves to play A5 but
recently he got caught out uh in this
exact variation by Anish giri in Romania
just a couple of weeks ago others such
as grishop like to kind of play Queen E7
and kind of wait and then they play with
stuff like G5 Knight H7 and they re
reroute their knight uh round to G6 it's
so many plans it's Magnus I think
picking now what to go for with black
very complex I've seen a lot of games in
this particular position and very
dynamic so shall we actually go back to
the bird's eye view and have a look at
the other games and there are a few
especially that catch my eye but uh the
one that I wanted to kind of mention
because I have a suspicion that it could
potentially finish quite quickly is the
game between Ari antari and Wesley so
are the players pedaling furiously to a
quick draw
oh it's the martial attack that seems to
be one of the games uh one of the
opening story of the tournament so far
and uh Ivanka you fear that that one
might end early firstly Ariane with the
white pieces it depends on how ambitious
he's feeling but he has taken up uh the
mantle here he has grabbed a pawn whites
are pulling up this is still very
theoretical but it just comes down to
Wesley's homework if Wesley knows his
stuff is black I've studied this
position plenty of times myself uh yeah
he is fine but actually this specific
position there's maybe more to Know Than
some others but I think it it uh it can
be a very smart decision by tari that
okay I've lost I have not much point in
the tournament so far so maybe I want to
slow down I want to make sure that I
play solid game it's okay if I make a
draw even without a huge fight or not a
long game then there is the playoff so
my opponent Wesley obviously will be a
little bit nervous right because
Armageddon is already going to Shorter
thumb control so it can easily decide
the way you don't want to
and uh and maybe he has a different
strategy which is uh which would not be
bad at all I think that he knows that
okay they want to beat him anyway yeah
so he's kind of provoking them that okay
it's a Jewish position come show me that
you really want to win and kill me
Wesley's a hot man to provoke though if
anyone's uh going to be solid it's going
to be Wesley and uh yeah they do say
that you don't want to Castle queenside
in a tournament you don't want three
classical losses in a row uh Ariane has
lost two in a row it would make a lot of
sense to just stem the bleeding with a
draw here but we should point out that
okay black uh did have a big threat
Queen to E1 and Knight D2 is indeed the
main move in this position so white
tonight is going to come back and block
this is a long long forcing variation uh
I was actually planning to play this
with white against Magnus a couple of
months ago but uh he went down a
different path and here what were you
planning David I mean like not in terms
of moves but slight Advantage could you
reveal no was it a draw
I was happy to be a bit of a chicken and
uh make a draw there if Magnus proved he
knows what's going on and of course
Magnus does so
um here there is a pen on the first rank
white needs to be slightly careful uh
otherwise his Queen side pieces might
never come out so there's a couple of
moves but uh Bishop to D1 is one way to
break the pin here dropping back the
white bishop and freeing up its
counterpart uh to come out to D2 next
move
and uh yeah I do believe there's others
available to Ariane so I don't remember
exactly how it goes uh Bishop D1 Black
Goes rookie eight or something Bishop D2
and black goes back with the queen right
it's not so easy to get out
from this kind of passive position for
the right pieces yeah let's uh jump in
maybe show some moves on the board
um you're gonna test my memory here
Judith I don't know I'm just trying to
recall it myself
Bishop D1 probably some rookie eight
yeah I believe there's also B4 in some
positions but let's say rookie eight uh
Bishop D2 black goes back with a queen
we need six okay 26 25 I'm not sure
which one maybe Queen E6 my memory
already here is uh not greyton
H2 by the way possible takes and queen
F1 the D3 phone is hanging
takes
and yeah hitting this Pawn next move and
I believe this is still a line
um even here I think white can give up
opponent have the bishop power and it
Fizzles out to a drawish ending yeah
okay but that's not much that's not what
Ariana wants potentially so after rookie
eight
think if that might be the move G3 here
as well
which means that you're losing a tempo
right before making Bishop D2 just
cutting out your idea there Bishop takes
H2 and now it might be that black plays
the move B4 black needs some counter
play before the queen gets evicted so
after B4 uh now Bishop D2 and
yeah black is forced back and next move
C4 will come and it does get very very
sharp in positions like this one
um so yeah White's pieces aren't great
of course white is a pawn up though and
has something to hold on to so this is
the game position and after okay
because Queen D1 I must admit I'm not
too familiar with this this is the draw
of vertex and Bishop D3 yeah and it's
just to me it looks like you're not
really hoping for much in this position
with white
you can play a move like A4 but it's not
likely to lead anywhere yeah you do have
to remember that in the Armageddon game
If This Were to go Aryan will have to
change it around and play something
completely different
Kings Gambit do you think
yeah
yes but you shouldn't forget that he's
collecting one point so he's doubling
his points which he had so far that's
true so that's already good start and
then he can think which obviously he did
already before this round he was
thinking and toying with the idea that
okay I'm going to be very solid if it's
Marshall I'm going to go for a draw and
then I'm going to do whatever he thought
out but for sure he's not going to go
into this opening yeah and okay so this
one could look like it's heading into a
draw so let's take a look at the bird's
eye view because the other game which
I'm super excited about because it looks
like it's red hot it's between our um
not uh alireza farouza and Fabiana
Carona oh yeah yeah oh yeah
someone's gotten out of bed greedy
of course important for the standings as
well so let's uh zoom out of this game
between tarry and so and let's jump in
to that clash between the leaders it's
crazy as you say Ivanka I'm already
looking that position and I'm thinking
what is going on I could have stronger
words there to express my feelings but
yeah just clueless as to the evaluation
of this position but it does feel like
both players or at least Fabiano are in
Preparation and uh talking about Fabiano
svera caught up with him before the game
so let's check out what Fabiano had to
say
Fabiano you have do you feel you have a
chance for a knockout punch today or are
you very happy with the draw how the
table is looking I'm playing with the
black pieces so I think he's the one who
is going to be trying to put pressure
and we'll see
who knows alireza is a fighter and uh
and we might have a big fight look
forward to it thank you
a big fight was predicted by Fabiano and
it certainly looks like a big fight is
occurring on the board
wow what a mess due date should we go
back from move one and yeah let's see
how it all started
how that fight began it is now move 15
but let's backtrack to the start of this
game it was one E4 and the French
Fabiano taking a leaf out of magnus's
book uh he talked about a big fight he
doesn't want to be solid here despite
having the black pieces and we do see
the classical variation of the French uh
White stepping forward here with his
pawns and here this line with Queen B6
going for the poisoned Pawn the
so-called poison Pawn on B2 just very
ambitious stuff it has a decent
reputation with black this move has
featured in several chessable courses
several books recently it seems to be
holding up here theoretically but you
need to know oceans of theory and uh we
also saw on the win draw lost bar a
second ago that uh this one very
fighting very combative chess here uh
Queen D2 just gifting the pawn and of
course white uh black here has said a so
he has to say B he has to follow through
with his plan take the pawn
meaning the queen gets kicked around and
now at night B5
Let's ignore the question mark given by
the uh by the game by the computer
here sorry uh it looks like a decent
move I'm sure there are others that
might say uh a better evaluation but
this one clearly part of his home
preparation maybe he just feels that
it's more testing for Fabi but uh Fabi
is prepared and now look at this Rook B8
there was a night Fork threatened with
Knight C7 check so getting out of the
way and Black's King
now loses the right to Castle the Knight
comes back so costing two tempo for
white slightly mysterious and Knight to
C5 there is no castle for black in this
game anymore
yeah you would take white here Judith
well I don't know but the question is
whether is it worth giving away two temp
is just for the fact that black ink is
going to be staying in the in the center
of the game yes it uh it is quite a
valuable uh
pink for white of course black wants to
go in it4 which which can be very
powerful it looks extremely scary for
black at the same time these days
working with the engines 24 7 I believe
on top level it means that you can come
up with the risky openings or very much
risky looking openings because of course
in this position if you don't work at
home it looks like uh you get a heart
attack in any second but if you work at
home and you're aware of the dangers and
you know the exact moves how to react
then it can be something uh a very good
choice
now for first comes to mind is the
exchange on C6 and somehow Knight D6 to
me
or maybe immediately there yeah I can
tell you that
this game this position has only been
played once before and there it was a
win for white and it was between two
grand Masters tal albigel and Daniel
Friedman
but uh there white actually played
Bishop D3 the developing move
but I was gonna ask you both farrugia is
a tactical genius he thrives in these
unbalanced positions Is it wise or Fabby
to go into your opponent's strands I
think generally speaking we have to
separate things when you are in the
opening preparation that's a completely
different story when you enter in a
middle game when you're out of the book
already so at this phase it's very clear
that Furby is in the book he knows what
he's doing or he prepared and he's
mentally also prepared to have his King
on d8 and play an extremely sharp game
and he knows it that if he wants to win
the tournament he has to show something
courage and braveness and he has to play
extremely well and you can see that he's
very much in the mood to do so which
which is very interesting to see yeah I
think it's very much influenced by how
the tournaments have been going so far
from Fabi it just shows extreme
confidence which is uh great to see
partly because of his results so far but
it also shows he wants to win this
tournament here and now if he wins
another classical game Fabby his lead is
going to not just be extended but it
might be insurmountable at this early
stage in the game and early stage in the
tournaments and yeah just to play like
this against veruga Ivanka I would not
have the courage I would be trying to
lock down the game and just trying to be
as boring as possible but that's why I'm
not as strong as Fabiano caruana it just
uh I love to see it and that really does
show that no HS is bringing out the best
in these players meanwhile Bishop D3 on
the board okay so continuing uh along
with that game between two grand Masters
but yeah slightly surprising Judith as
you mentioned there were ideas maybe of
going a bit more direct
well at the same time it's interesting
for white how he's developing because if
white can Castle
white has two pawns down right so we
should not forget that at the same time
for black it's very difficult to develop
properly and and really the d8 king is a
huge uh problem or it can be a huge
problem so if white can Castle move away
with the queen play C4 one day for
example that can be incredible
breakthrough and if white is able to do
that might can win the game very fast
and it it can happen that the game would
be even finished in five moves or 10
moves if somebody one of them are not
paying attention and of course after
Castle the Rooks can be moving to A1 B1
so black has to be very fast I believe
in reacting
yeah and and talking about Black's
position
White's play as you've indicated looks
quite natural how on Earth is black
gonna solidify their position soon as
not to allow white this Pawn break
that one we need fabby's help with it is
uh mysterious and I think that's why
farisha he's gone for this whole line in
general we saw the question mark appear
in the graphic earlier but that's not
necessarily because it's bad it's just
because it might not be the computer's
top suggestion but he's banking on the
Practical value here he's banking on the
fact his uh compensation is long term
like you say Judith that black king is
going to be in danger for the next 10 15
moves uh if it survives that long and uh
yeah in terms of moves I mean I want to
play Bishop D7 I'm not sure why but
again that costs one move and suddenly
white gets castled
I'm not sure black has that luxury it's
their way to try and trade Queens I
don't see it yet technically things
aren't working well I I can show you how
the one game in the database continued
at their black simply played Knight
takes Bishop
and I can I can ask you guys whether you
approve or not or disapprove and then
after Queen takes night the queen came
back to A5 and gave a check upon which
white said big deal King F2
wow nice and again it just seemed The
Rook came to be one and it seemed like
white had a very nice grip on Black's
play
yeah this looks scary I've got to say
black has no strong pieces no activity
and it just looks like one-way traffic
the two pawns are irrelevant here to
them
exactly this is exactly the position
which I would be happy to play from the
white side
uh if we go back I think really black
has to be focusing most on his Queen how
to get back to the queen and there right
so probably some simplification grabbing
the bishop must be the move either now
or in the next move I don't see anything
else
but uh I would give a question
for example
what about A6 in the previous move right
because I can take on D3 anytime right
so why not to play A6 before Knight D3
and big question here for why it's the
sound the retreat or go forward for me I
would
you know you've started you might as
well finish right put the Knight into D6
or is yeah I think you're you're not
happy to go back to C3 because then
Queen A5 there is a pin and you're not
active anymore right so it's very clear
that white should be focusing either
Knight C6 first and then to move the
Knight or to go immediately as you say
Knight D6 so now black is forced kind of
to exchange the bishop
I think because Knight F7 is hanging and
ic6 everything is a threat
and the question is how to react with
black
still looks so scary uh we do see the
evaluation bar preferring black but yeah
for errors so uh small here but if Fabi
would be a guy to be scared he wouldn't
enter into this game right sure because
of it fear you cannot play mm-hmm
yeah there are tricks against this
Knight now a direct threat against this
Knight in C5 maybe now is the time to
trade off yeah yeah maybe something like
taking on D3 Queen D3 and then Queen C4
what do you think
kid black yes
apply my Golden Rule of Chess when your
king is unsafe trade Queens
good principle
yeah makes a lot of sense so this looks
like what Fabi could be trying to do
starting with the move A6 just at least
asking a question of this Knight of
course white has other options one we
could mention is uh taking and then
dropping back with the Knight into D4
but then again blacks and Rook has
suddenly opened up and uh on this file
and if you can defend the threats you're
okay anyway I think black can try to
take Knight C3
Knight D3 I'm sorry and then after Queen
D3 Bishop D7 at least there is no pieces
around my king right and it's very
important also that black still has the
black Square Bishop so it's the C5
square is not so weak
because if there there would be an
exchange for example then White Knight
to the black Square bishop and white can
put the bishop on C5
still huge compensation and I don't see
why why should be better at all first at
all so great compensation
but it's uh it's really white cannot
fulfill his dreams and really get some
serious attack then the black may just
keep the pawns but problem for example
after okay one black should be oh sorry
I missed clicked that sorry dude uh yeah
in that position if white can get Rook
A1 then still some compensation
but yeah here it does feel like Fabby uh
as you say has to play a move like A6
just to ask that question and if you can
trade Queens if you can at least gain
Time by threatening the trade of Queens
it should be okay there is another
question Bishop D7 I think you mentioned
this already Bishop D7 and then simply
with the kind of threat so-called threat
to take on D3 and queen C4
yeah so for example if uh White Castles
maybe now we trade and come back
yeah maybe less scary than we thought
this resource of dropping the queen back
to C4 it's a really nice Square
gain of time and I don't think white can
ever hope for an advantage if the Queens
come off the board even if you gain back
one or two points
uh so it looks like Fabio should be safe
but no matter how scary the position is
and very tactical it can easily be the
case that within animals let's say there
will be a simplification and the
position will be very drawish right
because it happens in many of the sharp
positions that if both are playing well
it's going to simplify the way that
eventually it's kind of equilish yeah
but rally with farrugia involved it does
it does it get boring so uh yeah
optimistic here that this full-blooded
fight will continue let's leave Fabi to
ponder over how to deal with uh the
defensive dilemma right now
should we zoom out and check out some of
the other openings definitely
okay where to go next to Ivanka
um shall we pop in to the game between
Anish giri and Hikaru Nakamura
I mean these two have played each other
countless times and I think when it
comes to the the classical scores it's
Hikaru who has the edge there winning
five games to anisha's two
you know kind of uh Curious and
it's very interesting that already three
games and we're just not even half an
hour that we started the games and three
of them we are Queen off
wow
is that uh the free day made them solid
yeah to come after the storm just a
really stormy first three days and uh
suddenly the players they want another
rest day I don't know despite the Queens
being off in some of the boards still a
lot of life left oh absolutely
and uh as you said Judith the Queens are
rough in this one and uh this is the
current position still Level material
let's backtrack and do an action replay
of the opening moose uh this one now at
move 15 it started out as a sicilian and
we saw the rosalima variation with the
white Bishop coming out to B5 we see
there with the win draw loss bar that
white actually scores very well in Grand
Master uh play with this move a high win
percentage of 43 there for white
and okay
of course Nakamura knows his stuff and
after a trade of Bishop for Knight there
we saw some very natural moves
and eventually white did open up the
center following conventional wisdom
facing the bishop pair you want to
accelerate the play and is the Knight on
F6 uh comment isn't supposed to be on E7
that's a good point if we just go back a
couple of moves yeah you're right
through it normally the Knight lands up
on E7 maybe Nakamura has looked a bit
deeper maybe he was kind of anticipating
this pawnbrick and realized that
I don't know you could get away with
having the night on the more active
Square
um I think your right 97 would have been
my choice here for sure but okay Knight
F6 well of course if you have the time
with Knight F6 going D6 and then Knight
D7 that can be a very nice Square for
the night but we can see Anish wants to
play this it actually seems to be a very
trendy idea to put the Knight on F6
because I'm just four games in the
database all very high level games in
fact alireza played
faced it against pregnant just last year
and
actually it's called from those four
games white has scored three and a half
points
it's not bad it doesn't but it's a very
small sample size so let's not get
wildly excited about that I don't know
Anish might have been getting excited
about that when researching this
variation I suddenly would be and okay
we did see the center open up Queen
takes D4 and uh yeah some big threats
here potentially along this diagonal for
both sides I'm not sure whether the
queen is hitting the bishop or the
bishop is going to hit the queen Black
castled Knight C3 and this is where the
Queens disappeared black not liking the
tension played the move Queen to B6 and
it makes a lot of sense black has the
bishop pair so getting the Queens off
will suit him long term and I'm slightly
surprised to see Anish capture but his
idea now is to kick the Black Knight
back to E8 bad Square there and after
Bishop E3 hitting this Pawn Naka has
just replied by playing Rook to A6
Judith first instincts about who might
have the advantage here well it's clear
white has a great space Advantage so I'm
not surprised that uh Anish got little
tempted and and I see him playing in
many games having the queen swap somehow
right he doesn't mind to go into an end
game in his previous game it was also an
endgame or a middle game without Queens
we can call it also maybe this also I
would call it more of a middle game
without Queens I would think for example
playing A4
to gain some more space and not allow
for later B5 of course for the moment
black is not going to go B5 because of
Bishop C5 but black wants to go Knight
C7 Knight E6 but there's a huge weakness
in the position on D6
and Black's Bishop pair is not something
that black is is giving a great play
with them though maybe black snacks move
can be also D5
yeah and that is actually something that
Ali Reza thought about when he actually
faced this position against pragnananda
and there he actually put his Rook to D1
first and the whole idea as well was as
you say you know black needs to mobilize
the bishop perso after black played F6
he was ready to meet that with Bishop F4
and it was played in The Melt water
tour okay so very logical moves there
from both sides I think you're right
Judith black next move needs to strike
either with D6 or with F6 just to open
up the set of Bishops and it's
interesting because you may consider
Bishop F4 for example with the same idea
that black cannot push the Deep on
uh but after Bishop F4 already B5 is
also kind of something to consider
because Bishop is moved away so Bishop
C5 is not possible but probably anyway
Black's plan is really to play F6 and
somehow get rid of the E5 Central Pawn
and open up the the diagonals for the
bishop and also the ae8 Knight can later
on come out from there uh it's passive
place
yeah to me it feels like okay it's low
risk for white of course the niche has
things under control but I've seen
Hikaru win so many of these positions
where he has the bishop pair or he has
some small long-term uh kind of
strategic advantage and then somehow he
just clings on and survives and wriggles
out and then outplays his opponents
later uh so I don't hate Black's
position at all here actually quite I
think I would probably choose black
almost for it quietly yeah just I like
my central pawns there and you yeah you
like your Bishop yeah I'm way too biased
and actually it's one of my biggest
weaknesses I often miss the Dynamics
because I'm too busy going after the
bishop in Middle games but here I don't
see any thing going too wrong for black
as long as you can break out uh
healthily with F6 what about playing
Knight E4 with white let's jump in and
Knight to the E4 here
so okay you've clamped down on the D6
Square
still slightly pondering whether I can
play a move like D5 uh but well those
are the best move and your opponent
wants to stop something and you're still
making it right
D5 let's try let's try the five takes
what do you want Bishop F5 or you want
to grab my Pawn on B2 good question uh
first of all I'll just mention to the
viewers I didn't forget that onpassan is
a legal move there
it's a superpower it's a superpower
exactly who Bishop takes V2 as possible
I was yeah wondering about Bishop F5 but
also F5
crosses the mind but uh after Bishop F5
I mean Bishop takes Knight
might not necessarily be a threat
because D7 Pawn so D6 Pawn is looking
mighty fine yeah for example rook ad1
and yes
whoops exactly
now I shouldn't have allowed on person
but okay Rook 81 is on the board just to
point out here for example black could
consider a move like F5 and it's still
very complicated this type of position
uh it's likely black will win back upon
and things that are opening up yeah so
Anish didn't go for this one uh perhaps
worried that he might lose some control
instead he played the move Rook a to D1
so following the game you mentioned
Ivanka now F6 breaks out for black and
we're expecting F6 Bishop F4 with a very
tense position
absolutely certainly very tense and I'm
curious I mean judging by the clock
times I would guess that neither side
are aware of this previous encounter
but you know chess is like that these
days there's lots and lots of games in
the database and you just can't keep up
with them or yeah these top players they
can remember a lot of games but there
are millions of games out there being
played and yeah most likely they knew up
to a certain point and now they're just
playing logical moves and it just
happens to follow that one game but it
happens also sometimes you know the game
itself but you know that you have plenty
of time because let's face it this
position is entering into an end game
it's not so complicated so you have
plenty of time one hour and 40 minutes
so you you can also spend time that okay
I know that game was rookie one I like
it but maybe something else comes to
mind some other idea or after Rook D1
maybe he says well maybe F6 what am I
going to do Bishop F4 Bishop D4 do I
have other alternative and can I ask you
what happens if you know the game and
you know there's a trap
how should you behave
should you just like Blitz out the moves
or should you kind of like
regular make a move on the five minute
Mark well generally on a high level you
don't have these things of course when
you're a kid and you know some traps
yeah you're you're acting like I
blundered something then you're actually
sacrificing it or you're acting in one
way or another
but when you are playing on a higher
level you don't make these jokes anymore
of course it happens when you kind of
blender something then you're just
completely convinced so you have you
need a poker face
I think some players do it also that
they they use their expressions and body
language
to maybe pull you into some uh some
blunder or something
but usually you don't fall into those
things okay
I like to nurture that I think I'm just
a child because uh I I go for all the
Mind Games I go for all those uh tricks
and I think there's two schools of
thought one is the most of the top
players they just moose as quickly as
possible save time for later for me it's
like okay I know this position but I'll
sit there for three minutes like hmm
what to do and then I'll play it I'll
play a move maybe not so confidently
even if it's not setting up a trap and
only once the opponent kind of follows
down the path then I'll speed up and
then I'll show them who's boss and I
think that kind of switch in Pace does
scare a lot of people I mean I've played
against aronia for example I kind of sat
there being like what to do in the for
10 minutes in the opening and he walks
straight into my novelty straight into
my preparation managed to win that game
as black and uh yes occasionally it
works but more often than not like you
said the opponents don't fall for the
traps anyway so why bother with those
mind games but it's interesting I think
there are some players who work a lot
but they really select on which part of
that opening they are working on and
they come to the game they give this
impression that I know everything and
they are just flashing out the move
right to hide the bluff and then you it
gives the impression at some point that
does he really know this what's going on
or he they are just bluffing out so if I
divot here or there then maybe there is
a home so sometimes it's kind of very
tricky right the the is it only the
surprise that they get and still they
want to show that they they are under
control
or they are yeah you're right that's why
there's this phenomenon of as soon as
players are out of their players out of
their prep there tends to be a mistake
immediately just because they've bluffed
up to a certain point and they haven't
gone further who are the biggest oh
sorry Ivanka yeah yeah I was gonna say
who are the biggest buffers uh in World
Chess do you think Judith you've played
a lot of these uh top guys before well
can I can I answer first yes
yes I think okay I gotta go whisper this
again between just you guys and everyone
watching I think Hikaru is a big bluffer
but only because he he's so like
dramatic with his facial expressions and
you think oh he's not very comfortable
with his position
and that he does what you highlighted
there David he actually knows what's
going on you know you kind of think okay
well he's not happy and then suddenly
and then you think oh dear oh maybe
Magnus can do that too yeah yeah another
one
yeah Magnus I get the oppression
I shouldn't reveal too much but he knows
some stuff like you say Judith extremely
well and some stuff he knows he can work
it out at the board so he maybe doesn't
uh rehearse in his mind and of course
he's good enough these all these top
players they're good enough to work
things out of the board but uh yeah they
normally the complicated stuff like we
see in the game between ferrugia and
Carolina that stuff they'll memorize
they'll know inside out and then uh
maybe more mundane slower positions
they'll trust themselves to just
freestyle yeah absolutely and let's head
to the bird's eye view and uh speaking
about Magnus we should
I'll take a look at his game because
rumor has it actually I have it here
right in front of me he went into the
confessional booth and we love it when
the players give us their thoughts and
he said it in Norwegian so
I will have to give you a translation
which was basically that his goal today
was to surprise gukash and get him out
of his preparation so and he was
thinking that kakesh would never prepare
for such a dumb line so Magnus concludes
that he thinks that he could be worse
out of the opening but his opponent will
have a long strategical fight ahead of
him so shall we take a look at this dumb
line that Magnus has employed
[Music]
we get some more amazing spots
that we can um
[Music]
thank you
and we could see there Magnus in a good
mood because he says he's gotten his
opponent out of his preparation and
there is going to be a long strategical
fight ahead of him and of course he has
a satisfaction of employing a dumb line
he was really happy he concluded he was
in such a good mood right he had this
childish smile on his face I mean it was
nice to see more of the face after that
shave that's the main takeaway for me
from that video he looks like a new man
Magnus yeah normally when he feels good
he plays good I think the same for
everyone and we see the position in
front of us it's changed slightly there
has been a trade of one set of pieces so
far a bishop for Night Exchange but
white has Doubleday pawns and like he
said it's going to become very strategic
long term here uh Bishop to B5
yeah it feels like your cash
of course he's doing okay but uh what is
his plan Judith well I think he wants to
keep the tension and the point is that
black with the Knight cannot really move
away so comfortably because there is the
PIN with the bishop on H4 so my question
always especially in this position can
black play G5 because if black can play
G5 and the wide Bishop moves away then I
can go Knight E7 even simplify offer an
exchange of Y Square bishop and I think
the two knights are just completely
doing a great job
but
of course the pawn on A5 is not a half
for black so this way the bishop on B5
can locate itself in a very comfortable
way
so there is a lot of pressure I think
from right side putting on on magnus's
position so that H4 Bishop is really
kind of bothering
yeah black this position really reminds
me of a variation of the uh Four Knights
uh the Spanish four nights where kind of
black gives up the bishop pair doubles
the white pawns and yeah this pin is
often extremely annoying there as well
actually it's almost uh identical to
that variation in which actually this
white A3 Pawn would be back on C2 and uh
in that line often you want to break the
pin in various ways you can break the
pin by kind of moving with Queen E7 and
eventually uh kind of playing like B6
maybe Rook d8 move this Knight out the
way but it takes so long and in the
meantime white uh will be motoring
forward with uh plans such as D4 so I
think should we jump into that that
critical move you mentioned G5 Magnus
will calculate it but
whether it's sound I think actually I
think G5 probably cannot be a real move
because of Knight G5 take stakes and F4
is simply Unstoppable
let's show this on the board G5 it's a
very thematic sacrifice here Knight
takes G5 would happen and like you say
this looks too scary to contemplate if
black had still his Bishop on A7 or C5
on the long squared on the dark squared
diagonal then uh it would take a while
longer for white to initiate F4 but here
you can motor forward F4 and see how
this pin looks deadly
it's not Magnus uh it's not Max's style
either I think to play a move like G5
unless he can guarantee there will be no
tactics so so probably for black it will
be Queen E7 and uh
and play Slowly maybe Rook goes away
from B8 to d8 and then Knight B8
for example I think that's a plan
regroup it to D7 eventually
is it ever a plan
um instead of going Queen E7 I I mean
I've seen it done in other lines to kind
of try to get the Knight
to the king side
so uh the question I guess is how to do
that because we would love to play a
move like Knight to E7 uh to re-route it
to the king side as you say your
Vancouver Bishop takes Knight will ruin
the pawn structure and you have to be
really careful I mean maybe this is fine
for black uh often if you get a two or
three moves so you can kind of play King
H7 you can put the Rook on the G file
stay down at the white king if you can
get rid of your double pawns with F5 uh
you'll be doing fine but here I just I
slightly worry that uh the White Knight
will come to H4 maybe white will just
play D4
it feels a bit shaky with these Pawns
got to be weighed up at least
certainly and as the chat says there
this game is about to get spicy
I think it's time to take our first
quick break and it's time to mention
that there's a very special event
happening it's the 2023 speed chess
season beginning with the junior speed
Chess Championship on June the 13th this
four day event showcases the best young
talent in speed chess with over forty
five thousand dollars on the line but
the real prize goes to the top finisher
alone who moves on to the main speed
Chess Championship later this summer
catch all the actions starting June the
13th right here at twitch.tv chess use
xclam jscc in chat for all the details
and we'll be back with the Norway chess
action right after the break
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
[Music]
thank you
chess.com's game review recently got a
major update here are four key notes at
the end of each game review you will now
see a summary of the game from your
coach your performance rating for that
game and a quick grade for you and your
opponent in the opening middle game and
end game we've added a new
classification called Miss for when a
move fails to take advantage of an
opportunity but it is otherwise a sound
move we've also changed the definition
of blunder now a move will only be
considered a blunder if it loses
material or allows a checkmate coach
will now draw arrows and highlight
squares when you hover over or click on
the highlighted words in the move
explanations this should make move
explanations easier to follow finally
coach's explanations will now reference
specific pieces and threads in
explanations making move explanations
much more intuitive the new game review
experience is available on chess.com
right now
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I thought we were going to be on a break
um uh
um Hikaru can you take over
welcome back everyone and for today's
intro what we're going to do is we are
going to be talking about the games that
are going on right now in Norwich house
now first and foremost I'll start with
my own game um so far this is all
preparation I looked at this before the
game
um so nothing new so far I think you
know
we're sort of at the edge of where the
theory ends or at least in terms of what
I looked at um obviously I think Anish
based on his facial reactions I think he
knows the kind of this position is equal
and he's hoping that I wouldn't know
this whole line with Queen B6 and Rook
A6
um because without that I think White's
a little bit better so based on anisha's
visual reactions I think he's a little
bit disappointed and there is some
chance my game could and then draw
fairly soon depending on which which one
of the next couple of moves on each
plays of course it could also go for
quite a while so my game's looking
pretty stable but as we as we move
around to the other games there's
there's a lot of stuff going on so first
of all we have the game between tari and
Wesley where tari is decided you know
what it's not his tournament he's
probably not going to win so he might as
well consolidate a little bit get some
points where he can try to make a quick
draw with Wesley eat up like two or
three points I don't know exactly how
many points he got for a draw but
definitely trying to Trend towards the
arm again and pick up those classical
points and just just move along
um Wesley trying not to do that he plays
rookie eight move instead of Queen H4
like Magnus now of course I think if you
were to ask Magnus about this why Magnus
didn't play Ricky it again business
because in this variation generally
speaking why you can end up with
slightly better by slightly I mean very
very minor nothing super super exciting
but why can't it maybe a touch better
with zero chance for black twin it
doesn't look like Tara has played it
necessarily quite in that order per se
but still I mean it's hard to believe
that Wesley can generate anything so
that game I assume will be drawn within
the next like probably 20 30 minutes so
we'll get an Armageddon there um
elsewhere shots came against Notre back
I'm in Fairly stable maybe smallish for
white he's got this nice Center E4 F3 G2
um magnus's game is actually quite
interesting so gukesh played this this
Gucci piano or the Italian opening where
he played uh this bishop G5 with Knight
E3 now Magnus of course played D6 and A5
which is one of many lines and Magnus
side take on A3 now I've had I've had
some positions similar to this on many
many Blitz Games so I waste my life
playing online chess and I think that
John White's supposed to be a little bit
better if you're precise but you have to
be super super precise to prove anything
and so I think Magnus is sort of
gambling that in the long term googkesh
won't be super sides the double pawns on
a file will be an issue and and so
that's what Magnus is aiming for the
other game of course which is very very
wild is the game between
um is Ali Reza and of course Fabiano
Fabiano coming up with this this French
prep um typical typical Fabian of course
with his Pratt
um and he played this king d8 move and I
mean the game is very wild I think if
both players are how to prop my general
assessment is that probably it's a
little bit easier for Ali Reza to play
based on the peace placement I mean it
feels like for Fabiano the work on h8
Bishop Buffet aren't really in the game
King idiot as if he Bishop on C and not
active and so I think Ali rezzy looks to
cows will play F5 C4 very limited plans
generally speaking for white whereas
black probably has to figure out what
exactly the setup is so I'm not feeling
great if I'm if I'm in Fabian or shoes
right now considering that both players
appear to be out of out of their
preparation based on the time usage so I
mean that's pretty much what's going on
I mean so far I mean a couple
interesting games couple pretty pretty
dull games but you know that's just how
chess is so I hope you guys enjoyed this
update and I'll probably be back later
on
um probably I'll be back later if I'm
not back later that means I'm playing an
arm again so we'll see see you guys
and a big thank you to our fourth
commentator Hikaru Nakamura who is
giving us his thoughts right from the
confessional Booth so we certainly need
to digest a lot of the information that
he gave us so let's have a look at the
bird's eye view and process his thoughts
yeah Ivanka I've got to say Hikaru gave
us more information there than I think
we've passed on in the last hour
combined so thank you Curry we needed
that oh I love it and meanwhile Anish
still in thought bring Hikaru back he's
got time well he did tell us you know
that he he would be back so uh we live
in Hope Hikari can count on him and he
should be scheduled
once per hour he comes on in five
minutes and breaks down everything and
then we can just go back on break
exactly
so let's see what did he say he said the
interesting game with alireza right
which is absolutely true
interesting that with good cash what did
he have he said that white has to be
extremely precise and that's what Magnus
is counting on the probably the cash
will go wrong at some point
yeah I guess that's how Magnus kind of
plays against the youngsters uh he talks
about anti-young player chess and often
he just wants to slow the game down to a
different pace slower strategic and he
hopes that they kind of miss the moment
later on uh so interesting thoughts from
Hikaru kind of mirroring what uh we
thought the storyline of the game would
be uh we see on the camera a niche deep
in thought and
also Hikaru if you notice what he said
about his position he seems to be in
book he seems to know exactly what's
going on we mentioned whether he was
aware of the kind of the predecessors uh
the previous games in that position and
he said if Anish goes down a certain
line it's just going to fizzle out to a
draw if Anish wants to play on then he
needs to be very accurate as well and
Anish just mulling over that big
decision now uh in their Clash well we
can also see it on the on the clock that
he spent only 20 minutes while Anish is
nearly 40 minutes with his spending
yeah which is interesting it's answering
a question from just before the break
like uh do the top players play
instantly if they know what's going on
or do they kind of just take their time
at their own Leisure spending 20 minutes
for most people is a lot but uh Hikaru
even though he knows what's going on uh
yeah still taking a pause here and there
and okay which game should we focus on
first
should we take a look at the game that
we haven't checked in on
um between Shaq and norderbeck
and uh Shaq and nordebec actually coming
off losses in round three we saw
nordeback of course loose alireza
farouza there and shark lose and of
quite a painful manner in the Armageddon
game against kakash
yeah it went very much out of control
for him
probably he was thinking already that
I'd win the victories in my hand already
but this was a very complicated position
where he went wrong there but this
position is uh much more solid one I
must say
yeah it's not Jack style at least we
don't associate these types of positions
with him necessarily so therefore we can
kind of conclude that Abdul satoroff has
won the opening battle uh let's actually
backtrack because this is the one game
uh we haven't seen so far let's do a
quick action replay of the opening let's
show this uh this opening some love and
uh here we do see it was the Queen's
Gambit accepted one of the trendier
lines of the Queen's Gambit accepted
here taking the pawn uh E4 and E5
meeting fire with fire in the center we
saw a check and uh in this position
actually earlier in the tournament we
saw the move Knight F6 uh very very
sharp stuff but this time nordebec goes
for the solid line swapping everything
off in the center going for this
queenless middle game white will win the
pawn back sooner or later we see this uh
Pawn is not going to last too long but
eventually when that pawn did drop this
was the position we were left with
castling Queen side for black and uh the
white king kind of cast would by hand
here landing on C1 eventually and
everything traded off it's just Rooks
and knights left now and the only
imbalanced unit is the pawn structure
well I like C5 a lot with black because
later on possibly black can also regroup
his Knight if he wants of course on E5
it stands absolutely brilliant but to go
to Knight C6 and to have an outpost on
D4 it also makes a lot of sense later on
possibly King will be brought up to C6
with King C7 King C6 black angle A6 B5
so actually black can also get better in
this position I think black feels very
comfortable and white could not get
really anything in this game
yeah it's interesting kind of imbalance
as David highlighted it between the poor
majorities
um to my eye it would be white would
need to counteract Black's plan by
actually mobilizing his own majority I
mean is that possible with maybe some
Rook F1 and some I mean oh how to do it
I mean should you push with age the age
porn should you go F4 and then begin the
adventure or
yeah oh is it or is it maybe the key
thing that the white king is far away
from those pawns and can't assist it
what are the kind of key details here
for white I think that kind of Latter
detail you mentioned Ivanka could be
very relevant because uh Judith here you
were enthusiastic about Black's kind of
porn majority the three versus two on
the queen side here and that's because
the king can act as a supporter white
king kind of in limbo it kind of wants
to support its own pawns but it cannot
it's kind of cut off along the defile
and yeah if the King was over on F2
assuming the black Rook couldn't kind of
come into the position then it might be
easier for white to start pushing pawns
on this side of the board it's suddenly
difficult to do that pushing right now
with the move like F4 uh would come with
consequences maybe the Black Knights
would jump in Via G4 into the position
you have to be kind of wary what would
happen if black jumps in with Knight to
D3 suddenly the F4 Pawn would be loose
on that square certain uh kind of
concrete considerations to take in to
measure that and uh what happens if I
get the vacuum cleaner out and I take my
my rook and I offer a trade
um is this just Even Stevens or still
black has that edge because his poor
majority is more mobile
well after Rook D1 there are several
options for black but Rook D4 is for
example something to consider just to
keep the tension but I would just take a
look at capturing the Knight The Rook on
D1 and then with what are you going to
be capturing back because whatever
Knight you take back it's not standing
very well if you take with the King then
possibly Knight D3 can be unpleasant but
anyway even if I don't want any concrete
stuff I can come just King C7 King C6 or
also something else to think of for
black to play G5 and stabilize the
Knight on G5 on E5 because G3 is not
possible yet so maybe white has to play
King E2 in order to play G3 and with the
ID F4 black will be moving back with the
Knight to C6 Knight D4 black plays B5
King comes up and I think black is at
least as active as white spaces
yep I fully agree it feels like Rook D1
it's not a bad move but it's yeah it
feels like an admission that things
haven't gone to plan and I just want to
point out as well this type of position
it highlights the difference between
middle games and end games in a middle
game I think white would have great
chances here if Queens are on the board
maybe a set of Bishops just because
Black's E6 Pawn is so weak it's isolated
and stepping forward in the center would
certainly favor white if it were a
middle game but yeah because it's the
end game Black's got so much activity
black has this nice ball majority on the
queen side it feels like uh those
Dynamic considerations are far less
relevant it's all about uh kind of long
term here and Black's doing great and I
think in this this position it's also
important for white to to have the
mindset that what am I playing for am I
playing for a win am I playing for a
draw or I just say that my evaluation is
whatever let's say it's roughly equal I
just want to go on and understand the
position and play the best move because
if you have a misunderstanding in
evaluation for example you can easily go
wrong
so it's a it's a question whether how
mama jarov is taking this position
I think F4 is something to consider
immediately at the same time maybe black
witches go Knight G4 and possibly just
exchange the pair of knights
yeah and it just depends who that favors
I don't think it necessarily favors
anyone to be honest it feels uh like
that could be a safe approach for white
the thing with F4 like you said if you
don't get it now it might take another
10 moves to get it uh so do we delay I
think it's it's kind of up Shack Street
to play F4 and hope for the best later
but yeah I just love what nordeback's
done and I think I would pick black how
about you two
if pushed you guys have really been
serving the black position to me so I'm
like black of course
um but you know my instinct said white
then I am backpedaling furiously but
that's probably because of pattern
recognition and I totally understand
um yeah first instinct for me was white
as well just because I saw this isolated
Pawn I thought oh there must be a way to
Target it later but the more I look at
it the more I think the knights it just
favors black right now does it make any
sense or a good or bad move I I don't
know to play H4 for example with white
trying to push H5 and gain a little
space
put that on the board H4 makes a lot of
sense if you get two or three more moves
uh you can kind of push forward and
I do wonder whether black plays the move
H5 then I wanted to go to cage three
maybe Andrew cage three to G3 maybe I'm
going on a very bad path I'm not sure it
could be a very good path there as well
looks fantastic Judith
yeah and then stick The Rook on G5 oh
beautiful
yeah that's the thing after H4 H5 for me
would be the kind of kind of thing I
play in Blitz here as black just because
it I want to kind of clamp down if you
ever play F4 now I have a beautiful
Outpost for the Black Knight on G4 but
like you say there's Dynamic
considerations
Rook H3 in this exact position and maybe
a bit awkward this Black Knight on F6 I
really don't like I've got to say if
this one was more active then maybe uh
this would be less scary for white
yeah I was also thinking if after H4
black wants to go Knight H5 to control
some black squares on G3 or F4 but then
Knight E2
it was my plan
quite a good plan
maybe after H4 black just ignores
everything and says okay you do what you
want on the king side it will take you a
few more moves and let's initiate on the
other side maybe King C7 like you said
maybe a6b5 I'm not sure which one to
rush forward with
what about playing H5 let's say H6 yeah
I I'll just let you for instructive
purposes do what you want on the king
side first you know what I want I don't
know what I want I was thinking to play
H6 without H6 G5 or G6 my Pawn can be
vulnerable there is life are very good
it will become a queen or it might just
drop off the board
this h61
it has so many difficult decisions I
mean actually this type of position is
often harder than a tactical uh kind of
melee because at least when it's
tactical you can calculate and you can
make a concrete decision here is kind of
you're just playing by field you've got
five ten solid four was played yeah and
uh you guys called it you said that's
more his Vibe and sure enough it appears
on the board oh it certainly seems like
a lot of the games are
in in-game mode but uh let's go back to
the bird's eye view because there was
one game that was on fire and we have to
see how that one's developed and that
was between alireza farisa and Fabiana
Carolina
alireza playing in a very enterprising
style sacrifice importance and now big
decision
he's actually jumped in with the Knight
to D6 and there's been a change in the
Dynamics so can we dive in and see
what's happened yeah let's uh jump into
that game and it's actually something
very similar to what we discussed a
while ago and black has just played the
queen uh the queen to C4
Fabi trying to get those Queens off the
board and use using his extra two Pawn
Advantage I think one thing is very
important compared to what we were
seeing but I I'm not sure we didn't have
exactly the same position but black did
not waste a Tempo playing A6 and forcing
Knight D6 but he has Bishop D7 which can
be a much more useful move unless the A7
Pawn will be taken of course
hahaha yeah I guess if the A7 Pawn is
ever taken you're kind of mentioning it
can be captured in some lines but that
will mean that white has had to trade
pieces uh just to get to that pawn and
that would be a win I think a moral
victory for Fabi the good thing is he's
not just one point up by either he's uh
kind of got pawns to spare pawns up his
sleeve well I think white cannot
exchange Queens if he wants any
advantage of Queen A3 then Queen B4
check actually right can't escape from
the queen you can step back right but uh
22 Queen D2 sorry my arrows are going
crazy my boy my bad the queen D2 Queen
D2 is the only move to avoid exchange
right but it it doesn't feel like the
most aggressive move on the planet and
after all black Kanga still go
Queen B4
I had to catch myself there and do some
calculation but it's possible C3
and then the idea was
is this going to surprise you to take on
D6 exactly I see that pawn and I want
that material yeah let's jump in and
show this on the board what can uh White
try here I guess you can swap nights and
then go to A3 but the alternative the
variation you two are discussing here
firstly Queen before is impossible oh it
is possible wait Knight takes C6
I mean still that's that's feels to me
very complicated actually because after
the trade of Queens you know
there is a Pawn on A7 that's up for
grabs yeah
for some reason I thought this was just
uh not playable but you're right this
Pawn is also up for grabs as well and uh
just to show the other line uh you're
mentioning there C3 Queen takes D6 and
three pawns feels like too much but the
evaluation bar is bang in the middle oh
that then I'd normally take that as an
indicator that white has actually
extremely good compensation if you have
three pawns and the computer's like yeah
yeah if it's true what the engine says
if
you're trying to shift our reality to it
I mean trusty well you know it's like
it's typical if you we wouldn't see the
bar there we would think that I mean
okay if I test compensation but after
all white has three pawns down right I
mean I mean really
and then and then you say the bar and
say well maybe there is something in it
if the engine says that it's equal
and it must be very good for white right
if three points down
I mean but could it be for coin kind of
concrete reasons for instance the night
coming to B5 to attack the queen and
then
is unpleasant for black for uh
yeah or still like you still have moves
like no it takes porn or
castling I mean C4 is still very much
Brewing
yeah it's the question as well what is
Black's next move if I just Castle White
can often try and play a move like F5 uh
maybe try and break through on this
diagonal if you ever play A6 I'll jump
in with a check on B6
I mean I would take black I've got to
save because I'm greedy three pawns but
yeah in Practical terms if this was a
Blitz game I think white would have
fantastic chances again it's just uh
Judah as you say the computer the
players don't know what the Silicon
Overlord say they don't know that the uh
evaluation is roughly level so three
pawns I think alireza will just rule out
this variation in his head well if you
play an Armageddon this is exactly what
you want to get right with the white
pieces
and we might well get it Queen D2 is on
the board
so Queen B4 pretty much leads in that
direction
yeah I mean are there are any other kind
of improving moves for
for like could you for instance
try some moves like beef
B5
I I'm kind of struggling here to kind of
think of a way to solidify the position
but I thought B5 to prevent C4
well B5 is possible but that would be
maybe scared a little bit I was thinking
to play Maybe F6 and try to sneak away
with my king to E8 and F7 to stabilize
it
yeah if you got two or three moves
that's a beautiful kind of Safe Haven
yeah I mean if black gets three moves
you have other ideas too right true but
maybe white cannot break through within
the next few moves so I guess that's uh
that's one question what is White's plan
of course white would love to Castle but
right now maybe that's why we want to
keep our Queen on on C4 rather than
moving it away like uh we were showing
in that other line because now white
cannot Castle
and maybe cannot generate an attack yeah
I mean okay so
I mean we I guess we have to ask
ourselves in this type of position what
is White's plan is for instance Knight
takes night a big deal if it's not
no okay just not a big deal right
because the queen A5 check is easily
dealt with and then King F2 and then
what will white be doing next I actually
fell foul of not asking myself these
questions very recently so now I'm
trying to do it every opportunity
yes I think one of the good opportunity
and idea for white to bring his Rooks to
A1 and B1 on the open file so to put
pressure there and of course the other
idea is to play King F2 rookie one and
possibly F5 so it can be also
prophylactical move forward it's very
important that white is not exchanging
the queens and at the same time not
allowing the black king to get into
safety mm-hmm
should we jump in and ask just uh kind
of how those plans mesh together does
that say black starts with F6
which plan are you going to go for yeah
this is a good question how to react for
a white immediately right because if
black really gets to E8 and F7 that's
already a huge development and progress
for black two moves you have to hit me
within two moves here otherwise I think
Fabi is Happy can you hit them
immediately with
F5 although that's very risky after F5
my plan was to go Knight takes D4
and after Bishop D4 I would be trying
out E5 if it's possible
right
and if you go Queen A5 check then just
simply can get
yeah
you can take a pawn but you now find
safety for your king and everything's
beautiful for black yeah
yeah look how strong these pawns are
going to be the white king suddenly is
the one stranded in the center not the
black one so white has to be very quick
right after F6 to react on that
yeah F6 looks so logical once you've uh
said it true that I love it and uh
Knight takes Knight is nothing here I
guess uh because after this check
or maybe we don't take with the bishop
which piece do we capture with I want to
get a check in next move do we take with
the queen
take it with the queen I thought the
queen yeah
this track can just be met Again by
running away yeah
yeah
this Pawn as well dropping it's going to
be a two-point advantage and
they say in these positions with heavy
pieces and opposite color Bishops it's
about who can attack who can have the
safer King and it doesn't necessarily
look like black uh has to worry about
that anymore right now F6 looks
so logical I really didn't like ferris's
idea of just jumping in with Knight D6
it felt a bit premature yeah it's like
he had to wait for A6 right
yeah just if we backtrack a few moves
ago we left it here and maybe there are
other moves I don't know if uh White had
a threat but Knight D6 felt
too soon and we do see it was given a
question mark by the the question why
didn't he Castle first why was he in a
rush to play Knight D6
mm-hmm
yeah it looks healthy to me here you
kind of keep options open of F5 you
sometimes threaten Rook A1 yeah
mysterious stuff anyway he uh instead
went for Knight D6 and this is the
current position where we are awaiting
F6 and and it's super important here
that uh
black actually can't Castle because
black has already moved the king when
you've moved the king that's it you
forfeit your cast link rights and chess
is simple as that really you know so
with certain pieces have special powers
right at the beginning like for instance
pawns they can move two squares at a
time but for the king it loses its
superpower once it moves or if one of
the Rooks where you want to go to that
side have moved as well I have a
question after F6 what happens if white
sacrifice is one more Pawn you know it
doesn't matter already two three four so
let's go F5 okay let's jump back in F6
followed by F5 and here we were saying
oh no we weren't saying E5 sorry because
after E5 it seems like Knight E6 check
right I'm not sure actually it's true
also not so sure
maybe I just take and look at these
pawns and D4 right D4
yeah
they won't last long it's like they uh
it's like two armies they're Behind
Enemy Lines these secret agents but
they've just been found out their
identities have been revealed and
they're going to be uh eliminated next
move yeah I don't know sorry yeah and I
was just gonna say that uh Sam shankland
in his book he talks a lot about like
how to assess whether you should move a
pawn forward and uh one of his golden
rules is basically that if you you have
to look at whether you can support them
not just now but in the future and there
there you go they're right for the
taking yeah and look at this if you step
one forward then fully blockaded black
might even eat up these spawns with this
King
beautiful variation but uh not good news
for for Russia if F6 yeah because we
found anything at first I thought that
after F5 E5 is not possible and black
has to capture on F5 and possibly I go
King F2 rookie one and bother the king a
little bit not allowing so easily to run
away
King F7
and what happens if you just you know
forget that your material down and just
continue the game
like you go King F2 put the rook in the
center and then just say
well you know
I have the dark squares I mean I'm
really trying to think of something good
I think that's why I'm just so in love
with F6 because after I moved like King
F2 black could always consider E5 at
some point and things might open up and
it might be the boy king that's uh
suffering more than its counterpart
wow this is huge for the tournament yeah
totally huge because if six is there it
is on the board and we have to remind
ourselves if carono were to win this
game in the classical then it means
quite simply he walks away with three
points
and he already has seven and a half
points out of nine take him to ten and a
half points and that's quite a
significant lead and he has of course
defeated Magnus Carlsen in the first
game
yeah taking down your biggest Rivals
that's the key to winning tournaments
especially doing it with the black
pieces in a game like this one ferrugia
is on a hot streak winning two games in
a row but
yeah this one feels like it's gone wrong
in the opening coming up against Fabi
that's the problem how do you get him
out the opening he often has the
surprise up his sleeve and playing the
French defense looks like he's being
rewarded and it's so interesting that
when you play such a sharp opening you
if you have this Tranquility in yourself
right that you just focus on the
position you know that things are okay
you know objectively you analyzed it
properly you you're not a verse but you
will have to find the Right Moves but he
has the self-confidence for that to
enter in this kind of position and just
look at that it's just a very calmly
played F6 dude walked away but you could
feel somehow with his body language that
he's happy with his position
he's confident
yeah and that confidence is just
building day by day we saw Fabi beat uh
Magnus on day one of course he had a
decent Blitz event as well before uh
kind of the classical chess started and
just feels like uh yeah in his mind he
believes he cannot lose he believes he's
just going to beat everyone at this
point
just wow F6 it looks so simple once you
see it but to find that move is not easy
in the first place and uh the simple
plan as we've been mentioning King E8
King F7 but you see in this point you
said okay if you ask questions what is
the plan and this is exactly that this
way I also said F6 this was the
conclusion right that you have to put
your king into safety if you have to put
your king into safety then you you try
to look for moves with very safety right
yeah it also makes sense in opposite
color Bishops uh kind of positions put
pawns on Dart squares you control the
color complex that your opponent has the
bishop on and yeah none of these lines
we've seen look even vaguely playable
for white gotta say yeah material down
and it black keeps it
yeah okay certainly very complicated and
uh Fabiano looking like he has the upper
hand there shall we move on to another
game take a look at the bird's eye view
can can we look at dari's game because I
think it's very instructive or it can be
instructive what's going on there okay
yep let's uh zoom out of this one and go
over to the game between tarry and
Wesley so and
oh dear I do fear for the underdog in
this one Judith this is what I want to
say that if you look at that white just
gave away the extra Pawn which he
collected after the opening in the
Marshall Gambit
because he thought that okay we simplify
it's a draw end game
but you know just to have a Jewish end
game it doesn't mean it's gonna be a
draw unless you understand the position
at least as well as your opponent and
this is we are witnessing right now I
don't know what will be the the outcome
at the end but one thing is sure black
improved his position immensely right I
mean look at the pawn structure the
black uh has the black Square Bishop
white is blockaded on with A4 look at
that A3 b2c3 Pawn structure so if white
cannot come back with somehow playing
Knight D2 in the next move or something
and playing breaking out with C4
then white can easily have a very bad
end game because black is just look at
every piece is more active of black than
white look at this F1 Knight I don't
like it I hope it comes back to D2 and
and really pushing away the E4 Rook but
definitely it's Wesley who is pressing
in this position right now yeah you can
already see the outline of how black is
going to win this game either black will
come and kind of get a night round to C4
eventually uh where it's gonna hit this
B2 Pawn maybe even win the B2 Pawn or
the black king long term if the Rooks
disappear it has a clear path into the
position as you say shoot it on the
light squares the light squares all
belong to Black due to the pawn
structure and black and start advancing
on the other side as well just start
getting space here it feels like black
and play on both flanks white so passive
well it's still not the end of the world
right it just looks bad but it can get
bad if white is going to be playing
inaccurately that's for sure
yeah and so there we can see the chat
that Ariane does of course have his
supporters but uh what happens if you
initiate one of the plans that you
mentioned now
like the Knight coming to D2 and
breaking out because I agree with you
White's positions has the makings of
being an exercise in suffering
you don't want to let that happen you've
got to fight suffering with activity so
go for it now let's put this on the
board Knight to D2 one of the only
active moves in the position at least
but there's an also another move you can
consider because in this position of
course with white you say I want to make
a draw I can't show off with I'm going
to be playing for an advantage no you
know it's clearly you play for a draw
right so Rook D4 was something also I
would consider to
to check just simplify the position but
it's very tricky because black would be
exchanging the Rooks I believe
and let's say after Bishop D4 black can
try to play C5 and maybe B4
yeah possibly already because the B2
Pawn is going to be a huge weakness
right yeah so this is one thing then
you're going to start calculating okay I
don't like Rook D4 because there are
some dangers so let's go and try an id2
after Knight D2
that's I mean firstly the question is
does black kind of trade off this bishop
Black's Knight is beautiful but you
could maybe make an argument for
Wrecking the white Pawn structure all of
the white pawns narrow on dark squares
targets for Black's Bishop but maybe I
go E4 and I try to simplify and it's a
fact that the pawn structure is very bad
and let's say one day if you take off
the Rooks and the black Bishop can come
to C1 and grab the pawns that would be
deadly at the same time I'm not sure
black is able to achieve that so maybe I
just go E4 try to simplify keep the
Rooks on for the moment
but it's always right who has to be
careful because of this B2 weakness
maybe only 20 moves from now maybe 30
moves from now yeah maybe this is
playable I mean you have to calculate
for example you mentioned Judith the
bishop coming and whether this pin is
okay looks like white is fine here the
evaluation bar hates this for some
reason maybe just King E2 and white is
doing okay uh with the Knight coming but
already there's some tactics where
you're kind of hanging by a thread and
but if we go back and after Knight D2 I
think 93 something of course it comes to
mind to check it but what about Knight
D2 Rook E6 and then again white who has
to make a decision can I play C4 or or
what
yeah because after C4 it's a completely
different story right now takes on E3
and already for example Bishop BC Bishop
F6 or Bishop C5 first and rookie one
Bishop D4 I don't know but there are a
lot of weaknesses
that white has to look after
this feels like one-way traffic and yes
you're playing for a draw with white but
it just looks like pure suffering Bishop
F6
I just don't see this white knight ever
getting active Black's got the perfect
scenario with pawns on light squares
Bishop on Dart squares and
perfect strategy also you're playing
Wesley who's one of the best in these
types of positions exactly just kind of
milking these small advantages yeah
yeah it really is
quite
thing really
I I thought that was position I must
admit was
worse
but not that bad thinking
and now I'm thinking oh no
I kind of got felt a bit Eeyore about it
hmm I mean it's possible to play Bishop
D4 for example with the idea of Knight
E3 trying to say right and I did wonder
that maybe it was time to do like I mean
if you've all highlighted time and time
again that this bishop on E3 is
vulnerable it forces a change in Pawn
structure in certain types of position I
do want over the you know maybe you can
go King I know it doesn't look great and
it's no no no no I was going to suggest
a blunder as king E2 I was thinking of
but then already there's like Bishop
takes A3 in the air cool yeah
tactics yeah and it's not just the
position that makes me fear for tarry
here it's just the momentum of this game
he's been playing for a draw from the
beginning it's slowly getting more and
more difficult it's also the way the
tournament's gone losing two in a row it
would be very easily to kind of easy
here to start getting a bit down on your
position to start seeing ghosts to start
taking even more negative decisions it
should be fine objectively but yeah
black is the one having the fun yeah and
uh for those of you who are wondering
who Ari antari is he's the number two
player in noi but let's have a look at
some of his stats
and there you see he does of course have
a lot of big history he defeated Magnus
Carlsen at the 2022 Norway chess I
remember that game it was magnificent
he's been 2019 Norwegian champion in
2017 he became World Junior champion and
local was born in Stavanger only 23
years old definitely one of noise
brightest hopes
yeah and that's the thing he's uh been a
prodigy for a long time unfortunately
he's been stuck behind Magnus Carlsen
for a long time too so it's just about
whether tarry can hit the next level
he's yeah a fantastic player he knocked
me out of the World Cup once uh in 2017
so I know how strong he can be but yeah
it's just among this kind of field of
sharks how do you survive and so far
it's been a tough start to the
tournament certainly and uh shall we
zoom out and go back to the bird's eye
view because just taking a look at the
evaluation bars and pawn structures I
can just see that Magnus Carlson am I
seeing right is he
a pawn down
I'll have to do a bit of counting and
that can be vancouvert it does look that
way Magnus has lost a pawn in his game
wow should we go there and check out
developments because this could be wow
devastating for Norwegian fans looks
like both of the Norwegian players
potentially in a little bit of trouble
at this early stage
and yeah Magnus that freshly shaven look
not working so far kokesh with the beard
showing uh where the power is at
[Laughter]
thinking of the story of Sams was it
Samson and Delilah right
yeah lose your power the hair is still
there
position we see in front of us let's
just do a quick action replay and go
back from the last moment we were at
this game and it was about four or five
moves ago oh we left it here and white
had just played the move Bishop to B5
and Magnus reacted by stepping out of
the tension with those light squared
Bishops Bishop E6 hinting that he might
get greedy and grab a pawn but good cash
said no just do what you want go and
capture it because after D4 suddenly the
bishop might well find itself trapped if
it takes on A2 white would just step
forward with the rook and no safe
Retreat squares Magnus lost a move here
really strange stuff I've got to say
Bishop G4 he moved this bishop twice in
a row
and after a trade here D takes E5
magnus's idea was to capture on F3 but
suddenly a really clever intermediate
move is Visions again from gokesh Rook
takes B8 calculating correctly that
black has to recapture with the queen
and now in this position Bishop takes
Knight is too big a threat black does
not have time to capture on E5 and
therefore the Knight had to retreat this
is the current position he takes D6 C
takes D6 and it's an extra Pawn but it's
an extra doubled a pawn
thoughts on Black's compensation
well yeah it's like we can say I don't
know one quarter of a pawn
there's an own expression that has been
quoted to me many a time a porn is a
pawn well it's not exactly because you
see the A5 Pawn holds up both of the a
pawns the question is I think whether
black can control some of the white
squares playing Queen B5 or something
well unfortunately for black I think
when B5 probably it's not possible to
Bishop E7 but let's say black can bring
the queen to E6 or C4 or queen e690 5
Knight C4 that can be something very
good compensation
you know the queen and Knight often work
quite well against Queen and Bishop in
these types of positions as well so if
white doesn't have anything immediate
for example against this uh backward D6
Pawn or maybe if white can somehow uh
combine these pieces against the G7
Square then yeah black still feels like
you have decent chances but uh it's
definitely one of those cases it's like
not poor all pawns are born equal and
these pawns are definitely uh not making
a great impression but they would be
great in an end game
true if the black apron disappears no no
even if the black deep Pawn disappears
because you could fix but this is like
very surreal right if the queen and the
Rooks left the board you could fix that
pawn on A5 and then
it can be something it could be a target
for the white Bishop yeah stuck on a
dark Square
can be something like that that you play
A4 you exchange with Knight C5 Bishop d8
he takes the a pawn you take the A5
phone exactly and finally you have one
passport this is what you wanted the
apron is resurrected in a different
version no I mean
but okay this is like way in the
distance and obviously it would require
a lot of help but also at the same time
black has to be careful and I think they
are playing also what about the D6 bone
because right now that's an issue for
black that's why he cannot go Queen B5
because of Bishop E7 but also in the
next move it's possible for white to go
Rook D1 and threaten Bishop E7 or if not
from there then Bishop G3 possibly can
also put pressure on the D6 spawn so the
D6 Pawn is something to look after for
black
yeah maybe black is okay but the thing
is it doesn't feel like black can ever
play for more than equality if white
wants to shut this game down by just
kind of going for this Pawn uh it feels
like you know good Quest should be safe
which isn't good news for Magnus okay
let's think about concrete moves you
mentioned Judith a very natural one
there Rook D1 let's jump in and see what
Magnus uh would try to reply with
Rook to D1 hitting this Pawn
hmm I want to gain time against your
queen somehow I'm not sure whether I
really should Rush with this but let's
say I hit your queen with the Knight you
step back step away yeah Queen E2 I
somehow like to cover the C4 Square
let's say I just prevent your plan of
Bishop E7
evaluation bar is hating this play for
black it looks so natural but maybe this
is just showing that you need more than
natural moves Bishop G3 yeah black is
stuck
I'm not sure whether you ever want to
rush with F4 but you don't need to you
can just kind of build up I'm just
threatening you know I'm just having the
threat for example if you go Rook E6
then I would probably go F4 and quickly
Knight D7 F5 for example
hit me and hit me and this Pawn will
drop on D6
yeah things could turn actually let's
say after Rook D1 if we go back
I really want to get active with the
black queen somehow I really want to
jump in but I don't know if I have time
this Pawn is just hanging in a lot of
variations
yeah
it's that way
I was also thinking immobilizing the
knights and somehow sacrificing the D6
Pawn in the quest
to win everything on the queen side but
I guess that is too much to ask
how yeah this is a massive threat Bishop
to E7
yeah so I was thinking Knight to E5 okay
Queen back
and then rookie eight okay this is the
position we saw though Bishop G3 and
it's just yeah and again I've managed to
get into that no oh
Bishop overpowering right here oh no
that didn't work out that was bad news
somehow I would want to make it work for
black to play F5 you know some counter
chance and then after he takes D5 he
takes F5 to play D5 Knight D5 Knight C4
but somehow I'm losing pawns on the
king's side it's not tempting no no no
no I can't I can't do that it's just uh
somehow somehow it looks slow for black
yeah so that that extra Pawn is only one
part of the problem I feel
yeah there's no coordination somehow and
it's
just a very nice harmonious position for
white
yeah one big Target on D6 just might
mean that black has to take some passive
moves uh to even survive the next few uh
next few turns I do Wonder actually if
we took the A3 point off the board what
the computer would say would it still
give what an advantage
it's one of those types of positions it
feels like rukesh all the aces up his
sleeve
well it is uh something that we will
have to ponder on because it is time for
a quick break but don't go too far
because we will be back in a few minutes
with some more of the thrilling action
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the Champions chess tour to
the candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
hey everybody it's Danny here and as you
may know chess.com and chessable are now
one and I'm here to show you how you can
make your chest.com and chessable one in
just a few clicks to start let's log in
and connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click login scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
gonna ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm going to say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable home page
now the puzzle connect feature can be
found under Tools and you click puzzle
Connect Now what that does after you
type in your username is it's going to
pull positions from the games you've
played on chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning from the mistakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature
accessible but if you go to
chessable.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
foreign
[Music]
land of fjords Majestic mountains Cliffs
and waterfalls in addition to stunning
geography Norway is home to the greatest
chess player who has ever lived Magnus
Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best from Carlson's fiercest online
rival today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps laude Beck Abdul
sotorov and kukesh domaraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023 Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana
two more longtime Headliners seek to
take their next turn Atop A major
tournament Wesley so and Shakira mamat
yarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field who will
come out on top will Carlson run the
table yet again or will someone else
usurp the throne this is Norway chess
hello and we are back I hope you're
refreshed and ready after that pause I'm
your host International Marcy
wankerhauska and it's great pleasure to
be seated next to two legends of the
game grandma said Drew de poga and David
Howell
oh it's been a very tense start to this
round four so shall we take a look at
the bird's eye view and do a quick
Roundup of the situation so far
yeah we've seen all of the games in
differing detail but there could be some
shocks on the card the on the cards that
could be some decisive games in terms of
the tournament standings uh we see at
the far left of the screen and on the
camera uh kukesh against Magnus Carlson
and we liked gokash's position a pawn up
maybe not the best porn in the world but
he seems to be in control there Magnus
fighting for his life fighting for
equality
Judith giri against Nakamura
end game by now right and uh
did he really play Knight F3
that's kind of a strange move to me but
probably the reason is because black had
a very strong Strat playing D4 and C5 in
the next move which would open up the
huge long diagonal for the bishop and
then black would have been taking over
on the in the position because F5 now
stands very well but for the moment
Black's B7 Bishop is really not very
active so this is a prophylactical move
playing Knight F3 absolutely not an easy
move to find
certainly not and moving on to orientare
and Wesley so you kind of named it you
know Ariane does seem to be suffering
there he has perhaps the worst end of a
drawish position and then we go on to
Shaq mamajar of nordebec mamajarov what
do we think about that one
uh it feels like okay big decision just
being made there but it feels like a
roughly level position again where Matt
majara struggling to get out anything
out of the opening and Abdus a tour of
just looking extremely solid looking
very uh yeah impressive so far I've got
to say in this game is black
but roughly in the balance that way and
a lot of end games but there has been
one firecracker on the board and that is
between alireza farouza and Fabiano
caruana these two have played each other
countless times and to my eyes and uh
judging from the track record it seems
that in recent years Ali Reza has been
suffering against Fabiana caruana and
take a look at this alireza farooja well
here the head-to-heads age 19 against 30
and then here are the important stats
Karana leads with uh three wins and one
loss
in the classical games what do you guys
think about this
how easy is it to play a difficult
opponent
well I think it can be misleading the
rating points what you've seen on the
screen because it shows that the firoza
has a higher rating at the same time
when you're such a strong player like
Fabiano and also firoza Fabi is there
for so many years already on the very
top he has such an experience with the
very best players playing World
Championship match and many other events
that still I believe that that that he's
uh I'm not sure he's a better player but
he can score very very good results
because of this amount of knowledge and
and the experience what he accumulated
yeah and David are you surprised by some
of the numbers uh not really faroogia is
after all a young and up upcoming player
Fabi he's been around he's older more
experienced and some of these wins uh In
classical and Rapid would have come when
ferrugio was very young I've been saying
to everyone in recent years life begins
at 30 and uh Fabi proving that in this
tournament so far of course Fabi he's
looking impressive at the moment he's
capable of fantastic results we've we
know that Fabi scored one of the most
dominating performances in chess history
uh in the sinkfield Cup in 2014 and yeah
for Asia I think just lacking the
consistency the Fabi shows at the moment
yeah but there have been some important
encounters between the two that they
played each other in the candidates and
their Fabiano won and they also played
each other in the grand Swiss and it was
again another important victory for
Fabiano so we will see but uh
I have to I have to say David I hate to
break it to you but you've got to wait a
few more years before Life Begins
if it gets better than it is right now
then I'm not complaining yeah I can't
wait
but uh yeah experience it does tend to
count in of course you're capable of
great results he's on form as well this
tournament but
uh occasionally he makes some big
decisions and commit to a decisions and
it feels like that's happened in this
game Judith well and he's not only
number two in the world right now but
he's definitely one of the most
interesting players out there I remember
years back I think it was two years ago
when he was playing in the last round
against my country man the Richard
Robert who played he was leading the
whole tournament for for like eight
rounds and then the last round he
collapsed with the white with the black
pieces and firoza just gave away a rook
and they said yeah
it's a nice idea why not to try it I
mean of course there was a little
compensation but it he he said it
afterwards in the analysis in the studio
like no why not it was interesting it
which is a very nice experience for me
to see how he was thinking that time
yeah but is this like the trademark of
Youth that you feel like you can just
give up material I I know that farouza
is a flamboyant creative player but
this confidence that comes I think
braveness is definitely is a trademark
of of a very talented young players yeah
that's I said Life begins at 30 and
that's the one thing I miss about being
a teenager just that uh kind of lack of
fear lack of caring you know you just
play for the sake of playing you think
every game will end in Checkmate that's
the one thing I miss now it's like oh
every game ends in a 70 80 move grind
but uh I love arugia's style and just
the way he approaches chess like you say
just why not for the fun for the
entertainment and uh that's why the fans
love him and that's why he's been so
successful
and uh yeah what do you think should we
jump into that game it's still far Asia
deep in thought he's been spending a
long time on this last move over 30
minutes in the tank for arugia it's move
20. it's this F6 move which might be a
killer dude you spotted it
well yes and it's very big problem when
you realize it that you start looking at
the position and you see that oh do
moves and the black ink is in safety the
Rooks are connected and suddenly my two
pawns are gone
so this is a very unfortunate
Discovery I think for Fairuza and of
course now he has to be extremely sharp
how can he make damage control
like uh should he be going into some end
game like Knight C6 capturing the A7
Pawn gaining back one but still one down
but the problem is the D6 spawn right
now seems like it can be more of a
weakness than a powerful pass spawn
right
and after F6 and later black king moves
to F7 it can be very powerful maybe much
later but once black is going to be
playing E5 possibly pushing away the
Knight or whatever and play D4 so and
with different color Bishop it can be a
very annoying position where it's going
to be a long game but you know that you
play only four two results yeah yeah it
is also a big danger in actually
simplifying the position because yes you
make your life easier for yourself but
at the same time you do the reverse for
your opponent and as you've mentioned
you know black has material and well
we're going to see a move 96 Knight C6
played so he did back pedal somewhat and
uh go for that extra we'll just go for
the a pawn basically well one born down
is better than two
[Laughter]
I think this was the conclusion of
Fairuza a great classical chess wisdom
there
yeah he wants to take a form back why
not if you see nothing better yeah and
now the question is whether black is
going to be capturing it with Bishop
which seems like it's not the best move
because of Queen A5 right and queen C7
it would be very strong so black has to
choose between Queen C6 or B Tech C6
okay so if we kind of go for the most
solid one which David has got
highlighted Queen takes Knight yeah
let's show this on the board Queen takes
C6 the only drawback of Queen C6 and the
only reason I would want to keep if it's
possible on C4 that now white can Castle
or well hang on a second it's all a
little bit hypothetical because we do
see that Fabiano super quickly he's been
anticipating this move for a long time
actually captures that Knight with a
pawn yes because he does not want to
allow the Castle link you see yeah and
it makes a lot of sense as well now the
Rook on B8
is out there and mobile
it's opened up and now there's two kind
of logical moves for ferrugia he either
takes this Pawn immediately and uh at
least gets one of those two pawns back
the deficit reduced or he gives a check
with the queen on A5
and we always talk look for checks first
in every position should we uh check out
this absolutely in A5 what does black
play here I guess you have to go towards
the center you have to run with King E8
and let's say I take your Pawn
what has Carolina got up his sleeve
what's he got in store here because at
least now the king cannot run this is
why I was reluctant to take with the
pawn because the seventh rank has opened
up and the bishop would then be
loose attacked that's true but maybe
black is going to be playing simply
Queen B5
what do you think
before check that's also possible simply
Queen before check and go back when B7
let's say but then
white has good drawing chances actually
but wait one second
actually this is not good text and Rook
B1 right but I was actually
thinking not about Queen B7 but I was
thinking about being as greedy as I
could possibly be
wow grabbing the spawn yes makes sense
take it
and at least give me the you know
because one of the great things about
being a commentator is that these are
not my pawns and I always have the
option of take back
yeah now I've planted my king on F2 I
definitely cannot come forward and
attack you because you take the spawn
with check and uh it's nice that you
kind of defend everything you defend
your Rook I'm going to go to B1 instead
of Bishop C5
yeah now I really wish I could Castle
you can artificially castle with King
goes to yeah you because you've lost
your castling rights that's very very
important to mention once you move your
king that's it you can't can no longer
make that special move and now but you
can go King F2 King F7 sorry
yeah King F7 and yeah I don't see
anything for white I've got to say no
immediate
uh way to compensate for the two-point
deficit and if there's nothing immediate
black will be fine
but how fine is it if you just kind of
go hey I'm just going to reinforce F4
because then that allows the bishop to
move big threat on the board trapping
The Black Queen you should survive okay
eight simply I believe
yeah
whose Queen gets trapped first yeah the
White Queen once she's forced to run
away this is bad bad news how about okay
one last trick here how about if I take
first and then go G3 I'm stealing your
idea Ivanka you're welcome
I want to play Bishop C5 the problem is
ah just Rook B2 and
black strikes first
it wasn't a good idea afterwards
it was an idea though and that's what
fruition is you need some type of idea
and uh yeah if we backtrack to the
current position if he doesn't play
Queen A5 which doesn't seem to turn out
too well we mentioned Bishop takes porn
but black can just moved right I'm
wondering where do we even get active
Rook B2
um five I love rugby too because you
know two can play at having an unsafe
King and I just love that Rook C2 is on
the board you know his Queen E2 check
mating ideas oh oh oh one Bishop doth
has a doth does not I want to say it
does not check Mateus or something like
that
does not Checkmate Shakespeare exactly
yeah this one looks terrible i've got to
say and uh the letter of the evil seems
to be this queen A5 track let's uh give
farouja a bit more time 35 minutes on
the last move now another five minute
thought maybe you didn't expect B take
C6 maybe you thought Black's uh
automatic recapture would be with a
Queen instead I love what Fabi was doing
I think instructive for everyone at home
as well he was thinking in ferrugia's
time and immediate recapture just the
psychological
battle and on the board uh just feels
like everything in Black's favor right
now
yeah what favors black and with the last
move that the queen on C4 doesn't allow
car so at the same time also suddenly
after bc6 The Rook from B8 can be active
right the drawback of it is that the
seventh rank is uh weakness for black so
that's the question whether white can
take advantage of that
option so are you thinking about moves
like
I was thinking maybe to hold the tangent
with Rick A1
but
difficult with whites if only White's
King were castled it would be a
completely different matter
yeah just to show your point there
Ivanka rookie one would look nice but
even after a move like King E8 you
cannot get greedy because black will
come round the back and yeah you really
wish you'd have Castlewood here that's
why they tell you kids at home Castle as
early as possible right now really
difficult this is the current position
we're expecting Queen A5 check but black
for choice for sure
and okay should we go elsewhere which
games haven't we been to for a while
with Anish Geary we haven't been
yeah let's check in at the game I want
to see how our fourth commentator is
doing oh man if
a confessional
it's very rare we have a roving reporter
both playing chess
so reporting back for us
he's away from the board right now
Hikaru maybe he's uh in the confessional
revealing more secrets well one can only
hope
and this is the position we see in front
of us we do a quick count at least for
now temporarily it's level material
Level pawns uh black is just given upon
temporarily with this last move Rook to
A4 should we have an action replay see
how we got to this position from the
last moment we were here
um we joined this one uh we went through
the opening phase and we left it after
the move F6 white did Play Bishop to D4
and after a Trader Pawns in the center
black decided okay the bishop pair no
longer worth it you need to get this
bishop out from C8 so D5 we saw the dark
squared Bishops being traded white
jumped forward hitting this pawn and
this is the move you mentioned that you
liked Judith A4 clamping down on black
spawns preventing an advance over here
and after Knight F5 slightly mysterious
retreating the White Knight covering D4
no more Pawn pushes for black in the
center and C5 wow breaking forward
Knight takes D5 Rook takes a four so now
I guess Knight takes B6 is the big
question but this would be met most
likely by to B4
hitting the pawn hitting the knights
then I can continue jumping
and this is my question is black just
okay here or is there something to worry
about
pulling up for weight this Pawn attacked
this Rook attacked
it's interesting why yeah
maybe this time for blackheads to do
this way
yeah
yeah if he thinks he's got it all under
control anyway
well maybe after Knight D7 what about
Bishops Bishop takes F3 that's what I
was thinking too but after Pawn takes
Bishop
well maybe even Knight H4
wow wow
calculation nice and just just to follow
this variation through to the end Knight
takes Rook Knight takes Pawn check the
king moves somewhere Knight takes Rook
and it's a bit weird that Knights have
been Intruders but they're both just
simply going to fall off the board most
likely well this game very much seems so
that it's going to be a draw and we're
going to see some play of Armageddon
yeah on this
something like this and everything is
going to get vacuumed off the board
hoovered off the board and
draw most likely that's if Anish goes
down this whole very forcing line here
black is playing for something
grab the phone true true I've been a bit
careless here I mean still a draw but
been a bit careless here for white this
is our surgery of course yeah
let's go back to the current position
this is an if a niche initiates that
whole forcing line that 10 move
variation with Knight takes B6 at the
same time white shouldn't go anywhere
else because he can get easily a worse
position
true and what about instead if he opts
for another kind of idea which is to try
to get Rooks on the seventh
there may be a check with the white
knight yeah
yeah you can check on E7 and I guess
black would simply just trade everything
off uh if let's jump in just to show
this on the board Knight E7 is a check
I've got to look for checks first in a
free position of course but I fear for
white actually here in this type of end
game if that just plays a move like Rook
F7 prevents you from doubling on the
seventh rank
totally and uh White has ruined his own
Pawn structure for nothing so
I don't do that very instructive
still probably a drop but at least white
has to work for it here yeah I think
initi should bail out it's that time I
think Hikaru is not that the board and
his
probably giving it to her for us
in the confessional boost
because this is gonna be a draw and he
knows it well if he is we I promise you
we will go straight to our mind on site
[Laughter]
maybe he's already going to tell us
what's going to happen in the rest of
this game he's going to reel through
that 10 move variation then he'll tell
us how the Armageddon will unfold he'll
tell us his plans there for Anish
come back we want more
definitely and uh okay so we think that
this game is spiraling towards a draw
um maybe we should zoom out and have a
look at some of the other games for
instance you haven't paid attention too
much to shock Abdus that's one eye one
game I've got my eye on
um another one is Magnus Magnus game how
is Magnus coping with his Pawn
deficit yeah so should we start with
this yeah definitely okay let's uh start
with the game we now see in front of us
between gukesh and Magnus Carlson this
one really is bringing to life and uh
okay I think this is turned at least in
favorable ways for Magnus I'm not sure
whether black is better but suddenly
I've seen an active Black Knight coming
into the F4 Square suddenly uh okay
White's still a pawn up but this Pawn is
loose on e4
hmm what do we think you did it's black
in time here before white grabs all of
the black queen side Pawns
well probably white wants to grab C6
pawn more than the A5 Pawn for them all
but taking the A5 Pawn releases two pass
points on the a file yeah but it's still
Queens on the board and some tactics
might be
happening but yes I understand that the
A5 is also something to look after
what about Queen B5 here
and games I'm not sure at all that it uh
it will turn out to be any good for
black yeah I actually learned this from
Ivanka
um a couple of years ago Queen and
Knight versus queen of Bishop tend to
favor the queen and Knight if uh if
they're able to coordinate but rook and
Bishop beat Rooker Knight quite often
and I never knew this I never really
thought of it but rook and Bishop seemed
to combine better than uh Rick and
Knight do so going into an end game
risky maybe
should we jump in so it's yeah I
actually concrete
I'm glad you've reminded me of my own
rule that I had forgotten
but uh actually the more I think about
it I think it's maybe too risky right
because after Queen takes queen go into
that in game with open arms and then you
can now start
maybe something like this exactly this
is what I wanted to do anchor the bishop
and then
Target the B5 Pawn how much I thought it
would be one you want to go but after
Bishop D4 I would take on the E4 and
Rook F5 Knight F4
so now if I take this Pawn you'll meet
me with a check
or Bishop just in time to capture the
bishop yeah maybe it's holding together
just concretely for black but I was more
afraid of Rook B1 after capturing on B5
that's position Rook B1
yeah I wanted to stop Knight F4 coming
just again with this check but
um maybe it's just okay for black
but wait one second white will have two
doubled a pawns and I actually this is
like super important because I once had
the opportunity to play this type of
ending against uh humpy Canario and
there she only had one a pawn but it was
an interesting situation because Dave is
going to highlight it right here yes
yes you know both sides will have um
almost equality in terms of Pawns but
the bishop will support that outside a
pawn and I I spent like 40 minutes on my
clock trying to assessor and in the end
I was just too chicken and I was like I
can't can't do it I can't go into it
what do you think
well I think in this position of course
white is clearly better you can go
Bishop B6 or Bishop D4 and once you
start pushing the Pawns
yeah it's just whether that's uh B6 not
possible tonight D2 Knight C4 oh so I
have to put some better Square for the
bishop I blundered that one but yeah
either way it feels like black should be
able to hold a draw but white is the one
having the fun Magnus I was about to ask
can he be more ambitious yes keeping the
Queens on the board yes yes I think it's
a much better solution
yeah just attacking this Pawn getting
ready to centralize the Black Knight at
the same time of course Knight on F
Knight on e4 stands very well but on F4
it was also not the bad spot and the
wide Bishop from D4 will be very well
centralized centralized so for example I
can go Bishop starting with Bishop D4
because if Queen C6 then possibly you go
Knight G4 or that's not the idea
ah interesting
yeah let's forcing G3 let's put this on
the board uh Bishop D4 potentially yeah
actually maybe after this also do you
want to go Knight G4 right
opening a sneaky Checkmate on H2
and white doesn't have too much too many
choices yeah
no there are some unexpected things
might happen
queen of night that's so tricky
yeah
no I wasn't a big fan of putting the
the bishop on D4 just because I felt
like it abandoned the king but what
about if you just
a running theme maybe even a running
joke make it into a meme whatever you
like Queen takes porn I want it but
maybe Rook C8 simply never C8 and the
queen is somehow losing coordination
completely from the rest of the board
yeah and which one do you want to take
next this Pawn this Pawn let's say I
drop back I guess you have to take this
Pawn now I want to take on C3 yeah it's
annoying but E4 is always met by Knight
G4 yeah
and or is it
what have I missed here
maybe just E5 and I block but either way
this is uh starting to lose control for
white this whole variation Queen takes
C6 Rook C8 really nice move
yeah and the White Queen forced onto
really bad squares
I've got to say I love this last move by
Magnus it feels like he's turning things
back in his favor and
at least now it's good cash who's
starting to see ghosts potentially I
would be seeing these variations where
black is actually coming in with Knight
E4 with Knight G4 and I would be wanting
to pull the break here for gokesh
and yeah I think he'll take one of these
pawns see A5 C6 but whether he still has
an advantage that's Up For Debate
I don't think he does gotta say
worse comes to worst with maybe just CNN
game like the one we highlighted earlier
I think that's that's uh what should be
the outcome of this position somehow
Queen B6 or somehow playing
somehow yeah somehow simplify it with
white and enter into and draw a shunt
game
yeah because black species are very
active Roku is extremely well placed the
Knight is regrouped to a very bad option
either E4 G4 both are very good spot
and and of course whites or pawns are
weak E4 C3 A3 A2
and there's no way that white can hold
on to this E4 Pawn because that seems to
me the key point so can you kind of go
Bishop G3 I I know it's this is just
everything in
and then go E5
yeah let's try this Ivanka this is maybe
White's only real attempt for an
advantage Bishop to G3 hitting the black
queen where do we run to in B2 yeah
let's go in and if E5
where does the Black Knight go maybe the
only problem is there's no good Square
for the Knight anywhere you just I'll
take this pawn and I'll hit the Rook
maybe I'll hit your Knights if you
choose a four square so after all maybe
after Bishop G3 going Queen B5
or I'm going to the wrong direction
exchanging Queens but maybe it's just an
improved version for black over the line
we looked at because now black is ready
to jump in and capture this Pawn
followed by this Pawn maybe followed by
this one it's like uh Hungry Hippos here
just eating everything
yeah it feels like this one will fizzle
out towards the draw uh maybe this is
what good question should do though at
this point having lost a bit of control
tense well gukesh has plenty of time to
deal with the issues and come up with a
way to handle it but I have to say like
bailing out or kind of it doesn't feel
or like liquidating to a drawer it
doesn't really feel like his style
he's known for his Fighting Chess he's
known to be very gung-ho
I suspect we're going to see something
quite aggressive from him
yeah or bring it on I think Magnus also
wants to see that that's the problem uh
Magnus will hope that gukesh is in the
mood to take risks because that might
backfire but uh yeah either way I mean
it's been a great game so far from
gokesh can he take Magnus down that's
the big question should we check out
some of the other games the end game
between mama jarov and abdusatory
exactly let's head there and
seems like everyone woke up today and
was like you know what
let's play an end game a very long
drawn-out in-game maybe they've been
watching our man no not DVD but course
I'm
sharing my age with his DVDs and like
these days I get a DVD and I'm like I
don't even have the thing
to put it yeah
yeah and this one as we mentioned the
Queens did come off early it is an end
game it's Rooks the knights tricky
nights though and I'm not sure who's
being more ambitious of the two players
it's really come to life this game we
thought it was about slow strategic
Maneuvers black slowly pushing on the
queen side white pushing on the king
side
come to life at least for now and
okay I think we have to work out some
variations because both sides have
active pieces active Rooks
well I think right now white has to take
on C5
isn't it though there is very
interesting idea for black after Rook C5
maybe Knight E1
whoa maybe that's made him pause let's
show some lines here well yeah I mean it
looks like a very strong thread the
black white can go to B5 after Knight E1
direct feels very shaky right Rigby five
and then the king can step up to C6
Knight D3 is always in The Ether
yeah it's really clumsy black can always
take these pawns once the spawn Falls
maybe the rest will start falling as
well
yeah I take black here every time the
evaluation Bar says it's fine for white
but you start to panic if you kind of
you see if you're challenging the engine
all day
it wants to uh
trick us yeah it's uh it's the West the
engine it sees so much more than we do
but at the same time we gotta get inside
the place mines and at the same time
maybe objectively it's equal if white is
making the very best moves but there is
very easy to go wrong so we we know it
that from practical aspect it can be
extremely tricky to see the bar or the
evaluation of an engine right yeah for
sure so Ryan does not want to go to C5
capture the pawn or hesitating because
the active becomes uh very strangely
placed there so for example if white
goes Rook G8 but after that black can
capture I believe
on G3
and after Knight E4 let's say black
gives a check
and Kent black just defend the pawn with
B6
he he can I mean I'm wondering whether
white can kind of continue the farm with
Swinging The Rook to A8
going after all the pawns but I guess
you just give a check at the very least
I can drop back with the Black Knight if
I want to cue control maybe there's more
than that and also A5 is possible to
save the phone yep let's move A5 and the
black king will start coming towards the
center
blacks are pulling up in this line I
think Mama George just has to kind of
bite the bullet here he just has to in
this position take on C5 and go down
that line and hope that he's not uh in
any trouble we know thanks to the
evaluation bar that he's fine but it
does feel a bit scary for humans and
what about if you go after the a pawn
and just go Rook A8 immediately I'd um I
don't like this
because it feels like you're saddling
The Rook out there in no man's land
yeah maybe but maybe right maybe
I think there is an option to go Rook uh
G1 and after King C2 Knight D4 check and
again
and somehow it can be quite annoying
because where do you go with the King
you're forcing me back I don't want to
move forward because then you would have
taken a pawn with a check so I'm going
back
this feels all wrong for white somehow
it's no coordination A6 just simple yeah
there's no Knight d4s trying to
94 I'm sorry 94 yeah King C6 might start
coming well after now yeah after 94 also
drug C2 is possible and you're forced to
go to D1 because King B1 E2
or not because you can take on C5 and
you have C8 but I don't think we're K8
is a good move I think he has to take on
C5 it's just because he was pausing for
thoughts
but it's not something
but then what else
process of elimination he might have to
and that's why he spent uh almost 10
minutes at this point at this juncture
Mahmoud yarov he doesn't really want to
take because of 91. uh Judy I've got to
compliment your knight E1 I think this
is the third time now in one of the
Blitz Games you suggested Knight C1 and
then there was a knight D1 and now you
suggested Knight E1 these types of moves
on on my radar I would just be like I
would just be looking at a point of like
oh free food I can take this one but
actually why not to take it why not to
take the phone yeah because rugby five
would be a blunder for example of The
Rook G3 now Rook B5 would walk into a
check yeah check an ID foreign
next move the Knight will take this Rook
so this one also on the on the radar but
91 really sneaky threatening a monster
hook on D3 and this is scary suddenly
for Mama jarov
yeah because white is losing a little
bit of coordination what he had the Rook
on C5 is uh tricky placed
yeah again abduce the Torah just so
impressive uh at this young age again
he's kind of fashioning out these
chances where against lesser Mortals he
would uh squeeze out a point or two in
an unexpected uh can we go back a few
moves how did the uh how is the black
fruit got into G2 how did the white Rook
get to C8 no that's okay that I see the
road from H1 to age eight and see it but
in the meantime how the G The Rook to G
took
uh happened yeah let's go back uh to the
moment we left it we left it after F4 uh
about seven eight moves ago and Black's
night came in we saw a trade of knights
G3 and it was actually this move rookie
to E1 that allowed all this chaos to
ensue uh black now could take upon and
did take a pawn okay now I understand
that the Rook through D2 came into the
the white Rook was attacking this pool
in Black at least temporarily took a
kind of detour went to D7 first but when
given the opportunity after he'd
improved his King now came into D2 and
came via G2 and this is how the white
Rook got behind with a check and
okay current position so actually if I
did not have a choice instead of uh Rook
C8 because if white goes Knight E4 then
the King was ready already from C6 to go
and start the journey through D5 D4
come into the stomach of the White's
position
oh I like that phrase
come into the stomach and this would
actually end in Checkmate maybe against
the white king so white had to kick
Black's King back and
difficult times
got to take this Pawn surely I don't
know the margin for error here
not many maybe Rook B8 he wants to
consider maybe Rook B8 what do you think
maybe root B8
and if I continue harassing your Rook
I think C7
and yeah then you start going for the E
Pawn but that can be defended by the
Black Knight in the center
I don't know just the more he thinks the
more I think he might go wrong
often we do see that kind of phenomenon
happen you try to over complicate things
you panic you see ghosts I mean that
position did look scary for white but he
just has to go for it yeah yeah and
they're certainly looking tricky and uh
let's head to the bird's eye view where
we can see some of the games and one
game that looks to be heading to a very
certain drawish result is the game
between Hikaru Nakamura but first let's
hear from our fourth commentator in the
kovic and the confessional booth
ah welcome back everyone
um so here's here's the update first of
all my game I think it's very likely
going to be in draw in the next couple
of moves all this was more or less
preparation up until Anish played A4 I
looked this similar structure with A3
where I get Knight F5 with D4 and C5 why
you can go like 94 C5 Knight G5 and I
think it was Rook d8 if I remember the
correct position
um but if I get the chain of three pawns
it's kind of hard for white to play and
also with the only the 10 second
increment no extra time for Anish I
think he's just making a very practical
decision to go Knight F3 I mean maybe
I'm missing something here but the fact
that Anish is thinking just tells him
that he's looking for some way to keep
the game going instead of making a quick
draw here
um but overall I mean it's been pretty
smooth game for me I'm pretty happy
haven't really had to go into any deep
things I mean obviously 99 of this game
has been preparation
um and you know I'm just doing my Fabian
impression so probably headed to
Armageddon God only knows what's gonna
happen there I've been pretty shaky so
far in the first couple of games but you
know one one can hope that things will
go right way of course maybe I'm
counting the uh counting the eggs before
they've hatched certainly um but I
really think my game
well thank you Hikaru for entertaining
us with your thoughts and we heard it
here it was all preparation he knew
about that alireza farooja game against
pragnanda and completely prepared
they're good
and this seems to be one of those cases
I'm impressed they're still playing
Judith it's past move 30 it's a dead
level Rook end game
which movies it smooth 37 37.
but these guys like to play until the
very end until they have two kings and
now they are calculating what is the
fastest way to get to two kings in this
position I I know I don't know I I I
don't believe that I think the rock will
go to B7 and then the Rook will go to C4
and then there'll be some merry dance
there you go and I think even my
grandmother could draw this position
against her
right now but is it an ego thing that
they don't offer a draw but they will be
repeating moves
and then shake hands and there you see
the handshake it is a draw between
anishikiri and Hikaru Nakamura and off
to Armageddon we go and that will be
taking place in approximately 20 minutes
the players will be keeping their colors
white will have 10 minutes on the clock
your car will have seven minutes and
we'll get those important draw odds oh
so wow
I I do like that and going back to your
question do is it an ego thing
I don't know I think everybody has their
style how to make the drawing a
completely dead draw ending but I've
seen many of the games when they have
the opportunity to play out an extra
five moves ending up with two kings on
the board somehow they like to do that
and uh okay and well we will see more
action from those two players in
approximately 20 minutes but uh
are there any other games which are in
danger of uh finishing soon and heading
towards Armageddon so the one I'm
thinking of is orientare against Wesley
so
we thought that he was suffering a
little bit but has he managed to study
the ship and neutralize Wesley's play
I think we have to go in and investigate
our antari a draw at this point would be
a delight for him a relief for him and
it looks like he's done a good job of
Defending we see Wesley so at the board
right now trying to figure out how to
pose problems and uh this is the
position in front of us it's still Level
material white has done a great job of
getting rid of some of the tension by
trading off the knights Black's night
was mighty and Powerful in the center
white tonight was a bit sad so that
trade really
helps things and now the key question is
can Wesley go for the right piece
exchanges create a postpone potentially
he can trade Bishops that's one big
question right now and keeping Bishops
will that suit him he has to be a bit
careful with the black Rook lackings too
many Escape squares but what do we think
Dude any chances at all to squeeze water
out of this out of the stone I think uh
tari played the good descent game it
seems because we felt that it's a little
bit shaky for white or at least it's
very uncomfortable to play but I have
the feeling seeing the very active Rook
on d8 and going to attack from the back
rookie check is always there or sort of
G8 sometimes time to time if the king
from E6 goes away two verse to the F5 to
the king side then Rook C8 can be also
there so Black's idea can be only
somewhere somehow to exchange the bishop
on E3 and after F takes E3 whether the
G4 Pawn can be active enough to to be an
important passphone but with the active
Rook on d8 and being the king so close
to that bone on E2 I believe that this
game is going to be a draw and we're
going to see another Armageddon in this
much
more chess can only mean good things and
uh yeah Wesley about to make a decision
he does trade off the Bishops there we
go
and Ariane will recapture
certainly will and I agree with you guys
I think this is going to be headed into
Armageddon as well and uh we are going
to take a short break but there is a
special opportunity if you are a titled
player and there we see these two
Grandmasters in action because if you
are a title player you are eligible to
compete in the 2023 Champions chess tour
don't miss your chance to qualify for
the tour's fourth event we host
qualifiers every Monday excluding days
when other CCT events are underway your
next chance to join the action is Monday
June the 5th put it in your calendars
for details use x-clam qualifiers in
chat and we'll be back with the chess
right after this break with a very
special guest don't go anywhere
laughs
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay right now just
clock app right here almost there and
you did it
what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can play keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time lapse yeah okay you bring the clock
oh I left my clock at home dude you
idiot I told you to bring it let's just
go get somebody okay
oh
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
we're here in Toronto for the global
Championship I got Fabiano caruana with
me you don't need to talk yet I got
James we're gonna see who recognizes
these guys out of the out of the random
passerbys and we're gonna ask them some
fun questions about Chess for five bucks
do you know who this is
no okay active an actor well you see
this guy
any idea who he is somebody very famous
he is
this is actually 50 Cent's brother his
name is Daryl that's right it goes by
75. you want to play chess okay so what
is your player or something obsess
he is a chess player I'm not but he is I
play on the side yeah I've been taking
some coaching lessons from Grandmaster
Canty over here recently over here
calculation over everything what's your
name again sir uh my name is Jamie
what's your name
I already know it it's
Daniel yeah Daniel noradinsky okay
there it is
on the attack baby on the attack if he
wins I know the guys at chess.com we'll
get him a diamond membership okay do you
know what that is yes okay is that
something you want yes yeah okay look at
you look is this a London yo we got a
pro here with the London London how'd it
go
I should have said youtube.com
csq pod what is the URL just YouTube
actually don't remember okay
look at the pot
[Music]
foreign
hello and welcome back to beautiful
Stavanger and there we see our players
deep in thought as they battle it out
over the chessboard and I'm here ready
to comment all the action but we first
have a very special guest in the studio
it's Grand Master and one of the world's
finest commentators Maurice Ashley such
a pleasure to have you here and I heard
that it's your first time in Norway how
you finding it I'm feeling great thank
you so much uh Ivanka and David great to
be on the show yes it's been great in
Norway I didn't expect it to be a little
brisk as compared to my Florida climate
when I came but I've been enjoying the
fresh air as they call it and being able
to go around Stavanger and and enjoy
just the environment and of course the
chess it's been great yeah and how are
you finding Norway chess and it's very
unique concept I think it's brilliant I
love the idea of the Armageddon
afterwards I love the idea of decisive
games I think we should all have these
kinds
um of the tournaments everywhere
something decisive at the end as opposed
to 80 draws it's like you know you fall
asleep or there's any excitement but
this is guaranteed excitement all the
way to the end have you do you have any
favorite moments
uh so far not not really I'm still
waiting for something something out of
the ordinary to happen but I just think
the games have been fantastic I've been
really surprised by Magnus losing that
game to Bobby in round one uh the way he
did I think he's trying to catch his
form a little bit uh
we'll see we'll see and I'm surprised by
the fear of Disappearing suddenly there
was so much hair going on but now he's
he's pleading up I wonder if the hair
will go next we'll see if he's working
in that direction looking far more
youthful yeah today but I think he's
deadly serious he wants to win this
again for a fifth time in a row yeah
and last night part of a fundraising
event alongside daddy Ranch and Rain
Wilson and you were fundraising for
liday Haiti can you tell us a little bit
more how it went on the course
it's a great cause uh it's for young
women in Haiti building on their
education with the Arts and introducing
chess into it as well we were able to
raise over forty two thousand dollars
for the event so it was fantastic it
lasted about three hours and Rayne
Wilson absolutely great guy with his
with his wife they are very focused on
helping these young women or we're not
quite in the center at Puerto plans but
uh often the mountains in the rural
areas and trying to just build more give
them more options for their lives so a
great cause liday I.T and you can check
it out anybody wants to donate they can
go to lead ahiti.org you know certainly
a worthwhile course and also you're
involved with a big project happening in
Jamaica yes indeed my home country of
Jamaica I convinced the government to
put up some money and they did which is
fantastic to make the next Jamaican
Grandmaster uh technically the first
because I was Americanized by the time I
got to the United States and of course
I'm a U.S citizen and there became a
grand master so we're working now uh to
find the next one it's like American
Idol you know Jamaican chess Idol if you
will and Jamaica has embraced chess as
something special in the country and
we're just looking for the top talent so
we're going to train them we're going to
provide GM training we're going to
provide money to travel to International
tournaments we're going to do camps as
well and we're looking for boys and
girls so it's it's a great project it's
GM in 10. we're given 10 years to create
the next GM you know I think we can do
it in like five or six but that's
because I'm ambitious but we'll see how
it works out but it's fantastic
fantastic to see my home country uh
embracing chess in such a big way yeah
because the whole world seems to be
gripped with chess so it's fantastic
that Jamaica is also on board and you
reckon you can do it in five to six
years
I'm going to just be modest with 10 for
now in case we fail I'll stay on the
safe side but what's also great is other
countries in the Caribbean recognizing
it and a Grenada I believe just gave a
million dollars to chess uh I saw Nigel
short had an announcement there so we
are hoping that it will just continue to
expand to other countries as they get
this idea that chess is a big thing and
should be supported in their federations
yeah and I know you've been trying to
bring chess to a wider audience for many
years do you think that these faster
time controls like these Armageddon
setups are the way to go forward
I mean obviously it's quite exciting
nobody wants to watch nobody except us
you know the chess heads wants to watch
chess for six seven hours at a time it's
tougher to do that yes classical
absolutely has its place but in the
Modern Age a little bit faster time
control is something that I think is
agreeable is something that people will
be excited by we still need to have
great commentators like yourselves to
pull it together and explain what's
going on so that the audience is just
not thoroughly confused but yeah
combination of excellent broadcasting
like this and faster time controls
sounds like a winning formula
and what is your personal Favorite Time
control
well all I play is bullet right now so
we're probably not gonna commentate on
that but but yeah I I think uh I play a
little too much bullet in my spare time
you do bullets because you don't have
the time for longer games or because you
love them I think it's just I enjoy the
adrenaline rush games are over quickly
uh and and it can be reasonable chess
even I have had some pretty good games
but you know when you beat somebody and
there's only point three seconds left on
your clock there is nothing like that
feeling
and it shows it to the next uh decibel
place by the way so you'll have like
0.32 and I'm going yes
[Laughter]
I know someone else on the country panel
he was just like yeah yeah but uh um
yeah absolutely and Maurice of course
you are fantastic Grand Master as well I
mean what do you think about this game
between uh good cash and Magnus do you
think the good cash will be able to
squeeze something out of this position
yeah my feeling is that Magnus has
enough chances here to to keep the game
level it's uh it's just not enough the
white pawns are too weak it looks like
uh it's not much it's not much the night
is very Dynamic the bishop of course
will have a good Square on D4 but I just
think the weaknesses are enough Magnus
though is on the defensive clearly
there's only one player playing for the
win here and it's white
um but we'll see I I'd be curious if
Magnus slipped up in that c Pawn started
racing down the board just a little too
fast but the bishop does need a secure
Square as does the Knight by the way I
mean the Knight you know always needs an
anchor square of some kind but it seems
like the light squares the bishop can
never compete so it's not going to
overwhelm this piece and uh you're gonna
have to use a rook and a queen somehow
which means your Rook has to probably
leave the back crank I don't know it
doesn't feel as though it's it's quite
enough to handle all the issues in the
position to overwhelm Black's defense
I often find that this type of position
is where like your favorite subject
comes in chess geometry like all these
all this empty space it's just truly
fascinating you have to look for every
single possibility that's a great Point
uh I did a DVD for accessible I mean a
DVD of course in the old days of course
a video course with chessable shows my
age uh that talks about Chess
geometry and yes when the board is empty
like this it's important that the points
that are far afield you pay attention to
for example in this position the F7 Pawn
is connected to the A5 Pawn by the
square D5 and so the queen
pawn and the two pawns have this point
of concurrency I call it in the course
is that D5 Square so those things you
have to be very alert to I know Judith
is quite fantastic at finding those
points of concurrency uh she spots them
in seconds and probably that's now you
mention my favorite moment I wouldn't
say that's a favorite moment but
something that reminded me of something
I would put in the course maybe number
two my the second version was this
moment when irian could have played
Queen B4 Queen B2 and G3 very geometric
you have to spot this and and of course
you did spot it but that's that's the
kind of stuff that really separates the
top players and and the dynamic moments
that you used to see
are those geometric points yeah that's
very fascinating these points of
concurrency I've had fantastic reviews
about your course A lot of my friends
are saying they love it they have it on
repeat now the DVD version I made that
mistake as well
do you even have a DVD player no
and uh if we go back to the bird's eye
view do on any other games catch your
eye
well I think certainly the the big game
is the one between alares and Fabi right
like that one everybody's excited by and
right now it looks like a couple of
moves have happened since like since I
was watching
uh opposite colored Bishops uneven Pawn
structure white King's still in the
middle of the board this is all we could
dream of and I think black looked like
he had an edge and now I'm seeing this
move Queen A8 and the engine looks like
it doesn't like this move at all
but this is this is somebody's gonna win
though like this feels like somebody's
gonna win I don't see it being an easy
task for white to save this position
you've got the seventh rank under
control and did he actually take the
room he absolutely did
and so
something bad is happening to the white
King right I mean the first move that
screams out to be played is where it
takes porn thread and Checkmate only two
wow geometrical features all over the
place here absolutely
so Rook C2 what do we have Bishop D2 yes
and then Queen E4
let's jump in and show this on the board
yeah we need to calculate here Rook
takes C2 oh evaluation bar is gonna make
a mockery of us well it makes it it
makes it yeah I don't know it works the
other thing that I really I think we
need to pay attention to since the king
cannot cancel is the possibility of C5
Bishop B5 right or E5 Bishop G4 so this
bishop could feature in the queen at the
moment is not doing anything the White
Queen and even if you give it two moves
it doesn't do anything like Queen d8 uh
if the bishop moves then Queen E7
doesn't do anything because King G6 in
the in the piece is essentially safe
although it's starting to remind me of a
puzzle I created uh with F5 here at some
point
F5 and Queenie in Queen E8 isn't that
mate
uh it would be if the bishop wasn't
protecting so close protecting the
square but I have this I have this as a
puzzle it's almost reminded me of a
puzzle I gave the GM's but no so why is
it that that white is okay before before
this move or white is just lost in that
position it looks like Queen C2 live
position also a bishop did
there's so many choices this queen C2
this queen C3 this
yeah don't Castle now
[Laughter]
tutus and the evaluation bar is
approving
but what does it what's going on be ah
maybe bishop D2 it'll B1
oh wow so simple just Plumping up some
material
but maybe it's simply E5 and Bishop G4
but Castle is a threat Castle is a
threat Castle is a threat so maybe now
Queen E4
check
and let's say I move oh actually wait
there then Queen F4 whoops just in case
let's grab it this looks like pain yeah
so let's go to this square but now your
idea Maurice may be on the board
something with this bishop coming in and
C5 yeah C5
sc5 is deadly invite everyone to the
party but oh
if he survives this version it's gonna
be a miracle right absolutely
C2 is on the board Fabi he's worked it
all out you know him uh better than most
Maurice is this just the form of his
life right now
well I can't say that because he played
in the single field cup and won seven in
a row back in 2014 against this exact
kind of opposition so he is playing
absolute high level chess and play seven
one seven in a row to start the
competition by the way he's playing
great chess I think that he now is
catching his second wind he was at 28.30
Plus at one point and now he's 50 points
off his rating High which most of us
would just start crying if that happened
uh and he's such a fabulous player as
well he's number two in the wall for so
long I think he might be catching that
stride and I know for a fact that for
frabi it's world champion or bust
especially now that Magnus has advocated
the throne he's thinking I've gotta I've
got to show my stuff right now
particularly with all the young players
who are coming up time is ticking he's
in his 30s now he's broken broken that
bar you know as a chess player you start
saying okay what's what's the real deal
none of these old but for chess yeah
you're kind of old especially with all
these youngins I mean can you imagine
almost double the age of guccish that's
that's fine that's kind of scary and on
the subject of young talent I mean which
one of them all of them are incredibly
strong but which one do you have your
eye on especially
uh I think all of them are strong yes
but the one I really am impressed by
although I think he's not quite totally
stable yet is Abdus
he's he's just
he's has he has that intensity he has
the passion the desire he has the
fighting Spirit he comes back from Bad
positions that's a very big quality it
shows that he never gives up and he's
always looking for his chances and so I
think we've got to pay attention to him
I think in the next two three years he's
going to be showing us something special
okay well Maurice I would love I'd like
to say thank you so much for joining us
here in the studio and just entertaining
us with your comments and also giving us
all your thoughts and if anyone does
want us to support the lady Haiti then
uh please do so it's a fantastic course
and thank you so much thank you so much
for having me keep up the good work next
time you're annoyed make it longer
Maurice I will
oh and there we can see Armageddon is
gonna be coming there we see Anish giri
getting ready for his matchup
against Hikari Nakamura and they're the
players are we going to see a handshake
and they are off and to remind ourselves
of the rules of Armageddon the players
do keep their color so Anish will be
playing white as he is and he has 10
minutes on the clock as opposed to
hikaru's seven but Hikaru gets draw odds
and Hikaru is employing his favorite
defense the Berlin yep it's the Berlin
end game the Berlin Wall here and uh
Queen's off the board that means it was
interesting Anish giri nearly played a
move earlier just by hand by habit and
going into a fourth draw variation but
instead he remembered his preparation
went into this position and I've got to
say I'm surprised this is bread and
butter for Hikaru Nakamura Hikaru knows
everything there is to know pretty much
about this variation so Anish must have
prepared an extremely deep line and okay
we are now at move 13 and the players
finally pausing for breath finally
pausing For Thought Judith you went into
this end game when you
I had a very similar game with Gary
but I think I went with the somehow I
had with Knight C3 and knight uh E2
Knight D4 and Knight F5 I was reaching
out
or from G3 I don't know but it's uh
something very similar not G3 Knight F5
yeah Knights and F5 in any position it's
uh very promising for white absolutely
do you think this is a good choice for
Armageddon chess must win situation it
has such a drawish reputation this type
of uh this type of position
price that
this choice I must say but uh if he has
the self-confidence and he thinks that
he will outplay Hikaru
then
why not why not yeah
[Laughter]
I wouldn't have enough
self-confidence to
I mean back when I was still in
competition I don't think I would have
the
the courage to decide this way that if I
have a must win situation I really enter
into this end game
and I must admit I'm just trying to kind
of go back in my mind here and I don't
recall that many occasions when uh
anishagiri has actually entered the end
game uh entered this Berlin endgame so
it must be very specific targeted
preparation against the current but
these days he's just getting off the
queen I mean look at the games here you
don't pay attention for a minute 50
minutes and the Queens are off
who needs Queens anyway overrated pieces
but uh okay Hikaru is starting the
action on the queen side with A5 black
does need some activity he's got the
bishop pair so he would love to push
even further open up the a file for The
Rook potentially but Anish just ignoring
it getting ready to stack up his Rooks
on the D file instead
I quite like it for white I mean I've
played the Berlin my whole life as black
and it feels like one of the positions
where black is lacking any activity at
all well the question is whether first
of all is he going to go for A4 and
simplify this is always a question and
he does
and the big debate is also always about
the King on E8 how does that going to
allow the two Rooks to be connected
and it might be your plan there we go
Anish retreating his Knight getting
around to F5 as you indicated sometimes
to H5 but of course I rather like it
than F5 and if he goes Nakamura plays G6
it comes back to E4 possibly Knight F6
check at some point at the same time
black can run king of Fate King G7
do you think anisha's strategy is maybe
not to get like a great position out of
the opening but instead just to be able
to draw it out until the very end so you
know
I often see this approach in Armageddon
you either go all out for the win as
quickly as possible or you go for the
very long game where you can make many
many moves with no time on the clock
well it's important to be able to make
many many moves and try to make your
opponent to go wrong and make mistakes
and sometimes unnecessary mistakes are
played but it's not so easy to get those
kind of positions because here for
example black just plate can get fed
ghost King G7 immediately brings the
rule going to be exchanging 8X B3 and
it's not always that you have this
resource that okay I'm just going to
play around right you have to come up
with an idea he's going to play Bishop
E3 F4 Bishop C5 exchanging the black
Square Bishop
coming up King H2 King G3 possibly so
Bishop E3 on the board yeah Alice Davis
indicating he is threatening to play
Bishop C5 and trade off those dark
squared Bishops
and you mentioned the phrase draw it out
give anchor and I think that might be
unfortunate an unfortunate use of words
draw it out and uh I would think Hikaru
is odds on for the draw here just I
don't know even if it went slightly
wrong maybe for a couple of moves it
feels like Hikaru is now stabilized and
I think just giving black that extra two
moves that extra two Tempe with the
white knight dropping back then coming
back to E4 I think this is actually a
really useful inclusion uh G6 and King
G7 for black suddenly everything is
covered Black's going to open the AFL is
true Dimension bring the Rook maybe to
A2 or just simply trade off all the
Rooks on the D file and can you break
that Fortress well what white should be
playing for I guess to play somehow F4
F5 by any means but how is it how to do
it right so F4 King G7 let's say Rook F1
is possible
and
or maybe yeah somehow it should be or a
four even Knight C3 forcing black to
capture on B3
and then probably he has this other idea
wants to go 90 to Knight F4 of course
that's a great location for the night
bothering the E6 Bishop
he's going round with that Knight now uh
really nice maneuver there from Gary the
reason I fear is that
such reduced material yes Nakamura has
some kind of tough questions to answer
now but if he can answer them over the
next five or six moves he should be fine
so for Niche the stakes are extremely
high in the immediate future now black
can play maybe bishop D5 Knight F4 and
Bishop moves away to F3 or E4
but now it's a critical moment I think
for black whether how can he handle and
play against Knight F4
the one thing you really cannot allow as
black is a night trade for one of your
Bishops especially the light squared
Bishop if the knight ever captures then
the white Rooks will pour in through the
D7 Square also structurally you'll be
suffering long term even if all the
Rooks leave the board
was for example what can happen is like
Rook hd8 let's say or Rook 88 it's
always a debate of course which Rook to
bring but he goes Bishop C8 immediately
I found that the moves a bit surprising
I thought that he was actually going to
play C5 to take away the D4 square and
uh meet Knight F4 with Bishop down to
its starting Square
yeah so now he wants to meet I guess a
move like Knight D4 by just defending
that pawn you don't really want to allow
the white knight in
it's really strange though I think after
Knight D4 C5 he wants to be playing so
after Knight B5 Bishop A6 is an option
for Knight C6 E8
and uh just to confirm that it was a
draw between Ari and tari and Wesley so
that means those two will also be
heading to Armageddon in approximately
20 minutes as well
yep the results are coming in more chess
ahead of us firstly Anish improves the
white king
he's doing well though he's keeping the
tension he hasn't allowed any of those
immediate trades if all the Rooks
disappeared black would be very happy
the bishop pair should compensate for
the inferior Pawn structure here he's
just playing with his kingside majority
and she's getting ready for your idea
Judith starting to push forward with F4
coming next maybe I was too harsh on his
winning chances he's doing a good job of
making progress
well finally black was able to secure
his King and bring out the Rook from h8
to E8 it took him quite a few moves I
must say at the same time black is not
active anymore right I mean look all the
pieces are on the base rank finally
white plays F4 and if once white will be
able to break through and reach F5 after
Rook F1 defending the E5 Pawn first then
white can have finally a real Advantage
but maybe not F5 first maybe he's going
to play Knight C3 Knight E4 first and
only in a later stage wants to be
improving it with F5 that looks like a
very dangerous idea though
the white Knight's already been on e4
twice though so it would take a stronger
man than me to maneuver back around
again and Anish he needs to move now he
has kept an advantage on the clock a
significant Advantage I like the pace
he's using Judy you mentioned it
backfired in previous days in some of
anisha's armageddon's but here it could
be vital now maybe black is thinking of
playing G5 at some point and breaking up
the white bone structure because the E5
Pawn can get in trouble if the F4 Pawn
is moved away
maybe F6 also really it also works out
critical moment now you feel like for
Anish Gary
this white knight not doing too much
maybe it needs to be improved maybe
bring it into D4 now it's possible to
play also Knight C3 with an idea if you
go G5 I'm sacrificing a pawn by playing
Knight D4 and if F take G takes F4
Bishop F4 probably Bishop E5
is maybe not very good because text give
a check on d8 and white gets very active
and the Knight can be very unpleasant
possibly on F6 or not G3 Knight H5
just lots of dark squares if even if
black wins are Pawn in some of those
lines
yeah I agree just move the knights I'm
inclined towards Knight D4 because I'm a
cheapo Merchant as they say a one move
threats just try and take a pawn but
and ic3 also very logical here he slowed
down though Niche I think we shouldn't
forget that Hikaru is not very good so
far in the tournament in the Armageddon
I think he lost twice and this is the
third Armageddon he also said it somehow
the Armageddon doesn't work on his way
so far
yeah he lost to Wesley he lost a Magnus
in Armageddon games this time though at
least he's solid and okay a niche
stepping forward H4 all the pawns
running and striking out on the other
side it's like you just saw it being
awarded a question mark from the game
review and also miss for Hikaru I mean
the kind of move that immediately jumps
out to me after you make the moves H4 is
just to go G5 and undermine those Pawns
and also sometimes H5 can be considered
to create the F5 square foot of white
for the black white square Bishop
but now there is very important Square
oh D5 was weakness now the D6 square is
a huge weakness C5 is also a huge
weakness and Hikaru speeding up how many
moves are we away from move 40 because
on move 41 the players will start to be
getting their one second increment only
move 33. okay getting in the air
one second will be vital for these
players as the clocks tick down White
Knight is on a proud beautiful square
right now on D6 a nice Outpost but what
to do next Black's light squared Bishop
is holding everything together it's the
glue in Black's position and very
interesting decision by right playing G5
so forever black cannot think of moving
the F7 Bishop no to F5 nor to F6
it's a very committed move this is very
interesting that the it was exchanged on
G5 because one day maybe if white can
double The Rook on the H file and jump
into F6 with the Knight I know many
moves has to be taken and then until
that point but it can be dangerous
sometimes for black
and uh initial moving his Pawn up the
board it really does feel like Hikaru
isn't full on grovel mode he's just
simply trying to withstand the storm and
I like this next move you know just
saying if you're going to trade Rooks it
has to be on my terms but a niche he
seems in full control
the question is whether it's going to be
enough or no Bishop f8 I don't know of
course that F6 square is incredible for
white just to visualize it that one day
the Knight jumps to F6 it can give real
trouble for black but for the moment he
goes Knight B7 so to go Knight d8 or
Knight A5 we're just opening up the line
on the D file okay and some hesitation
we saw on the camera there from Nakamura
he does plug the open default with his
light Square Bishop he's allowing a
trait of dark squared Bishops though so
no more Bishop pair for uh black also
the White Knight should stand quite well
on Dart squares but maybe there's no
breakthrough hikaru's arguing he's built
he's built a fortress he holds the only
other open file the a file unless white
can work some magic there and pieces
flying on the board they are certainly
flying and I think Hikaru also had a big
threat of playing Rook A2 and uh using
the Rick and Bishop more 41 so the
players are spoiled they get one second
move from here
hit that one second because he has just
over 25 minutes
you know I think you have to do
something you have to sacrifice here but
it's also very dangerous because the two
Rooks will be very active of black
yeah but they're going to be active
anyway dude and also King E6 can get
five coming up with the king so white is
getting a first position now typically
you can see the Knight on A5 Bishop on
D5 is just favors black so much yeah I
think that's where Anish went wrong he
needs to win so he took a risk he put
his Knight on the edge of the board but
it has backfired his Knight now has no
influence and black is coming in from
both sides of the board
that white king is living a Charmed
existence even if black does start
advancing as you say Judah in the near
future it looks really promising now for
Hikaru I think he'll first improve one
of his Rooks and uh the one thing hikara
has to avoid is trading off all the
Rooks white tonight will come back to
dark squares good night versus bad
Bishop but
um yeah as long as he keeps one set of
Rooks on the board black is Super Active
no weaknesses the bishop holds
everything together
and a draw does favor Black so he can
run away from these trades force a niche
to repeat
winning chances dwindling
totally uh Hikaru now in full control
and somehow you want to magically
transport that King on G3 to C5 and then
you know be a different situation but
that king is not going to run there well
now black species are simply much more
active the Rooks the king is also
potentially reaching out L5 and the
bishop we are going to probably see a
trade of Rooks because the niche is
forced to keep blocking that Renegade
Rook on A1 but doesn't want the
exchange of Rooks he just wants to
repeat the position and while second
time we've seen this position and
eventually Anish has to gamble he has to
go for the win a draw is no good and he
gives up one of his Rooks for that proud
black Bishop but Judy you've called it
those black Rooks so active some check
mating threats on the cards and that A5
Knight is so badly placed
Rook D6 now black will be going back
with his King
I was thinking of uh F5 or something but
you cannot even do these kind of things
too
yeah
Karu got White's Rook off the board the
black king is going to come in Black
looks like he's winning this position
the evaluation bar is still not reacting
maybe he's building a fortress but white
will never win this position oh yeah
that's for sure it's going to be some
kind of position and D7 and then King E6
plenty of time for hikara as well he
does have that one second increment and
he does have just under one minute on
the clock
this is why I fears for a niche out of
the opening Hikaru is so good in these
types of end games
he's trying his best in here she's gone
Pawn hunting with the white knight but
White's pawns also dropping and he won't
be left with enough winning material
another Pawn will fall off the board
will we see a handshake from Anish
any moment now trying some last tricks
but White's only left with a pawn uh the
White Knight on its own will not deliver
chat mate and
okay Hikaru playing for the win not
trying to eliminate that white Pawn
he doesn't just want a draw now
yeah
I mean if yeah there you go we see that
the game has finished and Hikaru wins
the Armageddon walks away with one and a
half points and there you can see the
players discussing the game
well played by Hikaru just resourcefully
holding tight his position was the Anish
put him under tremendous pressure
yeah it would have been easy to get into
trouble as black in those difficult end
game positions but Hikaru stayed calm
and when he got his opportunity when
white put his Knight on the edge of the
board he worked his magic Judah really
nice performance there yeah absolutely
it was a great performance by Nakamura
strange Choice kind of by Anish going
into this end game because Hikaru is a
very stable player and and he feels I
think pretty comfortable also to play
out the Berlin and games
that means we have a three classical
games remaining and checking out the
bird's eye view I see it is a queen and
porn ending for kukash against Magnus
whereas the real
the game where everyone had their eyes
on between alireza farouza and Fabiana
caruana it has followed that line that
we indicated early on with Maurice
yeah and uh we know that this is
potentially decisive on the tournament
standings shall we check in there it
feels like Fabiano has a knockout blow
he has a winning move but he has paused
right now for 10 minutes he's trying to
work out all of the details we did
predict this position uh here with
Maurice Maurice was trying to get this
black Bishop into the game that feels
like it could be the final ingredient in
a winning attack but how to do it and uh
how to just break White's defenses here
currently black is a rook down so time
is of the essence
C5 you want to come out with a check
and I remember we highlighted this and
the evaluation bar didn't approve for
some mysterious reason maybe it just
gives white enough time to push the pawn
and run away
was it here that C5 was not good enough
yeah so maybe you should do a check
first right win the three yeah
and then I guess you have if you go King
F2 I it's more than sufficient right to
go root takes Bishop
I'm hoping I think so I think so right
that's why I would guess it so if you
have to go King E1
no C5 or E5 that's enough oh and Bishop
G4
yeah so we can open up the bishop this
direction we can open up the bishop this
direction you just have to choose here
if you're Fabby Queen and Rook alone
unlikely to deliver checkmate
where is the win he's doing the right
thing this is great and instructive for
everyone just he knows displays Queen D3
Chuck he's precise all the time
he's precise and also he knows he has to
drop his sleeve so it's easier to
sacrifice a rook if you know you can
repeat moves uh just in case if
everything goes wrong you can give a
couple of Queen checks but of course he
wants more so let's see what is the move
C5 what can I do against that
five again it depends on whether the
White Queen can come back in time maybe
give some checks
28 Bishop B5 Queen E7 King G6 and white
can take this pawn queen takes E6 at the
end
and
maybe C5 between the eight and maybe
just to show Bishop B5 does threaten
Checkmate in one but it does allow the
White Queen to check and come back
covering this Square
um so Judy you wanted something else in
this position
no it seems like it doesn't work
uh maybe now we give the check we need
fourth check ah because now
yeah
King F2 walks into Queen takes Pawn
check due to this pin the white Bishop
cannot take the queen
this looks decisive and yeah if you go
to F1
key detail is now there's a check and
this will be Checkmate next move killer
on the diagonals
do you think that's going to be found
I'm sure I mean here he has to be
calculating all the possibilities and
there is not much I believe
I mean you have this queen E4 idea you
have C5 E4
and uh
and you have to check Queen E4 in every
every move after C5 before C5 but now
that would be a repetition
you tried to go via E4 with the black
queen now it feels like he's got the
perfect square C5 is this just the end
how does white stop this
I didn't see it could I can't bring my
rook in just to show The Rook can try to
defend but now the king gets actually
trapped within its own uh within its own
pieces
Checkmate coming next move
no problem yeah could you just run away
well king after Rook D2
any time in these positions yeah King F2
will be met by a capture and black
simply has too many pawns and it will
likely end in Checkmate anyway
wow what a game by far what a brilliant
brilliant idea brilliant choice of
opening as well you know just to go into
a type of position whereas you would all
you would think that a farooja would be
in his element but Fabi had it all
worked out very impressive
that's the thing the top players well
players in general they want to be the
ones attacking defending his heart and
this is one of those cases for usually
grabbing a rook but likely to be
punished certainly and it's all to do
with the fact that White's pieces are
just badly placed
under there we see
Ali Reza farouza and Fabiana caruana
just sitting there Fabi contemplating
calculating those lines
and we're going to leave those players
there because we are joined by a very
special guest in our studio
we've nicknamed you our fourth camera
commentator but really you're just Grand
Master extraordinaire Hikaru Nakamura
Hikaru congratulations on that victory
in the Armageddon
yeah be like that unless it's a smooth
one-way game for for the player with the
black pieces um but I think in the game
it was very messy and then towards the
other certain point where I was able to
start playing quicker after I played
this whole B5 C6 and once I was able to
start making moves instantly I think I
need to kind of fell apart and I feel
that if I get to those situations where
I can make a lot of moves very quickly
I'm going to win a lot of the Armageddon
games
um that being said like the game against
Wesley should have been pretty similar
and I I found a way to lose that one but
overall I'm quite happy with my plan
that's you know the classical portion
matters more than anything else
and so you you mentioned that in the
confessional that the classical game was
all preparation well up to a point yeah
I mean there was a game between uh I
think ferrugia and pragnan turned this
line before
um obviously like I play a little bit of
everything I play the Sicilian in the
American Cup back in March and uh also
in the chest challenge tour I played
this wrestling along with E5 multiple
times against Fabiano and others and I
think for Anish who wasn't expecting me
to play this G6 variation and I mean
it's it's sort of the same problem I had
against Magnus in the third round where
when I played Magnus I could only look
at so many different openings and so for
Anish there's only so many things he
could look at
um and he didn't look at this and so he
had to fall back on a line that he knew
quite well and unfortunately for him it
was the line that I was more or less
expecting and so it was just very very
easy for me to hold and I mean I think
with three blocks not really being in
much danger I mean okay the good cash
game was a little bit up and down but
just not being in a lot of danger it's
been very uh very good so far hmm and
your Armageddon game I mean were you
surprised that he played into your
Berlin your favorite defense
um not super surprised I think the end
game maybe I suspect it's actually more
favorable in a five versus four than in
a ten versus seven if I had to guess um
and the main reason is because I felt
that he was up about a minute or two
minutes but he had to sort of find moves
and that I think the moment the critical
moment hit about seven minutes or six
and a half minutes I had about like four
and a half maybe and you have to use
that time if you don't find the win
right there then then the player with a
black piece has too much time or is in a
five versus four I think it would have
been down to like three two and a half
it would have been a lot trickier to
defend um but I think the main thing is
that when he didn't find the clearest
idea and then I just played this B5 line
which I actually didn't know if it was
good or not good but when I played this
whole whole B5 C6 all my moves I could
play in one second and when I can start
playing the moves instantly then Anish
has to think it just starts going the
wrong direction I think that's generally
the theme of Armageddon for the player
with the white piece if you don't have
the quick moves and like the player with
the black piece can make a lot of quick
moves it just becomes very difficult um
yeah so it is what it is it is yeah and
and uh so in general with this format do
you prefer the black side of the
Armageddon I mean I think I will always
prefer the black side of the Armageddon
no matter what
um again I think if I look at it
realistically I mean the game against
Wesley should have won that Armageddon
obviously I didn't win it um then it
gets Magnus with the white piece I got
absolutely nothing so I think black is a
big advantage in general but but again
it also depends how fast you are how
much Blitz you play in these these
different things but I I will always
take black and Armageddon game if given
the choice yeah and how are you feeling
about this tournament in general I mean
there are two ways of looking at the
first one is to look at the objective
overall score and the standings the
second one is to look at the classical
portion and just sort of exclude the
whole Armageddon
um circus and I think for me I I just
look at the classical portion more than
anything else and I've played pretty
well I I think I haven't done anything
too stupid and that's that's my goal so
I feel like overall I mean I'm playing
as well as I can playing if if you know
if someone if some of the players are
going to win all their games in the
classical portion like that's just how
it goes um you know like Fabiano if he
he wins again I think it's gonna be very
very difficult to catch him yeah and uh
it's certainly looking promising in the
Fabiana game is this a king's Gambit
you're right Hikaru we have a second
Kings Gambit in the tournament
we have to ask what inspired that
against Magnus uh well the main thing
that inspired is I actually I prepared
for the chest shamans Tour event the one
which I played here from Stavanger I
prepared it for uh faruja and then in
the game farooja didn't play E5 against
me so it was sort of a half preparation
half inspired idea and then because I
prepared it for for that match and the
champions tour I decided to use it
because why not and besides it makes for
good content anyway and and uh yeah but
it looks like I mean I'm kind of
surprised though because this variation
was this was the whole this was the D5
variation right the whole D5 Bishop B5
line and I mean it's it's completely
fine for black but I actually feel like
tari has a lot more than than I mean if
I could have gotten this position
against magnus's wide I would have been
very very happy so I'm surprised
well are you impressed though that
Ariana's followed your lead well
actually he's doing exactly the same
thing because he also played this D3
line in Marshall so although I was
confused by what he did um because he
couldn't he could have like killed that
game and then at some point he was
slightly worse uh which we're really it
just really confused me because like
when Magnus played Queen H4 against me
obviously this line lead to a force draw
um but I I think the rationale behind
like not playing Queen Shores to play
something else where the game goes on
but of course the reason Magnus didn't
do it against me is because you can kill
it with the white piece or blacks
nothing but then when Wesley did Aryan
like he killed it but then he didn't
kill it when when uh Wesley didn't play
the absolute main line so I was a little
bit confused by that but I mean I know
that aryan's a fan he watches watched my
stream quite a bit so it's not too
surprising but I do hope for his sake he
can win this because he's been quite
unlucky in the tournament I mean he was
completely blowing Notre back off the
board and then he didn't play his Queen
before Queen B2 I don't I don't even
know why but uh for his sake I hope he
can find a way because he's a very very
good player and I think uh score it
doesn't really reflect how well he's
played
and what do you think about his chances
here
I don't know if I like uh I mean it
feels like somehow Bishop A1 this whole
thing with this queen E6 Bishop E7 I
feel like it's gotten better for Wesley
than it was before that being said I
mean if you play Knight takes Knight
takes off six Bishop takes off six
Bishop C3 E4 is probably the idea here
so
if that's the idea you kind of have to
stop it
um I don't like that because now after
Bishop takes but because if you get
Bishop F6 Bishop C3 with the queen on e4
I think white is clearly better here but
now after Pusher takes off six
maybe ah maybe you can play rookie one
Rook before Gypsy three then Bishop C3
Rook A4 and King B2 but then there's
their tricks
I mean this this game I think really the
next couple of moves are absolutely
critical
um
I'm shocked that Wesley hasn't taken
with the bishop yet because if you play
Pawn takes Bishop C3 the diagonal
towards h8 just I mean optically it
looks insane to play that so okay it
does take with the bishop rookie one
played I mean maybe Rook before the
ideas to play Bishop takes E5 also
yeah this position I'm starting to like
it more and more
um for Ariane here because
okay Rook Cafe it looks like the correct
book says Bishop C3 again runs into E4
and if Queenie for those Rook before
always
maybe here you can play D3 maybe D3 Rook
before
King B1 something like this I
mean the supposition I'd love to have
half an hour to think with the white
pieces so I I mean of course I can't
tell what the bar is saying but
intuitively it feels like white should
be better here but it feels like it's
something where you need time to think
it just my intuition tells me why it
should be better but I I don't see it in
a split second and you don't really have
the time to think and now after E4 I
think Wesley's getting all the counter
play uh probably takes with a pawn
because you take the queen there might
be Queen C4
or before Queen C5
we're heading in that direction
still tricky though still tricky still a
lot of play here
like Rook before Queen C5 rookie five
Queen A7 so probably Rook before maybe
just queen queen A6 even
guns
but yeah it feels to me like it fills me
like um like tari's misplayed this like
there's probably something in that
critical moment I'm not sure what but it
feels like it and I think the bar
actually was saying white was better
right yeah significantly yeah
yeah it comes back to what I've said I
mean it's there's certain positions
where you can sort of intuitively you
can feel like there's something there
you don't quite know what it is but you
can sort of feel like it has to be
better apparently rookie 5 is a blunder
I don't know why or I mean this could be
the chest chest chess.com engine
um maybe there was just something
stronger it doesn't look like it loses
anything yeah but Queen A7 just even
just H6 H5 black this is the pro this is
the problem the blacks must become too
easy this is the exact problem black and
play H5 G5 G4 you can go Rook G5 you
have very minimal plans to consider here
antaria has to figure out what even his
plan is
ah C3 ah
C3 whoa
oh and look at this double question mark
from Black's move here Wesley's
blundered his Rook it's trapped oh
oh he misses it oh
and we see the cross there because he
missed the opportunity to trap that
black Rook on B4 that that's so easy to
miss but huge opportunity that would
have that would have won the game he
would have won the game up two minutes
upper rookie would have won there that's
that's really uh really tragic
yeah now e takes D3 ah but after Rook D3
it still goes on though I mean the the
end game's not dead now again
now it's not dead because black doesn't
have the central plot doesn't have the
past e-pawn anymore I mean I assume it's
still after rookie four but
okay takes Queen C6 Rook uh rookie one
maybe then Rook C3 rookie two G3
can you try to okay Queen C3 and yeah
that's I was saying Queen yeah seven
Queen C6 rookie one Queen C3 takes takes
rookie two G3 maybe but G3 F3 King B2 F2
Rook Rook F3 is probably winning for
white so
um
yeah this this this goes on I think
probably what we'll get is Queen A8 King
H7 Queen C6 rookie two
wow ah he's going for Queen D3 rook d8
and queen D3
I mean it's it's a try but this doesn't
look
doesn't look right it doesn't look right
okay
and tomorrow you'll be playing White
against Ariane so what are your thoughts
on that
um I mean he's obviously the lowest
rated player in the tournament so I I
will definitely have to take my chances
um but again I think if you try to just
prepare something play something and
hopefully a bit of a surprise I mean
we'll we'll see okay and uh also we're
very appreciative of your your
confessionals and of course there are
thousands of viewers watching your
streams and enjoying that as well so do
you have a message for them well I don't
think there's a message but I know some
people thought that I was doing it just
because I can't help myself but I mean
that actually isn't the reason I've been
doing it simply because uh I feel like
it's something that's good for the fans
to have some idea of what's going on
obviously for me it's very natural to do
anyway but I think it's something that
you know I've said this before
um I think I've said this quite a few
times but fundamentally if I if I look
at chess the game just if you if someone
comes off the street and they don't know
anything about Chess they see two people
sitting down playing a game they're
gonna find it very boring they're
they're gonna understand what what's
going on what what is this it has no
meaning per se so I think for me when I
think about the bigger picture you know
you have to try and make it interesting
you have to make it more accessible and
so for someone who's watching the
commentary
um and they want to get some insight by
doing that I'm giving them an idea of
what's happening I think it's really
really critical and I kind of wish some
some of the other players would do it
but you know there's only so much you
can ask for at the end of the day yeah I
know it's a very good point there and uh
Hikaru thank you so much for joining the
show thank you so much for doing your
entertaining confessionals and we wish
you good luck and hope to hear more from
you thank you so much
thanks and uh meanwhile okay this end
game has really livened up it's a race
at this point Black's F Pawn running
White's a pawn running Anything Could
Happen the clocks are getting low Wesley
down to two minutes but he does have the
valuable one second increment just now
that they've passed move 40 and Aryan
fighting for his life it feels like he's
lost control dude
has it all gone wrong for white or is he
still in this White's apron dangerous
and game they say that
say that end game is a draw
as it's not
and when there are pawns running around
and there is a race you can go wrong in
any second
I must say and I don't see exactly how
white wants to play probably A7
which after rookie 8 for example Rook A6
then F2 then he can go go back
the black has an extra Pawn but it's not
clear whether he will be able to to
convert it
and uh well big threat on the board of
A7 so that's why Wesley locks The Rook
down to the seventh row oh and Wesley's
King is now marching up the board
Off to the Races again well then now
it's an interesting idea maybe to go to
F6 and after H5 to go Rook F5
because the king is tied down a bit to
the H5 bone after that
which maybe black should be sacrificing
after King comes through H2 and G2
H3 and G2 oh he's going with the white
king Aryan but this is a very slow plan
black looks ahead here in the race uh
it's just shocking to me that the
evaluation bar is in the center because
this looks anything but drawn it feels
like one side is going to be a head here
but he simply wants to win that black
Rook he wants to push his a pawn forward
the black Rook will have to give it his
life up and then the white C Pawn runs
Black's got two past pawns though and
Wesley doesn't have any time to
calculate just over one minute now
Ariana minute up on the clock and that
could be vital well it can easily happen
that we end up in an end game where
black has only a pawn pawn versus a
queen and uh actually I I don't
understand why white went all the way
too
yes A7
yep and Black's Rook has to give itself
up now
surely
White's about to make a new Queen Wesley
just doing some calculation I think it's
a great drive but uh sorry was just
doing but oh but
it's gonna be a race and the white king
is on a square where the black pawn is
now threatening to promote with a nasty
check if the white King was anywhere
else white would be doing well suddenly
but he can go on G1 check G1 always
comes with a check once black makes a
new Queen the white king is hit maybe he
missed this yeah and uh there we can see
that our evaluation bar is actually more
table based bar because it when there
are less than seven pieces on the board
chess has basically been solved and
there we can see it is completely in
Wesley's favor
for What's Happening Here the white Pawn
is running and very quickly yeah but
actually to maybe black wins yeah
although
well suddenly I'm not so sure we might
even get a queen game can't you go King
G3
and it's a Bishop's Pawn so you can just
give up the rook and just push the pawn
to C7 even if black makes a queen first
it's just a dead draw no just take that
one
and push to C7 there's going to be still
mating ideas queen versus porn queen
against Bishop's Pawn is a well-known
draw no
is not playing for a draw
oh wait sorry of course
oh poor Ariane he found a way to save
the game from maybe a lost position but
yeah I was met by silence I was like
wait what have I missed that draw but of
course a draw counts as a win for Wesley
and there we go handshake stalemate
and Wesley takes the points yeah it will
be another happy moment when tari will
get to know that he missed winning a
rook in one move with C3
heartbreak it is uh heartbreaking I was
very unlucky for Aryan but uh so be it
that is the rules of the game he does
take a share of the points he walks away
with one point and Wesley so will net
one and a half points for that
Armageddon Victory and it's so nice
despite all the emotion of Armageddon
that the players are sat there analyzing
their game
and eventually the players do get up
most likely they're interested in what's
going on in the other boards if we uh
zoom out again there's so much action
everywhere here in Stavanger at no HS
and we have two results we have two
armageddings locked in three games still
in progress it looks like we might see a
decided decisive result though any
second now our leader Fabiano caruana
about to take yet another win
and uh he's just a bit so impressive so
far his technique has been Flawless
Judith is he going to close it out
well I don't think that he's going to
miss anything in this game when he plays
one of the best game of his life I
believe because it was a brilliant Rook
sacrifice what he did he played very
well and actually he plays incredibly
well all the way from the very start of
this tournament ah absolutely incredibly
impressive game and there with that
check are we going to see a result I
think we're also going to see a result
elsewhere between mama jarov and Abdul
sotorov they're about to repeat moves
and agree a draw any second so that
looks like the next game to finish while
we await developments uh between
farrugia and karuana we'll go in a
deeper dive any moment now but there we
see just this very second mamajorov has
agreed the draw with Abdul satoroph
simply nothing to do in that end game
great defense actually In The End by
Mama jar of who's a pawn down but found
enough activity to hold the result to
hold the ballots a fantastic defense by
my and that means we will see our third
Armageddon of the day in approximately
20 minutes
whereas two games still remaining
Fabiano looks like he's putting it in
the back of the net against uh alireza
fuja but Magnus Carlsen still playing
a queen ending against kukash
but still it's it's interesting how
Fabiano is going to be winning right
because I
you have a feeling for it and the bar
goes down very low but black has three
pawns for the exchange but the question
is what is the best way of winning right
can black give checks and does it lead
anywhere
that's the first question maybe Queen E3
queen king H2 Queen E5 check
and then uh and the King keeps running
King G1 then E1 and queen H4 at least
I'm winning a pawn though I'm not 100
sure that it's so good for black because
suddenly the H1 Rook can be powerful
he's doing the same thing oh yeah this
is much easier this is a much easier way
of doing it of course check on H4 then
and then eventually maybe he will just
grab the D6 Pawn right and it just has
nothing better and he just has to make
sure that his Queen can hold that
contact point with the G7
square and it's all good
just grabbing all the pawns it's like a
windmill here it's like a ferris wheel
almost he's just going round and round
with the black queen winning all these
pawns and now he can give another check
via F4 or E5 grab this D6 pawn and yes
the white Rook might get active but it
looks like too many Pawns
there is one tiny trap that I can see
so for instance if you were to go Queen
takes Pawn on D6
yep
C6 I think we'll be uh no there's no
trap I'm hallucinating there we go
another Pawn drops is currently six
points against one for Fabi but one of
those will drop now so after Rook H7 is
it 23 well takes H7 is impossible black
plays Queen f8 And Trades off the Queens
yeah so kabina faith is uh is the other
movement probably does the simplest yeah
why it has to just take that pawn with
the queen now
yeah and uh Fabi plenty of time eight
minutes
not plenty of oh sorry 17 minutes for
Fabi eight minutes oh sorry yes my
apologies
yeah he's been playing every move
instantly because he's had no other
legal move it's so depressing when your
opponent just gives you no option other
than to just hope for the draw hope for
the repetition and this is the uh
remnants of what has happened
oh he does play Rook takes Pawn at least
creating a threat mate in one Rook takes
G7 threatened but Moment of Truth Judit
do you think he's gonna go active with
the black queen or trade off
Trader
cynical but effective and we see a
resignation
what a game beautiful again
I
to me it was Perfection like from the
choice of opening
to the way he handled the complications
wonderful wonderful game by Fabiano
caruana and well he's racing ahead
ten and a half points
wow
with the black pieces against firoza
it is quite something yeah oh and on
that note I think it's time for us to
take a breather and we will see you
shortly in a few minutes with some more
of the thrilling action
trash kit is fun Jess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing
which has a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest bustles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
foreign
so I loved puzzles I loved solving any
puzzle you put in front of me so chess
was unnatural for my brain it was the
unsolvable puzzle it wasn't one of those
things you just looked at here is the
puzzle what's the solution it it was a
puzzle inside of an enigma inside of a
mystery like what is this game and there
was so much to it the more you learned
the more there was to learn so that
puzzle solving uh gift that I had or
desire wish you know I would do
crossword puzzles back in the day as
well as a little as a high school kid
fell in love with New York Times
crossword puzzles had to do one of those
every every day that the puzzle came out
in the paper so I always was a puzzle
solver and I think that that made it
easy for me to to transfer over that
skill set to chess
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
no way land of fjords Majestic mountains
Cliffs and waterfalls
in addition to stunning geography Norway
is home to the greatest chess player who
has ever lived Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best from Carlson's fiercest online
rival today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps lodibeck Abdul
sotorov and kukesh domaraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023 Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana
two more long-time Headliners seek to
take their next turn Atop A major
tournament Wesley so and Shakira
mamagyarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field who will
come out on top will Carlson run the
table yet again or will someone else
usurp the throne this is Norway chess
welcome back and it's time to reignite
that chess fire as the Norway chess
round four continues and there we see
the playing venue where Magnus Carlson
and gukash are in action and here in the
studio we are joined by a very special
guest it is a privilege to have here
with us Fabiano caruana and you just
defeated
um alireza faroogia and all I can say is
what a game that works to Perfection
yeah it was a very strange game I I'd
surprised him in the opening for sure I
don't play this line I don't play the
French too much in fact
um and he played a very dangerous line
but another one that I really remember
the details but then he played this
crazy move Knight D6
um I didn't even understand like it's
it's I'm not in danger after that it's
like maybe best case he's a bit worse in
worst case he just loses on the spot
um because I am two pawns up and I
didn't see his compensation I thought he
can castle and okay I was gonna bail out
with Queen C4 I thought it's that's why
I played Bishop D7 uh I thought the end
game he's probably equalizing but I I
wasn't opposed to a draw and then he
played Knight D6 and I had my choice of
like Queen B4 instead of F6 or okay F6
looked really
really natural and um yeah the rest of
the game was pretty smooth he even
blundered at the end Rook H7 I mean at
least Queen H7
the Fight Continues I'm I still have to
work for it uh he missed Rook at Queen
of theta like as soon as he played it I
saw on his face that he he had
immediately seen it Bobby you mentioned
uh Knight D6 is maybe the critical
moment did you see any way back from him
uh for him from that
not really so I was I was looking at
Castle
um I mean I have so many options I guess
I guess I'm okay in many ways but Queen
C4 I just I didn't want to play with my
king in the center with Queens on like
Queen D2 I think is not good for him
because I can take on D4 Play Bishop B4
or something so I thought he'll take on
C4
um yeah I think I thought that this was
good for black
did I miss something or oh no I didn't
think he did I just changed the position
sorry so Queen takes C4 detect C4
Edition as a bailout yeah I think okay
he takes on C6 BC 96 I guess it's about
equal
and I was happy that in case of like any
other move
like if he doesn't take on C6 and plays
F5 for example
uh I can take on D4 and I have this nice
little trick if if Knight D4 if Rook D4
then Bishop C5
uh
and if he takes on D7 takes Bishop C5
King C6
and I pick up a piece so I thought okay
it's it's
it looks like a safe end game and I I
really didn't I was kind of worried when
he went for the sacrifice because
I I knew that it was possible I didn't
remember any details uh after Rook D1 I
remembered Rook B3 is kind of the most
popular move
and
um yeah so I just wanted I was happy
with the draw and then he played 96 I
didn't understand it because
uh like I thought I have many many ways
to be much better
um
for example I thought um
instead of F6
uh I can let's say play
like Bishop D6 Ed
yeah instead of F6 Queen B4 is for
example probably he goes probably he'll
play C3 Queen D6 and try to find
compensation for three Pawns
um maybe he has
maybe he has enough I I thought this
wasn't enough for him either but okay F6
and my king goes to F7 seemed really
really clean to me
and I think he shouldn't take on C6 but
I I he can't Castle which is the main
issue right my queen on C4 stops him
from castling
and you mentioned uh just to fast
forward to the final position just to
blunder did he miss queen of Fate uh in
the final position yeah 100 uh he like
as soon as he
um picked up the Rook I think I made
some sort of expression and then he like
shook his head so I think he kind of
realized that immediately that queen of
Fate trans Queens like like Queen H7 I
thought
maybe bishop B2 is super accurate I just
need to consolidate like get my Bishop
to somewhere good
um
because I stopped Queen H5 which was his
only idea and if I get C4 Bishop on D3
for example it's just hopeless King F2 I
thought maybe he can try to get the Rook
to B1 but King F2 Bishop G4 Rook B1 I
can always put my queen on C7 or
something I thought
uh and I don't see how he's
like unless he he has some tactics it
just my pawns Will Roll right four pawns
is quite a lot
let me go back for the moment where he
played the queen A7 and event Rook B2 I
would be uh
interested how long did you see that
line did you see that Queen AAA taking
the Rook is losing completely or you
were just sure that it you at least have
a draw so when I played F6 I kind of saw
this
I thought it was winning uh
I mean it's like a very natural line I
mean he's he's taking taking on a seven
taking the Rook he's just capturing
everything and when when we actually got
here because I still have a choice of
let's say queen before and take it on D6
um I decided to like calculate it out
more or less to the end
I I think it's clear that black always
has a drawing hand like there's there's
absolutely no risk which makes it a very
easy decision but uh of course I I
realize that I'm also sort of probably
winning here so I don't want to spoil it
and
so let's say after Rook B2
I wasn't sure he would take the Rook I
thought he could play like Rook C1 but
you know he still can't castle and I can
always play either Rook f8 or I can try
to pick up the DePaul whenever I want
with Queen B4
uh
he's kind of not moving so I wasn't
worried
at least that like I'm much better maybe
winning and then he took the Rook I kind
of expected it
and the only thing I was considering
like I thought okay Bishop D2 is forced
because Rook D2 Queen C1
there's like one important detail here
which is that after Rook D2 Queen C1
King E2
I take on D2 take on H1
and uh queen d8 queen G2 and where was
King runs I always have a way to get to
the light squares like let's say King D1
I always have I mean I might have
multiple ways I might have a way to get
to B7 as well but but very simple is
Queen G4 and E5 right uh
I might even have a way to pick up his
d-pawn like maybe Queen G1 but once I
saw this I was I was pretty pretty
confident
and
and then I thought what he did is force
but H4 kind of surprised me I thought
Queen d8 was critical
this is what I was more expecting
I mean I figured there's like okay Queen
E4
um because I can't play Bishop B5 he
gets he gets the E Pawn and defense
against made so Queen E4 can get two is
forced now
I can pick up a Pawn on F4
uh we repeat the position let's say
queen F4 King E1
Queen E4 King F2
and so I wasn't sure if I I can provoke
G3 and then play Bishop B5 or play it
right now and I thought maybe I would
play it immediately because I didn't see
after Bishop B5 how he defends
uh
oh wait Bishop B5 is a blunder
what is a
um maybe rookie one Queen D4 rookie
three is is that possibly a draw
I've just uh been a bit naughty here
apparently H3 is okay for white but I
mean this is just a very engine like
defense so how do I do I provoke G3 like
with Queen H4 instead of Queen E4
and then I can get the same position
with the pawn on G3 maybe that's winning
um no I mean like with the King on
E1
yeah let's say
let's say kingy one Queen H4 G3 is
forced Queen E4 King F2 and now Bishop
B5
Yep this this is a yeah I wasn't sure if
I shouldn't provoke this G3 or not like
he made it easy for me because Queen d8
was still
uh still kind of tough and now a H3 his
King has nowhere to hide
and rookie won Queen D4 rookie three I
still thought it was like some
work to be done but I guess after I pick
up on D2 maybe just D4 yeah
or I oh I have Queen D1 Queen F1 even
okay yeah Queen D1 uh well everything
probably wins this one
so I would still have to find this uh
Queen H4 and but I kind of saw the idea
but I wasn't 100 sure
but all in all a smooth game Fabi and uh
now you've extended to your lead at the
top of the table feeling confident yeah
it's it's been going very well I didn't
expect today to go so well I really
thought uh that a draw would be a good
result
I mean like with black pieces and I was
actually looking forward to Armageddon I
was I mean it's it's fun I I like I
wasn't confident in Oregon but I thought
it'd be fun
and and uh yesterday you had you had a
rest day I mean how do you feel about
playing chess after these breaks is it
difficult to regain the momentum
no I I like the the rest day it's um I
don't think it breaks your momentum
because one day you still feel like
you're in in the like the mode for chess
um so I that it didn't feel like I was
let's say getting you don't get rusty
after one rest day but um but there's a
lot of preparation and potentially two
games every day so you it's it's easy to
lose energy so the rest days are are
quite nice
and will you reveal the design of your
sweater
how did you guys do uh well we didn't
win but but I don't know if like it was
ranked besides the winner
oh well we'll find out is it am I
allowed to say the winner or is this
some sort of secret
I think you're allowed I think you're
allowed to oh you well we can give it
away so it was it was Anisha noderbeck
their team and they came up with the
design where you have one Queen in the
middle and then it's surrounded by like
a million Pawns
and and the color or Kings
and uh they had a message or at least on
each had a message I'm not sure
um I'm not sure if I should say it
because maybe he wants to reveal the
message
and he probably does if you ask him at
some point but I'll I'll keep that a
secret for now okay then thank you very
much Fabi for joining us in the studio
and good luck in remaining games thank
you thank you
and in the meantime one classical game
still going on and that's between Magnus
Carlson and gukesh and of course we have
a big Armageddon game coming up between
mama jarv and Norbeck Abdus Surf and
that will be starting in approximately
the next two minutes
and uh should we dive in and have a peek
at this end game
yeah this this game has changed a lot
since we were last here between gokesh
and Magnus and it's been a one-way
traffic for most of it still the
equilibrium has really been Disturbed
but it's only black who has been doing
the running it's only black who can win
this Magnus trying his best to grind
down his young opponent and it's a queen
end game level number of Pawns but this
is where the white acorns really don't
make a great impression they are
completely canceled out by blacks one a
pawn so it's all about the king side
majority two versus one there if Queens
disappear black is simply winning but uh
Judith any chance for Magnus to win
while Queens remain on the board
it's a very interesting end game I must
say indeed the two a pawns is not giving
too much to White's position
the question is whether uh
cam black
be hiding with his King from the
Perpetual checks or if there is no
Perpetual check how he can improve his
position right because right now it's
black to move white is attacking the A5
while the E1 Queen is protecting it but
for now G3 for example would not give
anything extra for black because King H3
and the G3 Pawn would be more of a
weakness right now so black has to think
of somehow to improve his position the
question is for example
well the queen on B6 actually is very
well placed because it's attacking the
A5 Pawn at the same time it's also
attacking the F6 Pawn so now the queen
can't really move to some places the
king from G5 has to defend the pawn on
F6 the pawn cannot be moving to F5
probably because there is a starting
checks with queen d8 king F4 Queen D6
so it's very difficult right now for
black to continue the game Queen E5
seems to be the most logical move
and so from E5 it's defending
centralizing the queen is very important
in end game screen and the game
especially defending the F6 and the A5
and after that the king can be marching
ahead but the question is how to March
ahead because after Queen E5 if let's
say we dive into any line
then Queen E5 King H1 and if let's say
black goes King H4 what can simply go
Queen F2 and now I see a beautiful
stalemate idea Finn G3 yes okay in F6 we
have but can you imagine to play A3 if
the F6 probably A3 oh
in H2 G3
beautiful but of course Queen F6 is the
much simpler but I was wondering how I
can manage some stalemate setup study
like events
wow that's why they do say put your king
in the corner if you were born down
because sometimes there are still mating
ideas a nice resource there so it's very
difficult for black to to start playing
for a win right this is what the black
should be trying what about playing
Queen E5 and after King H1 to centralize
it to D5 the queen
because then I cover some very important
square like E8 so after that I can push
F5
and if Queen E3 check then King G6
and uh interesting do you think uh
ultimately that good cash will be able
to defend this tricky ending with under
one and a half minutes on the clock
that's a great question I'm not sure I'm
pretty sure that Magnus will give a
great headache yeah but I am I wanna yes
no
no no
[Laughter]
I guess I think he's a big favorite in
that one okay he's the ultimate Queen
end game expert and uh okay well we have
our third Armageddon appearing and it's
the game between Shakira mamajarth and
Nordic abdusotoff and we have to
remember that armored Again full format
white will have 10 minutes black will
have seven minutes they will get a one
second increment after move 40 and the
most important Point black will win with
a draw
early days in this one we've only had
nine moves it started out as a Queen's
Gambit declined and after the first
trade of Pawns just on the last turn
nordeback has jumped out with his Knight
trying to initiate even more exchanges
and manager says yes okay let's trade
off a set of knights so black is going
to be solid but white will have a bit
more space can he make anything of that
space advantage that is the big question
and okay there was a threat to ruin the
white porn structure so mama jaros just
simply drops back
this one looks like black is doing okay
to me
black is doing fine but white is doing
fine too so it's going to be I think a
tough game of course mama diaro will be
trying not so easy though probably he'll
come back my Bishop D3 Rook C1
optionally maybe at some point B4 black
obviously will not want to take on G
Street he wants to keep the tension over
there
it's not easy to gain Advantage for
white that's for sure but it's a game
but white does have a plan of just
simply lining up the rook and the Queen
on C2 and then penetrating onto C7 but
okay Mama Jeff is not a clinical player
he likes creativity he likes to go
forward and he attacks the queen
yeah and now the big question is how to
deal with this hit on the black queen
and he answers it immediately he drops
back any Bishop trades here would you
would think again uh get up to sort of
closer to that desired draw and I don't
really like what Shaq has done I've got
to say I don't understand this last move
it just feels felt like a one move
threat which is easily dealt with and
Abdul satorov he's going to be
completely fine surely maybe he has the
idea of repeating the moves this bishop
will drop to G3 and then second cloner
yeah as in many others that is true but
you are one move closer to that one
second increment
which okay there you go Bishop B7 on the
board I mean I agree with you it does
seem like a loss of tempo I mean my idea
was to go Queen C2 drop the bishop back
to D3
pressure on C7 but um the problem was
after this turf was not obliged to
repeat okay now he goes with this bishop
and uh okay marador but a lot of time on
the clock his three minute Advantage has
fizzled down to one and a half minutes
extra on the clock and look at this
black is breaking out in the center if
the pawn structure becomes symmetrical
if the D and C pawns disappear then you
would think there's not too much life
left there he needs something now over
the next five or six moves otherwise
nordebec has solved all of his opening
problems and okay he plays Bishop B5
some pressure on the Black Knight
maybe hinting that he might ruin the
black pawn structure if black doesn't
simplify in the center right now the
question is will Bishop F3 happened in
the game right now to eliminate the
Knight and the because if the queen
would take then C takes D4 he takes D4
that's that's not something black should
be afraid of but black takes it without
capturing on F3 on X on D4
captures for the Knight how the idea of
Knight C6 is in the air so that's why
nordebec plays 95.
nice F4
yeah F4 hitting that black knight is
committal but it's a manager of type of
move it's on the board kicking away the
Black Knights from its beautiful Square
in the center gaining a bit of time as
well you have to take these types of
risks and Armageddon absolutely now
Queen D5 is possible the intermediate
move before making a move with the
Knight
yup you could hit that pawn or G2 but
nope he drops back instead with his
Knight now the Black Knight is on a bad
Square it's on a bad circuit and this
gives white a little bit of leeway can
he create any pressure well Bishop C6
seems to be the most logical move though
maybe he does not want to make exchanges
at this situation
yeah again my major if we know him he
wants to play active chess okay he
activates that Queen therefore via A4
bit strange a bit offside you would
think that White Queen but still ideas
just as you mentioned that Judith the
white Bishop at some point will come and
neutralize Black's very powerful piece
on B7
well and the idea I believe that he
wants to bring his Rook to D1 so asking
the black queen where is it going to be
placing itself
and perhaps you have ideas of
E3 E4 as well now that the queen is out
there okay well big threat on the board
of Queen takes G2 and that has to be
defended and so that's why Mama jaraf
intercepts that diagonal
and I like what he's doing suddenly this
white knight is one of the most powerful
pieces on the board watch out for night
folks also this Pawn undercut under
watchful gays long term Black's Queen
lacking squares as well is about to get
hit by one of the white Rooks this one's
turning in White's favor surely while
the G6 Knight is really badly placed now
black is looking for counter chances but
the C6 Knight is incredibly powerful
yeah if you compare those two steeds
it's definitely the white piece on C6 C6
that dominates and also threats of
trapping this queen potentially okay the
black queen lacking squares but he's
holding things together for now
for the black queen is attacked she can
sit on E2 at least for now so holding
together by a thread now Abdul toroff
how to up the pressure for white where
Rook C two seems like a good option and
then doubling The Rook on the C file for
example so now white has several options
which is extremely tempting
yeah I like your one to kick the black
queen out of your camp out of your half
of the board and just double up stuck up
the Rooks but it's also tempting to go
rook fd1 and put pushing the queen to E2
and having The Rook all the way going to
D7 for example
it still has a Time Advantage remember
Dr if he's about to make this big
decision he plays Rook to C3 interesting
keeping the black queen where she is but
maybe threatening to trap her in
different ways
and notabeck has to decide how to
arrange the black pieces The Rook on A8
is terrible it's just stuck isn't there
a big threat of actually coming
retreating the Knight back to D4 and
then the Rook will come to D1
quite possibly
so various ideas of trapping this black
queen Behind Enemy Lines
another back I think he should just
Retreat her just get out the way before
you have to calculate too much and okay
he put his hand out and he retracted it
burning a lot of time on the clock
because if you go back let's say queen
D6 or queen D7 then Rook D1 and the
queen is also going to be pushed back
and Rook on C3 it's very nicely
defending the E3 pawn and later on maybe
the battery with Queen C2 can work in a
much more powerful way than if the Rook
would be still on C1 H5 on the board
really surprising nordeback solves his
back rank problems he gives the black
king some breathing space on H7 but it
doesn't really signal this start and
then attack this H5 move it feels like
he's just playing
well trying to play tricky chess here uh
hinting that maybe he'll play a move
like H4 later and Shaq needs to activate
his pieces he gets his remaining Rook
into the game watch out for some tricks
potentially on the C file nothing
threatened yet
as far as I can see but the black queen
really struggling for square she needs
to get out of Dodge and Rook C7 stopping
any Knight checks sensible move from
Abdus Torv and look he stands up checks
the board above the players the
electronic board above where the players
are sitting just to see how close he is
to getting that one second increment
three minutes left to make at least 14
moves before he gets one second it's
interesting that why is that one second
is so important exactly at this point
when he still has like what three
minutes
yeah I think it's just a sign of nerves
right yes yeah this is what I want to
point out it's a jump up from your chair
and look at his which move you're in
tension unbearable in the uh in the
auditorium and okay the black queen has
been kicked out Shaq maneuvering his
Rooks really sophisticated stuff
and he wants to kick back the black
queen even further
the white king is a bit exposed though
so watch out for some counter attacks a
bit later on if abdusatorov can survive
the coming moves now the black Rooks
also piled up everything on the sea file
right now why tonight is C2 threatening
with Knight E7 mm-hmm
I think he's gonna play it Queen back
and you threaten all sorts of tricks on
the longest line starting with a night
jump
well the Knight is under threat so it
does need to be protected
your knight if you Retreat the night all
the Rooks come off the board and the
drawing margin increases for black but
now Knight A7 is possible actually it's
a pawn sacrifice
oh is he gonna play it no Auto is not
playing it
he didn't want to have his Rook that's a
big thread on the board
yeah but black and go King H7 and
threatening with Knight E7
now he wants to cement that White Knight
on C6 he's advancing his Queen side
pawns Shakura here if he gets a pawn to
B5 it's going to be really hard for
black to break out of the bind Mama Duro
I believe he is feeling comfortable in
in this position having his Knight on C6
and stabilizing it in the next move with
B5
and that H5 bone can be sometimes
vulnerable right
at some point
yeah I think it's a bit Airy as well
okay he tries to trade off these Knights
chakra surely here is going to submit
that night by pushing his B Pawn
he's making a move I know he attacks the
queen first
wow yeah but that's not Queen they can
just see that by the evaluation bar that
was a blunder
what's happened there oops
or suddenly
okay a whole strum of moves and it looks
like white is fine the evaluation part
on Black's side though what are we
missing
I don't see it looks like white is fully
in control still
well okay E4 hitting the Black Knight
now we'll see a trade of Pawns
we'll come to that point later on I
think because the moves are coming thick
and fast
and now still everything to play for in
this position as Black's King is rather
shaky and white has a dominance there in
the center
yes and uh just while the tension mounts
let's quickly jump back to this position
Rook D4 was indeed a huge blunder
because after Rook takes C6 black would
have been winning there's a counter
attack against the White Queen no time
to take black screen and a check would
have been met by a block with the Black
Knight really strong move here after
Rook takes this is trouble for the white
king next move actually black will
either take the Rook or even just jump
in with the other Black Brook with a
Killer attack missed opportunity for
nordebec Abdus let's get back to the
game however and uh this is the current
position everything to play for but
white is breaking through white has a
strong Knight and the E6 Pawn huge
weakness
is Laboratories gonna do it
well I think it will be very hard to
hold it because there are too many
weaknesses Knight E5 G6 is a weakness
uh Rook E5 also very tempting to
maneuver it to G5
and 95 F5 options G4 options absolutely
and of course you can always pile up on
the E6 Pawn this is in complete control
mode for Shakura and chakra of course
has a big time Advantage as well Abdus
tour of now under 50 seconds on the
clock he will be getting a one second
increment now I think but it's too late
because the G6 Pawn is falling off in a
very bad circumstances because next move
is Knight E5 now my Maduro looks out
what move they are but uh
yeah he has that luxury manager with
almost three minutes on the clock he can
afford to take a zoom out of the
position and he knows that he is
dominating he knows he's got a
checkmating attack incoming and wow
desperation from Abdul store of giving
up on the G6 Pawn running with the King
oh what a nice play from Mama jar of
doesn't even take the pawn said attacks
the rook and going to grab that G6 Pawn
with the Knight
let's go and there you see it nordebec
resigns and Mama jaraf walks away with
one and a half points and a victory in
Armageddon Experience One
with a few twists and turns away exactly
but he seen before many this kind of
things yeah in the end of the turf just
didn't have the sufficient time on the
clock to spot that one opportunity to
turn things around and a manager
deservedly takes the win
oh that means there's just one game
outstanding and that is between good
cash and Magnus Carlson and the players
are on seconds
What's Happening Here
well both spawns are running running and
one step away from being a queen but it
seems like it's going to be a perpetuate
check
probably Magnus goes all the way to D7
C8
and we're going to see a playoff unless
someone is blundering but I think it's
very hard to blunder
yeah as long as you don't allow the
enemy porn to promote it should be safe
when kukesh is looking for the win he's
got the extra Pawn you can see on his
body language he's really interested
here if he wants to draw he just moves
the white king closer to the black pawn
but
okay he gives another check
a few seconds left Magnus has lost
control we talked about those two a
pawns could we see a scenario where
white has one a pawn remaining in the
queen end game that one would go down to
the wire I think the G2 Pawn is too
strong besides that even if there is an
exchange of A7 and G2 only one A2 will
not do any harm to Black and Magnus
keeping his King as close as possible
we're seeing a repetition and the
handshake it is a draw we'll see more
chest today with an Armageddon
well for armageddon's today and uh it's
interesting who do you think will be
more satisfied with that draw
fully he was in trouble in that Queen
end game at the beginning at least
before it turned around Magnus losing
control well I'll go cash probably he's
more happy
generally speaking when you know you
made mistakes none of them are happy and
now they want to focus on the next one
you can see that Magnus is unhappy that
things were not going exactly the way he
was expecting he looks like a bit tired
and annoyed
this happened
well he will have 20 minutes to recover
as the players will be playing the final
Armageddon of the day
it will be kukash with the white pieces
having 10 minutes on the clock whereas
Magnus will have seven minutes and draw
odds oh more exciting chess
oh this is going to be extremely
exciting that's that's for sure that
go cash will show that he wants to win
by any means and and Magnus will fight
it fight it out that he he wants to win
the match okay and I'm gonna put
everyone on the spot here who do you
think is going to win the Armageddon
I'll say Magnus uh maybe with a draw but
Magnus is black I think it's the
favorite
he's the favorite burger casual oh
I could split the tie
you know after all it was gookash who
beat Magnus on his 17th birthday but
anyway we're gonna leave you on a
cliffhanger there as we're gonna take a
short break and see you in a few minutes
[Music]
some of you may remember when puzzle
Rush launched it blew the Chess World up
and it happened literally right in time
for the World Chess Championship in 2018
and all those pieces just came together
of like when it was just awesome to see
of course it was excited it was a new
feature which we hadn't done in years
and it was a really good one and we're
like uh we like grew chess we're done
like how cool is that I remember the
word saying like guys like after it came
down
early early 2019 like we all need to
reset let's think about how we're gonna
add more features what could maybe be
something
close to puzzle Rush again because we
are never going to see growth like that
for chess again in 2018 puzzles because
the other thing that Serendipity with
was the world championship our first
feature in three years God I get anxiety
it was our first feature like those were
the dark years that Eric and I joke
about there were tears during that time
it was hard it was tough but then like
here goes puzzle Rush here comes the
world championship and here comes a
fateful dinner where I had queenies
shout out to you Hikaru take me to that
small restaurant the Isle of Man the
British Isles because hicaro picks it
because the car was a bit of a foodie
for those who don't know and that was
the dinner where I told a car that I
thought he could be the ninja of Chess
and that maybe if he gave streaming a
chance he might be surprised I spent two
and a half hours explaining what was the
online content ecosystem to Hikaru and
Sunil and Hikaru Embraces streaming
hardly because puzzle Rush was such a
fun feature to stream sort of not the I
don't want to say the chipping point
because there were so many incredible
streamers who were committing to what
would become the future of what we now
know is like this incredible ecosystem
online the chess bras were like the ogs
of of committing to it you know um at
least as far as having a fully a fully
focused switch brand right and there
were there were so many others but but
we all knew and Eric Hanson and I had
talked a lot at the time like we knew
like the category needed a Hikaru and we
knew that it was going to be something
that was going to take us to the next
level but I think partly the reason
Hikaru committed is because it was so
easy and fun because of puzzle rush like
that was it and then the world
championship viewers we were raiding the
chess bras and Hikaru every single day
with Peak viewership for the chess
category and it was like the Chess World
peaked yeah it appeared the end of 2018.
that was that was what you asked about
right we're talking if that's all we're
talking that was in that was that was
the high point of Chess that was it but
I do remember the first time Magnus
played on our site I remember that
feeling and I remember the Goosebumps
going on my arms of like oh my goodness
that's like yeah okay I mean there's no
better chess player in the world who's
gonna ever play well maybe in the future
one day but that was like the thing I
remember the moment where I was like oh
my gosh we have a Grand Master on our
site he's like kicking everyone's ass
he's just winning all his games what
super strong Grand Master is this
foreign
it was somebody cheating and we're like
oh my gosh how are we going to deal with
this it's hard to explain the whole
process but immediately right then we're
like this is going to be a make or break
for our future we have to invest here
and immediately started hiring like
statistician built an amazing team
around this and we've invested so much
time money and resources just to protect
this game that we love we immediately
knew how dangerous this could be and
remember that very first cheater was
such a painful experience to see so it's
been at the core of what we've done and
it's challenging because it's not
preventable
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
portion of round four of Norway chess
and if you've just joined us I'm your
host Ivanka houska and as always it's
been such a wonderful pleasure to be
here calling all the action alongside
Grand Masters Judy poga and David Howell
oh it's been a very fascinating day
today very tense at times but it also
some amazing games I'm like thinking
especially of Fabiana caruana defeating
I'm not Shakira he's coming next alireza
fuja yeah that game was definitely the
game of the day and I think we can call
it or from my end I can call it also
maybe the game of the tournament so far
because I'm expecting some more more
stuff there but we had other interesting
games it was not so much firework on
other games but we still have some very
nice moments yeah
yeah and I completely agree I think
we'll look back at this one game uh if
Fabiana wins the tournament which he
looks like uh he's a big favorite to do
now we'll look back on this game as the
moment that he kind of stormed ahead and
kind of asserted his control uh here in
Norway chess just opening preparation
combined with great calculation combined
with uh kind of Killer Instincts from
Fabi as he showed us when he came to the
studio it was uh nice to see but either
way it's been a great day and lots of
Armageddon today
certainly lots of armageddon's we've had
four armageddon's and we're gonna go
into our fourth one with Magnus Carlson
and young gukesh but someone who just
won their Armageddon was a chakra
mamajarov who just defeated nordebec
abdusotoff let's hear more from shakuria
second audio managed to take the Half
Point extra with white uh how would you
summarize Armageddon uh oh okay I mean
tournament is going not very well but
still to win some match is very good I
mean I pay for for much to win to lose
but I lose in classical and cannot win
any games I don't win any games in
classical I mean
um if it was just normal I mean
I hope
I can win some games in classical we
look forward to seeing in stock thank
you thank you very much
and that we had the thoughts of Shaq and
Shaq of course is formidable and let's
take a recap of today's scores and we
saw that Hikaru Nakamura defeated Anish
Gary in the Armageddon it was Wesley so
who was superb over orientari also in
Armageddon but the star of the round has
to be Fabiana Corona with his
resplendent win over alireza farouza and
in other matches chakra mamajorov one of
the most creative Grand Masters around
and still one result outstanding yet to
be played well it was interesting to see
Mama jarro that you could see that he
has mixed feelings about the situation
the standing right now of the uh this
event because he's kind of a little bit
unhappy that he didn't he can't do the
right way in the classical game and of
course he knows that Armageddon is ups
and downs and you can make blunders of
course he was very happy to collect that
extra half a point for today but he's in
eighth place so he will need to notch up
some victories in the classical games
having said that chakra actually almost
won Norway chess 2022 last year
and it was neck and neck with Magnus
right until the very end yeah
unfortunately for those two uh this year
Ivanka we see an eighth and Ninth Place
there's neck and neck again but this
time towards the bottom of the table and
we should mention that this is uh before
taking into account today's uh final
game between gokish and Magnus but even
if Magnus does get the maximum one and a
half points even if he does end up on
four and a half out of 12. he's six
whole points behind the lead at the
early stage we're not halfway yet but
surely it's going to be tough to catch
up you need to win pretty much all your
classical games at this point to catch
up with uh Fabiano on a streak with a
four point lead at the top of the table
over the field and how does one shake
things up
and these types of situations
well it's getting more and more
difficult situation from looking at it
from magnus's point of view I think I
think the most important thing is to to
get balance with yourself and to calm
down not to think about that I have to
win because it never works for me unless
I was in a mastering situation and right
now it's uh it's kind of a mustering
situation if he wants to win the
tournament but I think Magnus also wants
to find himself that he again hungry
enough and and can make decisions choose
openings and go all the way to convert
his his knowledge understanding and
really to win a game where he can show
that I'm better than you yeah the
certainly matter of Pride and for you
David is also about balance
yeah it's uh about balance it's about
getting lucky it's about taking your
chances taking massive risks and just
things falling in your favor
um I mean I never really competed
against such a huge field uh that often
in my career and uh yeah it's gonna be
difficult for those players kind of
chasing Fabi now to uh yeah to see any
scenario in which he falls back they
just have to kind of be consistent and
hope that at some point
um yeah he does prove that he's fallible
proof that he's humid and uh you know uh
Magnus very well David So how do you
think he will be feeling especially
after his game in the classical where it
felt like he was working his end game
magic magic yeah
um I do know Magnus very well and we saw
body language there not positive he was
shaking his head a lot at the end of the
game he will feel the missed opportunity
uh We've mentioned it a couple of times
this tournament but I did this chessable
course with Magnus uh about grinding the
art of kind of winning long long end
games and he did everything perfectly up
to a point against kokesh he had an
advantage maybe not decisive he was
never winning but he made the mistake of
rushing towards the end kukesh had one
minute at some point Magnus had over 10
minutes and Magnus kind of forced the
issue he went into a forcing line uh we
might look at it in a moment he gave up
his pawn and he allowed gokish to
calculate his way out of trouble in
those situations I think an on-4 Magnus
would have just sat there patient
patiently just waited maybe 20 moves
then pushed upon or waited until gokesh
was down to a mere seconds and then
initiated uh the forcing play so it
feels like something not just quite
right and from my own experience if I'm
not informed I also tend to rush things
so just slightly off at the moment
Magnus not quite at his uh usual
elevated high standards I think this is
a very important point that patience is
one of the most important thing that you
have to have when you play these long
games and when you really want to
when the drawish and the games
especially
yeah that was the perfect example of a
no risk end game he could have taken but
now he has to win it in Armageddon all
over again
yes and uh well we see our producer
trolling David
thank you for that feature chat Vic I
love sitting in the back of magnus's
streams even if uh commentating is yeah
slightly more fun slightly more
fulfilling I take myself slightly more
seriously as a chess player when I'm
commentating like this
and okay
Armageddon time who do you think has the
edge here so we've kind of the
psychological Edge and let's remind
ourselves of format oh and take a look
at that
cash is already sat there at the board
getting focused was this part of your
pre-game ritual to turn up early sit at
the board visualize what is going to
happen
I was always a person to show a few
minutes before the game game of the
start
well in Rapid of course or Blitz
obviously but also in classical I was
always few minutes ahead I wanted to
have everything done I make my Youtube
ritual of course like all the players
and I'm kind of getting into the focus
yeah I wish I had your professionalism
imagined it I just can't manage my time
well during the games or before the
games I find it hard to turn up early I
don't know what it is no matter when the
round starts I always tend to arrive a
minute or two late but uh of course when
it's zero tolerance I guess true unless
you really Force chess players to be uh
punctual they rarely are but you're in
good company David Magnus rarely arrives
on time
Gary Kasparov never arrived on time I
mean he did that for a reason to avoid
photographers and I I'm pretty sure I've
seen other Grand Masters and I do
remember someone giving me the advice
that it was good to arrive late because
when you shook hands you would be
standing and they would be sitting
psychological tricks mind games
that is too smart for me
[Laughter]
it is on the player's Minds though I
know Magnus uh yeah he's aware of these
things of these little psychological
ploys especially in Blitz and Rapid
games in classical it doesn't tend to
have too much effect but there we see
the handshake Magnus standing when it
happened will that be uh a sign of
things to come in the game will Magnus
be on top I Want To Praise kokesh though
he looks so focused and we're off it's a
King's Pawn opening Magnus does he know
that he starts the game with seven
minutes he's just adjusting his pieces
losing valuable seconds here and he
eventually plays E5
what will we see earlier we saw a
Italian game and it's a repeat of the
classical game the classical clash
between these two Magnus happy with his
opening there seemingly Judah are you
surprised to see Magnus repeat we
thought he was in trouble a bit uh
earlier on in the classical well I think
the troubles he had
he he not considered necessarily that it
was so serious and probably he
discovered how he is going to be
debating
in this position
okay and Magnus has deviated indeed he's
pushed his Pawn to A6 and dropped back
with his dark squared bishop and this is
where surely the importance of having
seconds on site to do the homework to do
the preparation uh is invaluable it's
Priceless clearly Magnus has had someone
helping him and uh he's gone to check
this opening and okay finally black
castles is very different from earlier
though well at the at this point for
example in this tournament I think it is
very important for the players to have a
second because for sure the seconds are
going to be taking a look already during
the game what kind of ideas they have
for the Armageddon if they get that
point and of course Magnus has his
second over here so that that is a lot
of help I think mentally also that you
get an advice and then you're on your
own but still you have someone who
checked it and gives the approper advice
yeah and I was getting flashbacks and I
was thinking I've seen this position
before and of course it's uh very
similar to one of magnus's games against
Wesley so
yeah the problem with the Italian game
is I always get flashbacks I always get
deja vu and then it turns out it's not
this exact position I've seen before
it's just something that looks almost
identical
and also it's also pretty okay I think
that he's repeating the same line
because it was very difficult for Magnus
to create something that he can play for
a win right but at this point the draw
and the Victory is the same amount of
point he can gain so usually I don't
think he's worried too much that he
should be losing any of the game yeah
when Magnus needs to be solid he tends
to thrive that is yeah going back to
basics for him and we see a night trade
set of Pawns have left the board as well
who are these exchanges favor Intruder I
thought the black will be going to d8
but of course as draw is enough
and maybe this is possible because after
Rook B5 black would be going probably
just rook fb8 and C6 would be
unavoidable
so basically Magnus just wants to
simplify the position make it easy
draw the game
yeah he looks a massive favorite to do
that and I think go cash is missed a
trick here I think he just assumed he
could take the spawn because
the other option is just to trade the
Rooks off and black has no problems at
all there if anyone's better it's going
to be black with the open file if you
take this Rook now the question is uh I
have a crazy idea it can white go Rook
B5 Rook fb8 D4 and then on C6 somehow D
takes E5 or Rook E5 sacrifice and giving
up an exchange with interesting
circumstances well let's jump in this
could be a potentially key moment if
gukesh doesn't get ambitious doesn't
gamble right now he might never get a
chance in this Armageddon root takes B5
Judith and he's taken and he's taken
we're expecting Rook here threatening a
discovered attack Bishop takes F2 check
is a threat winning the white Rook next
move so you want to block The Bishop's
threat and after C6 something on E5
either Pawn takes or Rook takes what
Magnus played G5 instead first and after
Bishop G3
probably he will be playing Knight D7
that maybe Knight D7 can be strong
97 threatening to trap this rook and
also defending the E5 Pawn mm-hmm
this looks strong this white Rook now
trapped and this happened on the board
thank you cash striking out in the
center now look at this
D4 on the board he's going to give up
the exchange after Pawn to C6 he's going
to sacrifice here and take this Pawn in
the center he's got two pawns for the
exchange here but look at this what
happens he went F6 and now D5 is
possible or taking on E5 between D5 so
The Rook maybe will save itself
decides to actually trade Pawns in the
middle
and it does look like The Rook is going
to be saved
but it has come at the cost of white
locking in their own Bishop
this one looks like great compensation
for black as well you mentioned at
Ivanka this bishop locked in for white
this Rook potentially locked in even if
it doesn't get trapped even if it
doesn't fall off the board it's not
necessarily greatly placed and yeah
anything could still happen in this
position Magnus picking up the pace only
a minute down now I think rule D5 should
be the move to save The Rook for the
moment
I was also one yeah I agree with you but
I also wondered about C4 C5 if you're in
a must win situation yeah I was also
wondering of C4 and after C6 you would
be capturing the bishop I guess thanks
and C5 and this is what we see on the
board you're a prophet Ivanka it's
happening kukesh needs to gamble and
he's ready to give up material in order
to do so I thought it's not going to be
enough for him
but I understand that he's going to this
direction
so good C4 that shows zero fear at all
we were talking about that earlier the
benefit of being a young player you
believe in all of your calculations you
never doubt you never think about what
could go wrong and Magnus looking away
maybe frustrated that his young opponent
is going straight for him
not backing down
C5 is imminent breaking this black pawn
chain if this Pawn chain falls apart
white minor Pieces come in I have also a
little Deja Vu like when Magnus played
against Wesley so the armagedda on it so
somehow a little similar that Magnus had
in not such a good position and then he
was flashing out some very interesting
moves with material down and he was
making Magic
and uh I'm not sure who's trying to work
the magic here kukesh has given up his
Rook for Black's bishop and wow Magnus
body language does not look positive
suddenly whites won a second Pawn level
material who's better here and why
he's not exactly the most happy I guess
Magnus but I don't see what is really
wrong with his position
26 Rook D1 I mean there is a certain
Harmony to Black's position and whereas
white will be always pressured by the
thought that his Bishop on G3 is just
trapped
oh and question mark for magnus's last
move it looks like the evaluation E5 can
be captured I was
Knight takes Pawn is possible here yeah
Bishop takes or Knight takes I'm not
sure if Bishop takes there might have
been Rook takes F3 so Knight takes on
the board this utilizes the fact that
wow missed opportunity according to the
computer but this looks clever if
everything is captured then later on
there would have been a nasty Queen
check on C4 Magnus instantly reacts with
Rook to A2
was this a trap has he tricked gokesh
well Queen C4 is still possible having a
lot of pawns for white three pawns for
an exchange
yeah but there's something happening on
F2 we had Maurice whoa kukeshi has given
up his Queen
whoa wow
or maybe very uncomfortable position for
black wow what a game Knight C5 E5 E6
brilliant played by the youngster this
Pawn is running both of white spawns are
running
this is scary for Magnus Black's Queen
alone cannot fight the whole white Army
Magnus needs something
sacrificing a queen
for a bishop and a knight
unbelievable I don't think it would have
even entered my radar and what happened
with this G3 bad Bishop right it's just
protecting the amazing DC exposed spawn
supporting this Pawn defending F2 this
Bishop's holding everything together for
white and bang bang just two more moves
if white gets the pawn to E6 it's game
over very frustrating and very difficult
position to play it with black I guess
Magnus is going to be pinning his hopes
on establishing a blockade on the light
squares and
is threatening the white Rook there are
back rank problems for gokesh right now
he needs to take a timeout maybe improve
the white Rook okay one
okay F3 what a nice move protecting it
with the bishop
why is Bishop doing all of the work in
this game
and what can Magnus do now the black
Rook is stuck there are all sorts of
threats White's e-pawn in some cases can
advance at the same time I'm not sure
about this F3 with Rook a true K2 there
is a Target on G2
as a counter attack counter play
potentially it takes a while though does
black have that time the white pawns
look so scary white is threatening in
some lights just drop the White Knight
back as well gain time against that
black queen and then the pawns will roll
yeah
what again I do like that comment we
need more games like this I
wholeheartedly agree I mean fire on the
board Magnus now ticking close to two
minutes on the clock whereas figure cash
five minutes and Magnus grabbing the
pawn it's a big question for good cash
can he push the e-pawn to its
destination what a game
I think you have to take your time out
maybe move that white knight out the way
first but either way not just the speed
with which he's playing just the way
he's kind of moves to the pieces she
reminds me of a young Anand from the
videos I've seen just yeah
E6 giving up the Knight and the E7 and
then the black Rook moves
the problem is uh these but where do you
move D7 let's see then D7 and then
there's a queen D4 at the end so white
cannot push yet wow H3 taking it yeah I
like that I I had this in mind King go
to H2 The Rush
no need to rush and Magnus is going for
your plan Judah he needs counterplay
that's the only way to do it right
I would go Knight G4 somehow so to
try to push E6 though after that King E6
comes already white can go wrong easily
yeah both sides can go wrong Magnus
under two minutes but he gains increment
in seven moves time the White Knight
needs to get out of the way for the
pawns to roll
it's a race I don't believe that Magnus
can create enough counterplay if white
is accurate but how to be accurate with
only a few minutes on your clock so many
tempting moves
why tonight has to retreat surely that
looks like step one yeah but the
question is where because wherever
you're going to be retreating here night
King E6 will be positioning itself maybe
Knight E4 with the idea of Bishop F2 and
Knight C5
but I also understand this decision to
play D7 because he's very much afraid
that Rook A2 is
coming
time to give a check to the king
centralize the queen
the black queens can centralize you can
maybe make an argument for blockading
with the black king as well uh lots of
options here for Magnus
one and a half minutes now though
such a hard position to defend
extremely dangerous
follows your advice Ivanka that's a
check
Queens are best in the center of the
board
yeah we'll wipe drop the bishop back to
block or just hide his King he hides the
king
okay and the big question is are the
pawns racing down that's why the king
steps forward and blockades the pawn and
Magnus down on time
just over one minute left and the
position is so wild but right now it
seems like black stabilized a little bit
because the bishop cannot move because
of the E5 might be under attack and
anyway that it doesn't have a space the
Knight cannot move now which is very
important because the D7 Pawn is under
attack so it's not so easy for white to
continue
Rook C1 may be to attack it's very
difficult to make the right move I
believe
Magnus taking a sip of his water there
I'm getting flashbacks as well when
kukesh beat Magnus in the Norwich has
Blitz just a few days ago that was also
a crazy material imbalance that was a
queen for Knight and two pawns and uh
here it's like Queen for Bishop Knight
and two pawns it's uh crazy how that
game is being mirrored right now and
okay indecision there hesitation from
kukash
what's he gonna do it feels like he's
gonna move his Rook
where to put that piece is he gonna go
attack that black queen is he going to
slide The Rook to C1 as you drew did
mention there
I like the comment in the future chat
kukesh is in tile mode
but tar finishes things off that's the
difference how is gokesh gonna finish
this game
he needs to get that win remember a draw
not sufficient Rook C1 met calmly by C5
blacks got his passport as well some
source of counter play Rook B1 trying to
get to B6
yeah and then the black pawn will roll
so complicated
yeah the pressure is on and cash now
ticking to under one minute and 40
seconds
um is the time
to kind of step back with the Knight and
pin all hopes on the e-pawn because
White's Rook is just not joining in the
action he does indeed step back with the
Knight but now the d-pawn drops you feel
that that was White's pride and joy
really but maybe he needed to be done
I like actually this move from the
perspective that Bishop F2 after Rook C5
will be very strong but of course it's a
shame that the people part D7 Plus Pawn
is gone oh and Magnus not actually
capturing that pawn oh he means business
and instead pushing the pawn to C4
wow
but now Rook D2 Rook C2 then Rook A1
right
The Rook slides up then black can
actually get back uh down behind on
White's first rank with Rook A1 and
queen G1 ideas okay Knight D6 he's
jumping in can Magnus keep his Pawn
alive or is it time finally to capture
that scary white d-pawn look at kakesh
looking kind of taking that Peak up at
the screen now he's getting one second
increment in a few moves time
Let's Plays under the one minute mark
no way back from here it's going to be
Eternal time travel I think I would just
take that pawn too scary I know Magnus
is in a confident mood I think he's
going to push the pawn on C3
then I'd be five oh you're right
and no it comes back
oh maybe that pawns life was short-lived
after all
and Rule these three structuring big
threat Magnus has to move his kick okay
one will be able under
what is he oh okay I thought he was
going to put his King on a bad Square
dab he Retreats out of the way of any
night checks C6 very powerful
still threats on the board Magnus moving
his Queen away
and black is on the verge of going on a
counter attack but whoa the evaluation
bar leaps up there is now a win for
gakesh apparently E6 is a winning move
right now pushing the white pawn and
black and Bishop B5 yeah Black's King is
caught in the crossfire oh that would
have been amazing net but he misses it
go cash
black queen comes back now but he's
still putting the pressure on still
threats Rook D2 threatened now penny
that black queen to its king
um Magnus less than 10 seconds less than
five seconds oh
getting a one second increment that is
nothing
I feel that maybe that was the one
moment that good cash could have cashed
in and suddenly he's repeating with this
bishop the black wriggling behind
counter play the white king not safe you
see the relief of Magnus look at the
body language oh for a moment I'm in
safety but he only has three seconds
left on the clock and they'll only gets
a one second increment but on the board
on the board
well there's not just the board though
Bishop check but now the other white
Pawn has disappeared all of White's
winning chances are falling with the
fall of his pawns and okay a bunch of
quick moves
wow blunder tonight on E6 oh and take a
look at that clock you can cash with
just one second remaining
Magnus takes it and walks away with an
Armageddon Victory oh what a crazy game
amazing they saved the best to last
yeah kukash was just a few accurate
moves away from taking a historic
victory in a beautiful game it would
have been he made such a great decisions
and unexpected and surprised Magnus in
several times and sacrificing the queen
it was just such a perfect idea he took
the risk he knew that he has no other
option than to give up the exchange and
he took that pawn
because somehow Magnus was careless we
can say he was just playing he thought
it's going to be simplifying and then
from Rook B5 it really took off for for
gukash
yeah it would have ended up in all of
the books that went by gokesh if he had
uh spotted the way to convert the
advantage but in the end of Magnus too
quick too tricky too strong and uh yeah
this would have been a great learning
experience but he's so good already at
17 go cash almost a masterpiece in the
making but there we have today's scores
it was a victory for Magnus Carlson and
he takes one and a half points and it
was armageddon's nearly all around
Hikaru Nakamura being Victorious Wesley
so Victorious and chakra mamajarov also
winning against nordebec Abdul sotorov
but the hero of the round has to be
Fabiana carono who scored an amazing win
against Ali Reza fuja and take a look at
that ten and a half points out of 12. it
looks like Fabiano is running away with
the tournament he kind of Hikaru
Nakamura in second place with just six
and a half points out
six points and at the bottom of the
table I mean some big names there Magnus
Carlson in just eighth place and Shakura
mamajov who nearly won the tournament
last year lying in Ninth Place
oh
we were in for a spectacle today I think
absolutely absolutely I picked two games
and those two games I got the maximum
out of it in the Magnus game and also
alireza Fabiano they were just amazing
yeah and we're happy chess fans today
what was your favorite moment a
I think it's that final game I mean Fabi
well played to him taking that classical
Victory but that final game which just
had everything and uh tomorrow's
matchups uh okay we have Magnus Carlsen
against Anish giri Fabiana Carolina
tournament leader against chakra
mamajarov and other big encounters which
one stands out for you Judith I'm very
curious about the top two games what we
see on the screen Magnus against Anish
that will be very interesting for me
finally how can Magnus make himself
really a tiger lion whatever to make a
smooth very convincing game and of
course Fabiano mamajarov that will be
very exciting because we see that
Fabiano is just a killer so far in
mamajaro of no matter how good or bad
their mixed form is he can always make a
huge mess on the board and he also a
person who has incredible ideas yeah
absolutely and for you David what are
you eagerly anticipating all of it but
I'm looking out for our fourth
commentator in his game tomorrow to see
whether he can close that gap on Fabiano
hikaru's had a good tournament steady
tournament uh he seems really happy
right now and yeah can he catch up
that's the big question for me yeah and
uh what are your final thoughts of the
day
oh that's uh we all need another rest
day it's been so much action
the players return inspired didn't they
I think it's heating up I mean we are
entering into the middle of the
tournament right this was around the
four and tomorrow we are turning to the
second part of the tournament so it is
getting already clear who is the leader
who is trying to catch up and who are
what kind of form everybody is so now
only huge surprises has to happen yeah
to see something a big difference in the
very top yeah but it's a very tough
event and of course someone starts
winning classical game then things can
turn around absolutely anything can
happen and like you say the players came
with a lot of energy for their
Armageddon matches I would say I mean
but what a brilliant day of Chess it's
been spectacular so far so I'm going to
wish you a good night and thank you all
for watching and see you all tomorrow at
5 PM Central European Time bye-bye
foreign